Wollen wir anfangen?
Alle zwei Wochen die gleiche Frage. Ja, wir wollen anfangen.
Und ich nehme an, Dennis, Max spricht in dem Sinne einfach für dich.
I'm in.
Du bist dabei. Hallo. Wir sind's wieder. Die drei von der Tankstelle.
Oh, der Max kriegt hier voll die Updates rein. Ich will auch Updates.
Na, ich hab hier grad ein neues System drauf installiert.
Was?
Ich hab hier grad ein neues System drauf.
Ah, genau. Erstes Thema. Max hat einen neuen Computer.
Ja.
Haben wir schon gesagt, was das hier überhaupt für eine Sendung ist? Nicht, dass die Leute sich hierher verlaufen haben in unseren Podcasts und glauben, sie würden jetzt schlaflos in München hören wollen.
Wir sind doch hier bei Bits und so, oder?
Nee, wir sind hier bei...
Schlaflos in Prenzlberg.
Schlaflos in Prenzlauer Berg.
Wenn man noch genug mag, trinken wir noch auf jeden Fall.
Mobile Max, genau. Und wir waren gestern ein bisschen schlaflos. Na ja, nicht sehr. Aber es lief eine Weile, denn wir haben gestern unser erstes tolles Hörertreffen gemacht.
Hörertreffen.
Und? Wie fandet ihr es? Der Kerl hinter der Theke.
Mit der Brille?
Nee, der nicht. Ja, ist ein nettes Café, kann ich nur empfehlen, das Übereck. Nee, war auf jeden Fall gut besucht, 20 Leute oder so? Ja, das hat mich nicht gezählt.
Ich hab's irgendwann ganz am Anfang mal gezählt, da waren wir so 15 insgesamt. Da warst du noch nicht mal da und dann ist, glaub ich, gerade so. Und dann sind ja noch ein paar gekommen.
Ja, es waren ungefähr so 20 Leute.
Und der Typ, der da so am Rand saß, ich weiß am Ende jetzt auch, warum der so am Rand saß.
Der hatte keinen Mac. Ach, der, der da noch auf dieser Empore saß, der hat da irgendwie so seinen Stammplatz. Ja, also der sitzt nicht immer, aber wenn er da ist, dann sitzt er da.
Der gehört gar nicht dazu. Ach so, deswegen durfte der Tisch auch nicht verrückt werden.
Genau. Ja, das ist ein Laden mit Tradition. Den gibt's schon ganz lange. Und das ist noch so eine richtig schöne Ost-Berliner Spelunke, zwar auch Postwende, aber halt ganz früh aufgemacht und schon immer an dem Ort.
Postwendend, ja?
Genau, postwendend. Naja, auf jeden Fall war das sehr nett. Es sind eine Menge Leute gekommen und wir haben eine kleine Vorstellungsrunde gemacht. Es war alles sehr schön und prima. Und dann hat Tim alle ausgefragt. Ich hab nicht alle ausgefragt. Naja, ich komme immer schnell in so einen CAE-Modus, wenn jemand was Interessantes sagt.
Wenn wir mal was Interessantes sagen?
Na, das passiert ja selten.
Das wäre echt ein Versehen gewesen.
Nein, wenn die Hörer was Interessantes sagen.
Ach so, du bist im CAE-Modus.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall eine Menge gelernt und wir haben auch das eine oder andere an Vorschlägen einkassiert. Es waren auch sehr interessante Detailgespräche, die wir alle dann noch mal unabhängig voneinander... Alle haben sich irgendwie über deine Hardware gebeugt, oder?
Die macht natürlich neugierig, wenn da so eine offene Platine rumliegt.
Das war deine tolle Uhr.
Die jetzt gerade zu Hause läuft. Ich mach grad wieder nen Test.
Und du wurdest aber auch über irgendwas gebeten, sagst du vorhin?
Nö, manche Leute haben sich halt interessiert, mit welcher Software, ob man dann so ne... Also da ist halt ein Atmel-Chip drauf, den muss man ja auch irgendwie programmieren und man muss ja auch irgendwie sein Programm dann auf diesen Chip draufkriegen. Und was ich benutze ist Data-Kit von Atmel selbst, das SDK 500, da gibt's aber auch andere billigere. Aber ich wollte halt mal das haben, weil ich hatte das auch schon mal. Ja, kannst deinen Chip draufstecken und den programmieren kannst du aber auch mit einem Kabel deinen Chip auf deiner eigenen Platine schon programmieren. ISP nennt sich das In-System Programming. Und das kann man auch auf Mac benutzen. Zwar nicht mit der originalen Atmel-Software, die AVR Studio heißt, die gibt's halt nur auf dem PC, aber da gibt's irgendwie AVR Dude oder Dude. Und die läuft auch auf Mac. Das ist so ein Command-Line Tool, muss man sich vielleicht ein bisschen reinfummeln, aber wenn man es erstmal so kriegt und da gibt's tausende Seiten im Internet, die haben das auch erklärt, dann kann man mit dem Mac auch seine Atmel-Chips irgendwie beschreiben und dann gibt's auch für den Mac den GCC, dass der so einen Atmel-Code erstellt, damit man den C programmieren kann. Da muss man auch nichts in Assembler machen, kann man aber auch zur Not. Und also man kann auch mit dem Mac die bösen Hardware-Basteleien machen, das ist gar kein Problem.
Ist das dieses, aber das ist was anderes als dieses Arduino-Bot?
Na Arduino ist im Vergleich ja sowas wie dieses STK500 von Atmel. Nur ist es halt ein bisschen kleiner, hat glaube ich keine LED drauf, aber die Anschlüsse, die der Chip hat, werden auch alle nach außen geführt, über sogenannte Header, also über so Pfostenleisten, wo man sich dann sein Zeug ranstecken kann. Und mit diesem Arduino kann man das genauso machen, ist halt billiger, ist auch inzwischen ein sehr gefragtes Entwickler oder Bastler-Board.
Ich hab da mal mit diesem, gibt es ja dieses Baustellen in letzter Zeit hin und wieder mal.
Das was?
Baustellen. Das ist so, das machen hier Christian Heller und Philipp Stefan. Die haben das so aus Bauen und Basteln, haben die so eine Wortneuschöpfung gemacht. Und die machen hier in Berlin so kleinere Veranstaltungen, wo man dann so ein bisschen löten lernen kann und ein kleines Stück in die Programmierung kriegt. Und da war ich irgendwann mal, ich glaube beim allerersten Versuch. Und zum Löten sind wir leider gar nicht gekommen, aber die Dinge zu programmieren, das ist erstaunlich einfach. Also man braucht gar nicht so viel Angst haben. Das ist ein bisschen C-ähnlich. Irgendwas knackt hier gerade ganz furchtbar. Das ist so ein bisschen C-ähnlich das Ganze.
Nee, das ist eigentlich C.
Stimmt, das ist sogar C.
Ist halt noch ein bisschen anders als C-Programmierung, weil du halt noch Interrupts hast, auf die du reagieren kannst und so weiter. Aber eigentlich, was du da programmierst, ist richtig C und wird auch mit dem GCC nach Atmelcode übersetzt.
Und das war also das erste Erfolgserlebnis, das hat man relativ schnell gehabt. Ich dachte, mit so einem Scheißteil muss man ein Assembler programmieren oder so. Aber die Zeiten sind ja offensichtlich lange vorbei.
Also kannst du halt machen, aber musst du halt nicht.
Ja, das ist zwar echt.
Ist halt witzig, wenn du irgendwie ganz wenig Code hast und dein Code ist irgendwie 1000 Bytes lang und du hast schon voll viel Funktionalität drin. Und dann benutzt du Printf, was ja bei C so normalerweise dabei ist. Und dann benutzt du es plötzlich und dein Code steigt von den 1000 Bytes irgendwie auf 5 oder 6000 Bytes hoch.
Weil er dann so ein paar Bibliotheken nachladen muss?
Genau, weil der ganze Printf, das ist ja schon mächtig, dass er auch die über die Zahlen ausgeben kann und Formatzeiten und so. Und schwupp, schon ist dein Code irgendwie 5x größer. Und dann lernt man auch langsam erkennen, warum eigentlich Software heutzutage so riesengroß ist. Weil natürlich jedes Framework sowas von viele Features hat, die alle irgendwie mit reingelinkt werden und dabei braucht man das überhaupt alles gar nicht mehr. Also man braucht immer nur einen Teil von diesen riesen Frameworks. Also grundsätzlich auch auf Mac. Und dadurch werden Programme so groß.
Gut, ich hab nur gerade mit einem Ohr zugehört, weil mir gerade was einfiel. Es haben sich ja gerade hier alle so beschwert, dass der Stream so leise wäre. Und ich meinte die ganze Zeit, ich hätte keine Chance, das zu korrigieren, aber jetzt habe ich doch noch einen Weg gefunden, was mir jetzt erst die ganze Zeit einfiel. Und da wäre es schon mal ganz interessant, vielleicht das Thema mal auf dieses Programm zu bringen, mit dem wir streamen, weil das kennt auch nicht jeder. Und ich glaube, das hatten wir auch noch nie, oder?
Nee, das ist...
Das ist nämlich NiceCast. NiceCast.
Relativ nice, oder?
Und NiceCast ist ein Programmchen von Rogue Amoeba, was sicherlich der eine oder andere kennt. Und das ist halt so eine Mac-Bude, die sich extrem auf Audio-Software spezialisiert hat. Ich bin mir sicher, dass ihr irgendwas davon auch schon mal selber benutzt habt, oder?
Na ja, eigentlich so Audiozeugs haben die doch immer sehr viel, oder?
Na ja, wie ich gerade sagte, sie machen im Wesentlichen Audiozeugs. Aber was halt am bekanntesten ist, ist eigentlich Audio-Hijack. Das war eigentlich so das erste. Ist nicht das einzige, aber das erste Tool, eigentlich meiner Auffassung nach auch das beste Tool, mit dem man halt unter Mac OS X an beliebigen Stellen Sound abgreifen kann. Insbesondere an den interessanten Stellen wie das, was die Programme ausgeben. Deswegen heißt es auch Hijack. Du kannst einfach Hijack Pro starten und dann hast du irgendwie das, was der Safari ausgibt, das will ich jetzt mal irgendwo anders hinrauten und dann kannst du es halt mitschneiden. Das heißt, der einfachste Weg, deine DRM-Musik in iTunes sozusagen einfach abzuspeichern, ohne es jetzt auf CD zu brennen. Aber du kannst halt auch eine ganze Menge andere Sachen machen und du hast auch die Möglichkeit da so diverse Plugins zu aktivieren. Also du kannst ja auch so komplette Audio-Chains zusammenbauen mit Kompression und Pipapo, was halt so der Mac an eingebauten Audiomodulen in Core Audio so hergibt. Ja, und das ist einfach, also ich kenne auch so verschiedene Setups, die halt auch Podcaster nutzen. Also es ist teilweise auch für Podcasting, Recording benutzt worden, weil es einfach eine ganz einfache Methode ist.
Wenn man Skype aufnehmen will zum Beispiel, oder?
Ja, genau. Also dafür ist es zum Beispiel auch sehr gut.
Ich habe gerade eine total tolle Idee, was die als Nächstes rausbringen sollten. Ein Programm, mit dem man für jedes Programm einzeln einstellen kann, wie laut es ist, damit man Safari runterfüllen kann.
Ja, und das hatte ich neulich schon mal hinterfragt, ob es sowas eigentlich gibt. Warte mal, da hatte ich da auch irgendwelches Feedback drauf bekommen.
Das weiß ich gerade nicht mehr, ob ich das geträumt hatte oder ob das echt war.
Genau. Aber was man damit zumindest schon mal machen kann, ist man kann Programme muten, was ja auch manchmal schon mal ganz hilfreich ist. Also du kannst zum Beispiel deinen Browser sozusagen zu vollständiger Stille verdiensten. Also habt ihr das übrigens gesehen, das Safari, das da von Apple auch so einen Sketch abgab? Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt auch wieder so ein Patentantrag war.
Mit so einem Lautstärke-Regler drin?
Genau, pro Fenster.
Da warte ich schon seit pro Tat möchte ich ja gar nicht.
Naja, also pro Seite sozusagen. Das wäre sehr sinnvoll.
Ich komm übrigens gerade über den Chat ran, dass ich viel zu leise sei. Mal wieder. Und zwar wirklich bamm, bamm, bamm, bamm, bamm. Sagt irgendjemand, dass ich zu laut bin?
Ich schmeiß dir alle raus.
Vielleicht einfach lauter machen, mich ein bisschen.
Ich soll dich lauter machen. Ach, jetzt weiß ich wieder nicht, was das denn hier überhaupt. Ich war heute so nachlässig hier in der Verkabelung, jetzt recht sich das wieder. Ich mach dich mal lauter, sag mal was.
Jetzt sag ich noch mal was?
Du bist super.
Super, danke.
Ja, also das wäre super, wenn sie das einbauen. Aber vielleicht noch mal so zurück. Jetzt kann der Chat auch das Thema Audio jetzt einfach vergessen. Wir werden uns hier nichts mehr erinnern. Und, ähm, was ich bin übersteuert? Ihr habt doch eine Meise. Ähm, das wird jetzt ignoriert. Hier ist gar nichts übersteuert. Ähm, Audio Highjack Pro, bla, bla, bla. So, okay, gut. Und was haben sie noch? Dann haben sie noch dieses super Airfoil. Das ist, ähm, da haben sie halt den von John Johansen mal ausgegrabenen Key von der Airport Express Station dann sich sozusagen geschnappt und dann eben auch eine Software geschrieben, die an die Airport Expresse dieses Apple lossless oder, machen sie MP4, ich weiß gerade gar nicht, Format schickt. Das heißt, damit kannst du dann eben alle Programme irgendwie highjacken und an eine Airport Express schicken.
Man kann da wohl alle Formate hinschicken. Also mehrere. Nicht nur lossless, sondern auch MP3 direkt, weil ich hab mal den Linux Audio Framework Developer getroffen und der meinte, dass das Linux jetzt auch schon zu so einer Airport Express sein Audio routen kann.
Ja, aber das muss er nicht, weiß er nicht, dass das MP3 ist.
Ach, das hat er doch gesagt.
Dass er das als MP3 über das OVDR schickt.
Kann man machen. Also RAW oder lossless oder MP3.
Oder MP4 wahrscheinlich. Okay, wusste ich auch noch nicht. Aber wahrscheinlich haben sie einfach so einen Audiostein drin, der das einfach so kann. Wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche, was sie auch im iPod drin haben letzten Endes. Kaufen sie eh in Massen.
Müssen wir nochmal gucken. Also ich finde das ja nicht so schlecht, dass so eine OS so grundsätzlich alles Mögliche zu dieser Station streamen kann. Ich finde ja, Apple nutzt das ein bisschen zu wenig. Also es kann mehr.
Ja. Wir wollen ja auch nochmal über Apple TV reden. Ja, das ist auch lange gedauert.
Dieses Airfold kann ja auch in einer 3.0er Version, das ist jetzt auch schon wieder ewig her, aber die können ja auch Filme abspielen und den Sound dann zu dieser Express schicken. Und dann spielen sie den, weil der Sound halt ein bisschen braucht, eine halbe Sekunde oder wie viel auch immer, spielen sie den Film halt dann immer um eine halbe Sekunde verzögert ab, sodass es wieder in SYNC ist. Und das geht alles, weil dieses AirPod Express hat halt auch eine Uhr drin. Und warum Apple das nicht selber so anbietet für Quicktime oder so, weil das wär doch mal das Hammer-Feature.
Vielleicht geht das einfach mit Ihrem ranzigen alten Quicktime nicht und es kommt erst mit Quicktime X. Aber ich tippe drauf, dass es noch nicht mal mit Quicktime X kommt. Tipp ich. Naja, aber nochmal hier so zu dem... Ich will jetzt nicht durch alle Programme durchgehen, aber zwei, drei sind ganz erwähnenswert. Was ich mir neulich auch gekauft habe, auch wenn ich es eigentlich zu teuer finde, aber das hatte einen bestimmten Grund, weil ich wollte mir einfach mal Zeit sparen. Insofern war es vielleicht für mich nicht zu teuer. Das ist Fission. Fission. F-I-S-S-I-O-N. Und das ist ein MP3 Audio-Editor. Das heißt, wenn ich mal den Fall habe, dass ich eine MP3-Datei cutten will, also irgendwas rausnehmen will, was ich anfange oder Ende trimme oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas rausnehmen, dann kann ich halt mit Fischen das direkt in der Datei selber machen. Ich kann also einfach das fertige MP3 nehmen und muss es nicht nochmal in irgendwas konvertieren und dann nochmal re-encoden und so weiter.
Das MP3 ist ja in so einzelne Blöcke aufgeteilt, und dann schneidet der anhand von diesen Blöcken. Also macht der das ordentlich oder schneidet der einfach so mittendrin?
Nee, der macht das ordentlich und der macht auch Übergänge rein und so. Also der berechnet sozusagen die Teile, die sich wirklich ändern müssen, dann komplett neu. Aber halt so im Kontext des Ganzen, aber er re-encodet halt nicht das ganze Fall nochmal. Und das ist so schön.
Weil früher haben die einfach abgeschnitten, auch wenn wir so einen Makroblock oder wie auch immer die heißen in der Mitte erwischt haben, dann war der halt kaputt und dann hattest du mal kaputte Blöcke in deinem Stream.
Wer die?
Na, die Audio-Tools von früher, wie auch immer, die hießen, keine Ahnung. Also da gab es halt nicht so schicke Software. Überall.
Ich bin mir auch nicht so wusst, irgendein Programm, was MP3 geschnitten hat.
Ich weiß es so, dass die einfach immer mittendrin abgeschnitten haben.
Und das Team macht MP3 in place?
Nein, du kannst aufmachen und...
Naja, aber dann konvertiert er das halt. Das ist ja der Punkt. Dann linearisiert er es wieder. Und danach kannst du es halt wieder encoden. Aber dann hast du natürlich noch mal einen Audioverlust. Und Fission macht das halt nicht. Das heißt, du hast lossless aufkomprimierten Dateien. Und das ist ganz gut. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie noch was anderes machen, außer MP3, ob sie auch MP4 machen. Weiß ich gerade nicht. Kann sein. Kann auch nicht sein. Und jetzt noch mal zurück zu Nicecast, was meiner Auffassung nach der einzige Icecast-kompatible Streaming-Client ist auf dem Mac. Zumindest der einzige, der was taucht. Oder der einzige, der mir jemals ins Bewusstsein gerügt ist. Ja, aber der QuickTime Broadcaster ist ein stinkendes Stück Scheiße.
Hat der überhaupt ein User-Interface?
Don't talk to me about QuickTime Broadcaster. Wie viele Jahre hat sich dieses Software jetzt nicht geändert? Na, jetzt haben sie mal wieder einen Patch geliefert, weil irgendwas überhaupt nicht lief. Das dauert dann auch mal ein Jahr, bis sie mal irgendwas fixen. Sie machen dann nicht viel, das ist schon oftig. Das ist auch Quatsch. Also das Icecast ist insofern ganz cute, weil das kommt halt irgendwie mit einem einfachen User-Interface. Also für meinen Geschmack ist es schon ein bisschen zu, naja, ist so ein bisschen oldschoolig, wie Frühmeck, OSX und so mit so einem komischen Slider, der da rauskommt. Also hübsch ist anders, aber es ist zumindest funktional. Man kann halt da sehen, dass man irgendwie einen Pegel rausschickt. Leider kann man den Pegel erst sehen, wenn man es rausschickt. Das ist irgendwie so einer der Bugs in diesem Programm. Also man kann nicht schon vorher sehen, dass man einen Pegel hat und dann geht man irgendwann on air. Aber es ist zumindest auch so über hier meine DSL-Breaks, also wenn mein Zensurprovider mein Netz kappt, schafft er das dann auch irgendwie darüber hinaus, weiter zu streamen. Also er reconnectet automatisch, also relativ stabil. Und man kann halt die ganzen Metadaten, die mit rein schicken, auch konfigurieren. In unserem konkreten Fall, wenn ich jetzt hier auf xenim.de, also streamsxenim.de, das ist ja hier das Hörer-Support-Streaming-Network, was vor allem, also unter anderem von Carto in Hannover betrieben wird, da sind noch einige andere Leute dabei. Ich sollte mal keinen Namen nennen, dann vergisst man wieder irgendjemand, wie auch immer auf jeden Fall. Die machen das ja ganz nett und leider kann ich hier ein Bitt nicht setzen in Nicecast, nämlich dass das irgendwie ein Public Stream ist. Das kann man zwar schon, aber dann geht dieses Nicecast davon aus, dass dieser Stream eben auch automatisch in ihrem blöden Public Stream-Directory automatisch auftaucht, was mir jetzt auch nicht das ist, was ich jetzt will. Ich hab die auch irgendwann mal angeschrieben und keine Ahnung, die wollten das irgendwie nicht ändern oder so. Also grundsätzlich sind die schon responsive, aber an der Stelle ist Nicecast jetzt nicht so flexibel, wie man es vielleicht immer haben will, aber es läuft super stabil und tut den Job. So und wie ich das jetzt eben geschafft habe, hier auch noch das...
Wieso auch kostenlos?
Bitte? Nein, nein, das ist alles Kaufsoftware bei denen. Also die haben auch ein paar...
Das sind ja auch die, die das Wirecast machen oder wollen ja auch richtig Geld für haben, ne?
Nee, Wirecast ist eine ganz andere Firma. Das hat damit nichts zu tun.
Und da ist doch das gleiche Logo hier, die sitzt hier.
Nee, das verwechselst du. Das mag vielleicht ein ähnliches Logo haben, aber Wirecast hat nichts mit Look-Ammi anzutun. Die machen auch kein Video, die machen nur Audio. Was ich total vergessen hatte, ist, dass Nicecast eben genauso wie Audio-High-Drag, da haben sie auch so ein generalisiertes User-Interface, die Möglichkeit hat, noch Audio-Units einzuplangen. Das heißt, ich hab hier auch noch einen After-Gain-Regler und so, den hab ich bisher immer übersehen. Und den hab ich jetzt einfach aufgedreht und dann ist es jetzt auch schön laut. Zumindest ein bisschen. Ich hätte mir jetzt hier auch noch ein Setup machen können mit irgendwie Kompressor und Tralala und so. Aber während einer Live-Sendung macht man das immer besser. Nicht nächstes Mal gibt's dann schickeres Streaming. Noch schickeres Streaming. So, jetzt haben wir schon viel Werbung gemacht für Rogue Amoeba, aber das sind so Leute, für die macht man auch gerne Werbung. Nächstes Thema. Ach, wir sind so schön schluchztretend. Großartig.
Päckchen machen, weiter geht's.
Wir könnten jetzt höherer Größen die gerade am Einkaufen sind. Du, wir meinen dich, der du gerade vor dem Kühlregal stehst und darüber gerübelst, ob du dir 2 Liter oder 3 Liter nicht kaufst.
Die 4 bitte an die 8. Und nicht die Rentner, ein Taubten.
Mit dem Flammenschwert. Oder ich das Klopapier vergesse.
Das war jetzt ein kleiner Insider-Joke vom Hörer-Treffen. Aber jetzt haben wir gegrüßt. Gut. Müssen wir noch was zur Zensursula sagen? Nachdem wir letztes Mal schon so unseren kleinen Polit-Spagat gewagt haben und gewagt haben uns aus der heiligen Konsumerwelt des McIntosh-Kaufens abzulenken?
Na ja, wir können mal sagen, es gibt seitdem eine Petition, oder? Die läuft jetzt schon seit einer Woche.
Stimmt, das kam ja genau erst danach.
Das kam von einer Woche ziemlich genau mit der Petition. Die kam letzten Montag. Oder letzten Dienstag?
Fühlt sich aber schon an, als ob das im halben Jahr läuft, ne?
Fühlt sich an, als ob das schon über 70.000 Einträge wären.
Sind es? Zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme. Wenn man was kennenlernt, dann denkt man immer, es ist ja schon mindestens eine Woche alt jetzt, bis es bei mir angekommen ist, so vom Rum erzählen. Aber in Wirklichkeit ist es 5 Minuten alt, weil man Sachen so schnell irgendwie einem zugetragen werden über Twitter oder über Chats oder wie auch immer, dass man also gar nicht mehr denkt, dass es so frisch ist. Also früher, wenn dir was erzählt wurde, war es eine Woche alt und dann kam es irgendwann bei dir an. Deswegen bist du automatisch davon ausgegangen, wenn du kein Datum mitbekommen hast mit der Information, dass es eine ca. eine Woche alte Information ist. Heutzutage habe ich dieses Gefühl immer noch, dass Informationen so 2-3 Tage alt sind, aber in Wirklichkeit sind sie 5 Minuten alt. Also ich dachte auch, die Petition wäre von der Woche von davor. Dabei war die am gleichen Tag gerade losgetreten worden.
Also ich war Zeichner Nr. 17.
Wirklich? Aber du hattest auch Insider-Information.
Ich hatte keine, nee, das ist die Petitionisten, die werden nicht informiert darüber, dass ihre Petition jetzt online ist.
Ach so, aber du hattest trotzdem Insider-Information.
Nee, ich hatte überhaupt keine Insider-Information. Ich habe das über Netzpolitik bekommen und war durch Zufall einer der ersten, der drauf war. Diana, die das Ganze mit initiiert hat, die war selber irgendwie...
Die auch gestern beim Hörer-Treffen war?
Genau, die gestern auch da war, die war selber 2.400 irgendwas. Also, die Leute werden darüber nicht informiert, dass deine Petition nicht online ist.
Ich war 69.000 und irgendwas.
Ach, also, hast du es jetzt erst unterzeichnet oder was?
Vorher dachte ich, da ging es immer nicht, weil der Server so überlastet war. Und dann dachte ich irgendwann, na jetzt sind es ja 50.000, jetzt brauche ich ja nicht mehr, jetzt haben sie ja die Summe, die sie brauchen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welche Zahl ich war, aber irgendwas Vierstelliges.
Und dann wurde aber gestern erzählt auf dem Hörer-Treffen, also hast du ja auch selber gesagt, dass es ja eigentlich gar nicht um die Petition geht, sondern um die Medienaufmerksamkeit, die dadurch entsteht und dass es sich halt trotzdem lohnt, da noch einzutragen, damit es halt eine möglichst hohe Zahl ist. Ich meine, man macht jetzt Politik nicht durch hohe Zahlen, aber so ein bisschen doch.
Na ja, doch, in der Politik wird sehr, sehr viel durch hohe Zahlen gemacht. Das ist so dieses Wahlprinzip.
Ich meine, die Zahl ist natürlich absolut gesehen noch keine hohe Zahl in dem Sinne. Es ist halt...
Wenn man die Hürden bedenkt, die der Server einem auferlegt, um darunter zeichnen zu können, schon...
Ja.
Das ist ja echt nicht easy.
Das stimmt. Es könnte einfacher sein. Wobei ich hatte jetzt nicht so viele Probleme wie du. Dir ist irgendwas aufgefallen, was mir nicht aufgefallen war.
Dass man die Captures, also bei mir war es jedenfalls so, die werden groß angezeigt als Grafik und man muss sie aber klein eingeben, sonst nimmt das nicht. Kann jemand nochmal testen, aber mir war so.
Das Problem hatte ich nicht. Also, vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz erzählen. Wir haben ja letztes Mal über diese Zensurlesäure-Ding erzählt. Da brauchen wir jetzt nicht nochmal genauer drauf einzugehen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da jetzt eine E-Petition, die die meisten von euch sicherlich schon gezeichnet haben.
Und solltet ihr sie noch nicht gezeichnet haben, dann macht das doch einfach mal. Weil das ist jetzt, also abgesehen davon, dass das jetzt bisher die erfolgreichste Blablabla am schnellsten gezeichnete Petition war, ich finde ja eigentlich die Zahl 50.000 an sich ist ja jetzt eigentlich so hoch auch nicht. Also diese 50.000er Hürde ist halt nur eine von dem Petitionsausschuss sich selbst gesetzte Grenze, ab der sie quasi so eine eingebaute Automatik haben. Also das ist nicht irgendwie ein Petitionsgesetz oder so.
Und das ist auch gut so, weil da gibt es eine Petition, da fordert einer, dass der 500-Euro-Schein abgelöst. Also eingestellt werden soll, weil mit dem könnte man ja eh nicht bezahlen. So Petitionen gibt es da.
Naja, ich meine, warum nicht? Wenn das die Hälfte der Menschheit unterstützt, dann kann man es ja auch sein lassen. Das wird bloß halt nicht stattfinden.
Genau.
Ich finde das auch okay. Meinetwegen sollen sich ja auch die Lunis austoben. Letzten Endes finden sie halt kein Gehör. Aber wenn halt bestimmte Petitionen besser wegkommen, ist gut.
Der Petitionsausschuss setzt sich wirklich mit jeder Petition. Man kann als Einzelperson hingehen, kann sagen, ich reiche hier die Petition ein und die setzen sich in irgendeinen Mitarbeiter, setzt sich damit auseinander.
Und sagt irgendwie, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Naja, die müssen schon ein bisschen mehr Arbeit geben. Also ein bisschen mehr Mühe. Aber im Wesentlichen wird es wahrscheinlich darauf hinaus.
So was wie, dass er sich zu seinem Kollegen wendet und sagt, findest du das nicht auch, dass es ein totaler Scheiß ist?
Wahrscheinlich ist sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, also ich hab da auch wenig Illusionen, was sozusagen die Wirkungskraft dieser Petition als solchen betrifft. Aber was sie natürlich bewirkt hat, ist eine, naja, ist jetzt auch wieder so schwierig mit der Netzwahrnehmung. Man weiß ja bei den meisten Artikel noch nicht mal, ob sie dann auch in Print erscheinen. Aber es ist zumindest jetzt in jedem oder nahezu jedem populären Blatt, was auch online erscheint, also Zeit und Tagesspiegel und bla bla bla. Es gab diverse sehr gute Kommentare, die halt auch jetzt das erste Mal die Essenz dieser Kritik aufgenommen haben, was vorher einfach überhaupt nicht stattfand. Ich meine, die Journalisten versagen meiner Meinung nach sowieso, hatten wir auch letztes Mal schon die Diskussion, total, was einfach diese Kontrolle der Regierung betrifft. Dass das halt erst so eine Horde von Web 2.0-Nerds braucht, um sowas auf die Agenda der Journalisten zu setzen, ist eigentlich traurig. Aber es ist halt trotzdem gut, dass wir jetzt ein Mittel gefunden haben.
Aber es passiert immerhin noch. Genau.
Diesmal ist die Wut echt greifbar. Also bisher, vorher fand ich war das immer so, naja, wir regen uns jetzt halt mal wieder gegen irgendwas auf. So und kein Hahn kräht danach und letzten Endes ist es den meisten. Ja, ja, aber diesmal ist es halt anders. Diesmal ist halt wirklich so ein Punkt erweitert. Und vor allem, was ich ganz göttlich finde, ist, wie die Politiker jetzt auch ihre Arroganzschiene einfach da weiterreisen. Und ich habe zwar noch nicht den Eindruck, dass es schon da ist, aber ich habe so langsam den Eindruck, dass es da hinkommen könnte. Dass wenn sie es jetzt noch so, irgendeiner muss jetzt noch mal das Maul aufmachen. Schäuble wäre eigentlich ganz gut. Der hält schon so wischend die ganze Zeit ganz, ganz auffallend die Fresse. Der kommentiert irgendwie gar nichts mehr. Der ist schon sehr vorsichtig. Aber stell dir mal vor, er oder die Merkel oder sonst irgendein Hirni sagt jetzt noch so irgendwas wie Internet-User haben kleine Schwänze und...
Die haben doch eh alle kein Leben und nichts besseres zu tun.
Genau. Und sind sowieso alle doof und ihr könnt nicht mal... Ihr seid ja sowieso nicht relevant.
Frau Merkel, können Sie das nicht mal sagen?
Genau, ich würde mir gerne wünschen, dass es irgendjemand sagt. Ich glaube, wenn das kommt, dann...
Hat der Schäuble das schon so gesagt?
Ja, aber das ist schon eine Weile her. Es geht jetzt aktuell um diese Debatte.
Mit den Grundgesetzrichtern und so weiter, also den Richtern, da meint er doch auch, er macht die Gesetze und wenn die, also wenn wir sozusagen die Gesetze machen wollen...
Das bezieht sich ja nicht auf diese Internet-Gemeinde. Also derzeit geht es ja darum, dass hier einfach aktiv Leute, die einfach verstanden haben, was die Implikation des Internets in den nächsten 20 Jahren ist, dass die halt bespuckt werden öffentlich.
Das ist absurd. Irgendjemand hat einen schönen Artikel darüber geschrieben nach dem Motto, naja, es wird sich doch auch kein Politiker ein Bierzelt stellen auf so einer Rede und erstmal vor 10.000 Leuten erzählen, dass sie doch alle nur besoffenes Pack seid. Aber sie erzählen 70.000 Leuten, dass sie doch Verschwörungstheoretische Spinner sind, die Kinderpornos toll finden, weil sie eine Petition unterzeichnen.
Das ist...
Das muss man erstmal bringen.
Ja, weil sie uns eins nicht abnehmen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht hatten sie da bisher auch recht. Sie nehmen uns einfach nicht ab, dass wir so eine eigene Lobby sein können. Dass wir wirklich so eine gesellschaftliche Gruppe sind. Und wenn überhaupt, dann halt wirklich nur so in dem Sinne, wie sie es eben dargestellt haben. Also diese ganzen Loonies, die den ganzen Tag nur im Netz rum, die einfach kein Live haben. Aber dass das halt eigentlich schon auch so die Leute sind, die sie stützen, und das ist noch viel schlimmer, dass es eben auch eine bestimmte Elite dieser Gesellschaft darstellt. Das haben die glaube ich noch nicht so richtig verinnerlicht. Und es wird Zeit, dass sie das merken. Und diese Zensursula-Petition scheint mir derzeit das angemessenste Mittel, um da doch mal ein bisschen Klimp im zu machen. So, jetzt könnt ihr alle klicken. Haben wir da noch was zu sagen?
Zensursula erstmal nicht so viel, oder? Genau. Zeichnet die Petition, guckt euch an, verfolgt das Ganze. Und ich hab, ach doch, was ich noch habe, ich hab so einen kleinen, das kam relativ gut an, ich hab so eine Mail an alle meine Freunde und Bekannten rumgeschickt. Die hab ich auch auf eine Seite gestellt, die können wir vielleicht gleich noch verlinken. So als Muster-Mail, falls man ein bisschen mobilisieren möchte, weil in den üblichen Kreisen ist das Thema ja wahrscheinlich wirklich langsam rum und langsam wird Zeit eurer Eltern, eurer Großeltern, eure Arbeitgeber, wen auch immer, darüber zu informieren, dass es das gibt. Und ich schicke einfach mal, der Link ist ein bisschen kompliziert, obwohl eigentlich ist etween.net/petitionsmail.html. Mittlerweile sogar Rechtschreib korrigiert. Mit Doppel E. Ich hab dir grad einen Link geschickt. Ich hab den noch mal in Irrg rein.
Wie hast du mir einen Link geschickt?
Irgendwie per Adium, glaube ich.
Hoffe ich. Ich bin doch jetzt währenddessen noch nicht im Java, mein Freund. Ah, ein vorformulierter Brief.
Genau. Den sollte man noch ein bisschen anpassen, auf jeden Fall. Schick den raus.
Kommt in die Show Notes. Ja, Community, tralala. Ich war ja auch wieder viel unterwegs in letzter Zeit. Also, naja, für meine Verhältnisse war ich eigentlich nicht viel unterwegs, aber ich war zumindest überhaupt mal wieder unterwegs, nachdem ich noch weiter nicht unterwegs war.
Wo warst du denn?
Ich war in München.
Was hast du in München gemacht?
In München hab ich einen Podcast aufgezeichnet.
Ja, aber ich möchtest aber noch nicht so erzählen, nehme ich an. Na gut.
Und da halte ich mich ja immer ganz bedeckt, zumindest wenn es den Kanal aus Radio Express betrifft. Ist ja auch egal, wird man eh bald hören können, hoffe ich. Aber dann hab ich halt auch die Gelegenheit genutzt, noch mal ein kleines Hörer-Treffen zu machen, was sehr nett war. Und das betrifft insofern vielleicht auch Mobile-Max-Gemeinde, als das natürlich auch hier unsere Freunde von BITS und so nahezu vollständig vertreten waren. Und das war auch ein sehr nettes Treffen, wo es auch sehr produktiv wurde zwischendurch. Da haben ein paar Leute sich auch engagiert, da mal ein bisschen mehr Tools zu hacken, die wir Podcasts alle so brauchen. Aber unter anderem war ich dann auf dem Vintage Computing Festival Europe gelandet. Das fand dann nämlich gerade statt an diesem Wochenende.
Was gilt als Vintage?
Vintage gilt laut Aussage des Organisatoren jeder Computer, der älter ist als zehn Jahre.
Das sind ja schon durchaus Power-PCs, oder?
Ja, da standen halt auch so Apple IIs rum und so ein Klimp im, aber halt auch eine ganze Menge so 8er-Hardware, so was weiß ich, 8088 und Z80-Krempel und diese ganze Sinclair und C64-Mumpe. Klar, das ist ja logisch. Aber auch so alte Robotron-Maschinen, also der ganze Ostpark war da irgendwie auch vertreten. Auch so Geräte, die ich so noch gar nicht gesehen hatte. Festplatten-Controller, so von der Größe von so einem Power-Mac. Na ja, die Platte selber war zu dem Zeitpunkt zwar schon klein, aber der Controller war halt so groß wie so ein Mega-Mainboard. Weil viel Elektronik und so weiter, du musstest ja an Festplatten damals auch noch Computer ran machen. War auf jeden Fall ganz nett. War jetzt nicht außergewöhnlich toll und so und es hat auch so ein bisschen, naja, hast du halt so viel bärtige Hobbyisten, größer 35 Jahre, die dann halt so mit ihrer ganzen alten Hardware da angeguckt kommen.
Wichtige Assoziationen sind immer so ein bisschen angestaubt, riechen gekonnt haben, könnte die ganze Veranstaltung.
Nee, jetzt die Teilnehmer.
Nee, die veranstalten, also so einfach, wenn man da so reinkommt, so irgendwie findet das in einer alten Turnhalle statt oder so was, nicht am schönsten Ort der Welt.
Genau, in einer alten Turnhalle. Mit Holzboden und so. Also, hatte auch was Heimliches. War auch eine nette Community und so. Und allerdings, was ich wirklich gut fand, was ich leider keine Gelegenheit hatte, mir wirklich näher anzuschauen, aber das Programm sah einfach super aus. Also, die Vorträge, die da liefen, waren einfach irre. Also, so Einblicke in, wie das so früher war, uralte Programmiersprachen und noch so ein paar ganz andere nette Aspekte. Leider wurden die nicht aufgezeichnet. Allerdings hat der Martin, hier Martin Pittenauer von BITZ und so, letztes Jahr da rumgehangen und hat die Vorträge aufgezeichnet und jetzt als Podcast veröffentlicht. Da möchte man vielleicht auch noch mal reinschauen. Naja, das fiel mir noch so ein zum Thema Reisen und neue Erfahrungshorizonte und alte Hardware angucken. Aber wir können uns jetzt mal auf die neue Hardware stürzen, die wir schon angedeutet haben.
Auf die Nägelnagel neue Hardware, wenn ich das mal so sagen muss.
Genau, dein Aschenbecher war voll.
Mein Aschenbecher war voll. Ich bin heute Morgen aufgewacht, klappt meinen MacBook Pro auf.
Und der ist nicht mit aufgewacht.
Und der ist nicht mit aufgewacht. Das Display bleibt dunkel.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Hat es ihn so im Arm, im Bett?
Die ganze Nacht über? Nee, er lag tatsächlich neben dem Bett. Also es ist für mich ein absolut unvorstellbares Phänomen. Ich hab den gestern Abend abgeschaltet.
Dann hast du fünf Minuten auf ihn eingerettet. Ey Baby, komm, ich hab's nicht so gemeint.
Und dann hab ich mit der Faust drauf rumgeprügelt.
Ist nicht dein Ernst?
Nein, na kratsch, nein. Auf jeden Fall wachte er nicht mehr auf. Also er wachte auf, aber das Display ging nicht an. Also ich hörte die Platte rauschen und sowas.
Du hast ihn auch mal ordentlich ausgedrückt hier über den Button.
Ich hab den nochmal ausgemacht, ich hab nochmal angemacht. Ich hab diesen...
Du hast den Aschenbecher ordentlich ausgeleert.
Das heißt ja nicht mehr Power Manager Reset, sondern wie heißt das jetzt? Also SMC Reset, wo man dann den Akku rausnehmen muss und fünf Sekunden die Power-Taste gedrückt halten. Hab ich alles gemacht, hat alles nichts gebracht. Und dann hab ich beschlossen, naja, wenn ich... Also das dämliche ist, ich muss heute diese Woche noch nach Darmstadt. Und das war alles. Und ich wusste jetzt nicht, wie ich die Daten runterkriegen sollte. Und da hab ich gedacht, wo ich doch mal ein bisschen Geld auf dem Konto habe, nutze ich doch die Gelegenheit, kaufe ich mir einfach einen neuen während der alten Reparatur ist und verkloppte den danach. Und hab mir so ein schickes neues MacBook Pro gekauft. Von dem wir alle nicht ganz so unglaublich begeistert waren, aber was will man machen? Du weißt jetzt ein sehr schönes Gerät, das vor mir steht.
Ich find's ja total schick.
Das sieht total schick aus, oder?
Mit der Batterie und mit der Festplatte, dass man jetzt da prima rankommt, das ist auch total toll. Mit der Dual-Grafikkarte und den ganzen OpenCL-Features, die man da nämlichst haben wird, also dieser NVIDIA-Kram. Das ist auch total super. Und die längere Akkuleistung dadurch, diese bessere Batterie, weil das ist ja nicht mehr eine normale, sondern ist jetzt hier so Lithium, wer ist das, Polymer?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ist das so eine neue Batterie schon?
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so runde Zellen, sondern das gesamte Volumen wird jetzt für die Batterie, für den Batteriestoff benutzt. Und das ist schon alles ganz toll. Was ich ein bisschen vermisse ist die nächst höhere Auflösung. Ich finde, Apple sollte mal wieder nachziehen und so wie andere Firmen auch die Auflösung erhöhen.
Da ist ja auch noch Platz. Da ist ja noch so ein schwarzer Rahmen-Display rum, wo sie durchaus noch ein bisschen reingehen könnten, oder?
Ja, ich meine, die anderen sind inzwischen bei 1920, bei 15 Zollern, also könnte Apple mindestens mal auf 1680 hochgehen.
Also was mich erstmal sehr erschreckt hat, als ich das Ding gekauft habe, dass man jetzt sämtliche Adapter dazu kaufen muss. Also vorher, das Alter hat einen DVI-Ausgang und ein VGA-Adapter lag dabei. Das konnte ich jetzt jeweils für 20 Euro nachkaufen. Also einmal einen VGA-Adapter, einmal einen DVI-Adapter. Oder vielleicht sogar 30 Euro. Dann brauchte ich noch ein Firewire-Kabel, weil das, was ich habe, ist... Ich habe ja nur Firewire 400 zu Hause, die ganzen Geräte, aber das hat ja nur noch ein Firewire 800-Ausgang.
Ich kann dir jetzt sogar sagen, warum du diesen Adapter kaufen musst.
Wieso?
Aber für erst mal zu Ende.
Und ich hab mir schon gekauft. Aber ansonsten bin ich so auf den ersten Blick, auch wenn es gar nicht so viel besser ist als mein altes, doch sehr...
Es ist einfach sackstabil.
Das sieht auch geil aus irgendwie. Ich find das jetzt schon sehr schick.
Vor allem durch den Trick, dass du den am Rand unten so ein bisschen abschrägst. Dann sieht es ein bisschen aus, wie das Gefährt in dem Luke Skywalker über den Wüstenplaneten geschossen ist. Weil es auch nach unten so ein bisschen wegging. Und dadurch sieht es noch schmaler aus, als es eigentlich ist, weil man die eigentliche Auflagefläche unten gar nicht so richtig sehen kann.
Genau, also es ist ein bisschen dünner als das alte. Ich hab das vorhin mal verglichen. Aber dafür auch ein bisschen breiter und tiefer. Was ich ganz hübsch finde, sind so kleine Details. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du bei deinem Kopfhörerausgang anguckst, das sieht so nach grauer Plaste aus. Und hier ist das irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht, ist das Aluminium?
Metall eingefasst, ja, ja. Das ist jetzt komplett Metall alles.
Das ist echt, also das hat so nochmal so ein...
Das wurde ja auch mal Zeit.
Das wurde Zeit, aber es ist...
Das wage ich gar nicht zu bejubeln, weil es ist einfach.
Vor allem, ich glaube, 8 oder 10 sind es. Ich weiß gar nicht. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7. Ich glaube, es sind insgesamt 8. 8 leuchtende Batterieanzeige. Das ist mal ein Hammerfeature.
8 LEDs, die jetzt an der Seite ist.
Und ich meine es nicht mal ironisch. Und sie sind sogar an der Seite. Man kann sie sehen. Genau, ich muss meinen Rechner gar nicht mehr von unten klicken, sondern man kann schon an der Seite sehen.
Vor allem, du hast da jetzt wahrscheinlich auch schon die zweite oder dritte Revision von dem Mainboard wahrscheinlich. Und da wird es sogar stabil laufen.
Genau. Was ich ein bisschen, also das war wirklich so, ich bin dann aufgewacht, wusste nicht, was ich machen sollte. Hab dann erstmal bei Graves angerufen, ob die mir auch die schnellen Neues machen können. Dann haben die gesagt, äh, Festplatte auswechseln. Also weil ich wollte dann die alte Festplatte behalten, weil die aktuellen haben alle nur so kleine, so 320er, glaube ich, haben wir gesagt, Festplatten. Und ich hatte ja eine schöne 500er da drinnen. Außerdem, wie gesagt, wusste ich gar nicht, wie ich Daten runterkriegen sollte, weil wenn das Display nicht mehr geht, macht sich das ja auch immer ein bisschen doof. Dann habe ich beschlossen, ich kaufe mir ein neues, alte Festplatte rein, neue Festplatte in das alte rein. Und das wird dann schön repariert und danach verkloppt. Und das haben die bei Graves irgendwie nicht so auf die Reihe gekriegt. Darum war ich jetzt bei Fuxdata, hier auch an der... Wo sind die? Kastaniali, ne? Fuxdata. Fuxdata. Und die haben wir dann auf ganz schnell, das war wirklich, bin hingefahren, habe das alte Ding abgegeben, habe mich eine Stunde in ein Café gesetzt. Eine Stunde, ich wirklich so viel wollten die gar nicht haben, aber dann habe ich gedacht, gehe ich mal auf Nummer sicher. Und dann kam ich zurück, dann hatte ich meinen neuen Rechner. Und der lief dann auch sofort. Und alles...
So geht das beim Fux?
So geht das bei denen. Kleines Detail, was mir aufgefallen ist, das neue Energieeinstellung Panel. Also da gibt es ja ein Kontrollfeld jetzt mit einer Energiesparlampe.
Ist keine Glühlampe mehr, sondern...
Eine Energiesparlampe. Ne, das Detail meinte ich aber gar nicht. Ich hatte noch das alte Energiesparpanel und konnte darum am Anfang direkt nach dem Festplattenwechsel nicht die CPU wechseln, äh die GPU wechseln.
Du hast ja auch ganz schön mutig gewechselt. Ich meine einfach die Platte aus deinem alten Rechner rausnehmen und in so ein neues Gerät stecken, wo ja doch schon so ein bisschen Hardware-Support her muss. Also ganz sehr froh sein, dass es überhaupt erst mal funktioniert hat. Weil eigentlich wurden die MacBook Pros, die neuen ja auch mit so einem damals 10.5++, also die haben ja immer so eine Spezialversion.
Also offensichtlich ein bisschen, was es noch davon, noch ein bisschen spezialisiert dran.
Aber das 10.5.6 kam nach den MacBooks raus, oder? Also muss eigentlich, sonst hätte das nie funktioniert.
Und naja ansonsten hätte ich halt, hab ich im Endeffekt auch so gemacht, weil ich dann so gedacht habe, naja ok, wenn das schon ein Unterschied ist, mal sehen was dann noch so unterschiedlich ist zwischen den einzelnen Betriebssystemen, hab ich nochmal einen Archive in den Store gemacht und sozusagen, also nochmal, neues Betriebssystem drüber gebügelt und jetzt ist das alles schön drin. Und jetzt habe ich hier die kleine Energiesparlampen.
Wann kam die MacBook Pros raus? Wohin im Januar vorgestellt?
Ich hab's schon vergessen. Viel früher, Ende letzten Jahres.
Das war als wir in Kanada waren. Das war September, Oktober.
Also schon fast bald wieder ein Jahr alt. Und so richtig eine Revision so.
Nur mal als nimmst du euch eigentlich immer, wenn ich mir ein neues MacBook kaufe, kommt dann ein paar Wochen später die nächste Generation.
Es gibt ja schöne Gerüchte, was neue MacBooks betrifft. Ich glaub zwar immer noch nicht dran. Also ich würde gerne dran glauben. Und also ihr habt's mitbekommen, oder? Dieses, ich glaub da ist nichts dran. Ich glaub nicht, dass es passieren wird. Ich fänd's trotzdem ganz toll.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wovon du schon.
Na 3G eingebaut. Und SIM-Karte.
Ich glaub dran. Da haben wir schon besprochen, weil es einfach mal sein muss. Da kommt niemand dran vorbei. Alles demnächst hat IP und ist irgendwie online. Deine Uhr wird es demnächst haben. Die Telefone haben's schon. Die Computer sind halt noch nicht da. Die sind da online, wenn ich ein WLAN hab. Oder halt ein Ethernet-Kabel. Aber sie sind nicht deutschlandweit online. Weil im Wald gibt's kein WLAN. Aber im Wald gibt's irgendwie 3G. Na ja, wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall gibt's da ein bisschen Netz. Und das werden die sich da reinholen.
Ja, aber da müssen sie ja nochmal den Formfaktor ändern. Wieso? Oder meinst du, man muss dann unten die SIM-Karte reinlegen, sozusagen. So von unten.
Oder die kommen dann mit einem ganz anderen Konzept.
Da wo man einen Rahmen reinsteckt und so.
Wahrscheinlich da wo man einen Rahmen reinsteckt.
Ja, ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass wenn da eine SIM-Karte drin ist, dann machen sie da nicht so einen Slot oder so. Das auf keinen Fall. Insofern müssten sie wahrscheinlich kein neues Gehäuse bauen. Und uns halt mit den Antennen irgendwie auch hinkriegen und so. Aber sollte auch nicht das Problem sein.
Aber sowas muss einfach kommen. Kann sich so eine große Firma nicht erlauben, dass demnächst alle Geräte irgendwie Dauer-Online und Dauer-Netz haben und so weiter und die nicht.
Also was ja so ein bisschen...
Die Frage ist, für welche Kondition? Also haben wir dann wieder Vertragsbindung und ich kauf mir meinen MacBook bei T-Mobile?
Bestimmt.
Na, bestimmt. Da geht aber alle auf die Barrikaden. Ich kauf mir meinen Mac-Tosh nicht bei T-Mobile.
Ich bin bei den iPhones auch nicht interessiert.
Bei den iPhones ist das auch was anderes, vor allem, weil es sich um ein Telefon handelt.
Also ich meine, es wird natürlich Optionen geben. Das gibt es ja jetzt auch schon bei den Netbooks. Es gibt ja Netbooks, die gibt es alle frei. Und dann gibt es die bei den diversen Händlern. Und dann haben sie vielleicht einen Exklusivpartner, mit dem sie sozusagen, also ich geh mal davon, oder sie bringen eine Version der MacBook Pros raus, die von vornherein 3G eingebaut haben und mit Datenvertrag ein bisschen günstiger sind. Die ganz normalen MacBooks, die man mit MacBooks kaufen oder eben MacBook mit Vertrag. Und nur das hat dann das Modem eingebaut. Das kann ich mir am ehesten vorstellen.
Also ich meine, wenn sie da 3G einbauen, in ihre Laptops, dann bauen sie das nicht in einige Geräte ein, sondern in alle. Und dann ist das halt auch eine weltweite Geschichte. Und zwar weltweiter als derzeit ihr iPhone weltweit ist. Bei dem iPhone gönnen sie sich sozusagen diesen Luxus, dass sie das eben nicht in allen Ländern anbieten. Auch wenn es natürlich dann in andere Länder unter der Hand weiterverkauft wird. Das wissen wir ja alle, aber wir wissen ja wie es ist. Nicht alle Länder werden bedient. Aber es gibt natürlich viele Länder, in denen schon Macintoshes verkauft werden, in denen aber keine iPhones verkauft werden.
Da soll es weitergehen.
Aus den selben Gründen.
So.
Naja, was heißt das dann für ein MacBook, was eben 3G hat? Das heißt, dass sie da eine ganz andere Strategie fahren müssen. Wenn sie das aber machen, wenn sie einfach sagen, naja, da ist ja so ein Slot und dann kannst du da reinschieben. Dann würden sie ja genau das, was ihnen beim iPhone wichtig ist und was meiner Auffassung nach ihnen beim Mac auch wichtig ist. Nämlich dieses, wir wollen die Kontrolle darüber haben, wie das so mit den Protokollen ist. Und wir wollen nicht, dass wir jetzt wegen irgendwelcher bekloppten Provider, die irgendwie beklopptes Netz haben, das nicht funktioniert, weil das fällt dann auf uns zurück, die alte Leier. Und naja, ich sag nur, dass es definitiv ein Gedanke ist, der auch bei dieser ganzen iPhone-Strategie ist, abgesehen von ihren Revenue-Modellen, die sie natürlich damit auch noch haben. Bloß diese Revenue-Modelle gibt's halt sowieso schon im Telefonbereich. Im Computerbereich ist das was Neues. Also diese Netbooks von T-Mobile und so, das ist natürlich jetzt, im Prinzip wächst diesen Telefonen jetzt eine Tastatur. Kann man sagen. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob das auf den Macintosh Max zu übertragen ist. Ich würd mich natürlich super freuen, wenn da einfach nur so ein SIM-Karten-Slot drin ist und fertig. Und dann steck ich da meine Karte rein und dann mach ich irgendwie Daten-Kram. Aber ich glaub einfach nicht, dass das Apples Way of Dealing with it ist. Also wenn die sowas da anbieten, dann...
Das kann sein.
Stecken die da irgendwie auch auf der Provider-Seite in irgendeiner Form mit drin, um da einfach die Kontrolle daraus zu haben, dass das eben seamless ist und dass das funktioniert und das Setup...
Also wie gesagt, davon geh ich auch fest aus.
Und natürlich möchten sie auch unsere Apple-ID haben.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Teasering auf dem iPhone? Da gibt's ja auch irgendwie keine Neuigkeiten so richtig, oder?
Na doch, es gibt.
Na findet statt. Also in der Software, in der 3... Du meinst jetzt in der 3.0 Software? Naja, es ist drin das Feature.
Es ist doch schon wieder Disabled und so weiter.
Nee, nee, es ist nicht Disabled. Es ist... Es gibt diese Carrier Bundles. Also es hängt...
Wie man jetzt mit dem aktuellen iTunes nicht mehr hochladen darf.
Also man kann... Dieses Feature ist freigeschaltet, je nachdem, was der Provider sagt. Wenn der Provider böse ist, dann sagt er, nee, Teasering ist nicht erlaubt bei uns, wollen wir nicht, dann gibt's das einfach nicht. Und wenn er ein netter Provider ist, dann bietet er das an. Und jetzt gab's so Tricks, wie man mit iTunes diese Carrier Bundles, heißt das, glaube ich, neu hochspielen konnte und quasi wie eine neue Firmware installieren, bloß ein bisschen schneller. Und dass man danach alles, wenn man das so hatte wie vorher. Und dann konnte man dieses Teasering darüber einschalten. Und das ist jetzt mit der neuesten Firmware...
Das heißt nicht Teasering, das heißt Tethering. Teaser will man mit... heißt was anderes.
Ich schreib's hundertmal an die Wand.
Tethering, Tethering, Tethering.
Das ist...
Das ist auch mit dem Schlips.
Mit dem Schlips?
Na, mit dem CL.
Okay, Tethering. Und darüber konnte man sich das einfach freischalten und das geht halt jetzt nicht mehr mit der neuen Ice-Type, sondern mit der neuesten 3.0-Beta...
Fünf.
Don't tether me, bro.
Und...
Das heißt dann auch nicht Ethernet, sondern Ethernet?
Du kennst doch bestimmt Don't taze me, bro. Das ist ein Internet-Meme. Na ja, das ist kein Internet-Meme. Das ist ein Media-Meme. Ah, das ist dieser Typ in Kanada, der irgendwie zur Tode gethäsert wurde und vorher sagte er aber halt noch irgendwie Don't taze me, bro.
Memes da vielleicht ein bisschen.
Ja, ich hab das jetzt alles nicht gesagt. Ich geb's dir zu. Ich halt's maul. Erzähl weiter.
Ja, auf jeden Fall wird das, wenn das mit der finalen Version nicht mehr möglich sein wird und wenn das bei T-Mobile nicht möglich sein wird, dann diesen Tazering-Modus zu nutzen, dann ist das ein weiterer Grund für einen Jailbreak.
Vermutlich mal. Das wär auf jeden Fall ein guter Grund, nicht auf T-Mobile zu wechseln. Ich erwege das.
Du erwägst doch zu T-Mobile zu wechseln?
Naja, ich erwe... also, naja, also... Ich schließe nicht vollständig aus, dass wenn das neue iPhone kommt und es keinen bezahlbaren und gangbaren und vor allem nur schnell abzuwickeln Weg gibt, an dieses Gerät zu kommen, außer einen Vertrag abzuschließen. Und es gäbe die Möglichkeit, weil mein altes iPhone, der Trend geht zum zweiten iPhone, dann hätte ich sozusagen dieses Gerät noch fürs Ausland und mein Hauptkritikpunkt, dass ich im Ausland halt gemolken werde, wäre insofern einfach dahin, weil ich halt nach wie vor mein altes Gerät habe und mit dem könnte ich dann halt immer noch das gleiche machen. Und für in Deutschland hätte ich dann eben sozusagen einen neuen Vertrag, auch wenn das natürlich bedeutet, wie ist denn das, kann man eigentlich Mobilfunknummern übernehmen? Nee, ne? Kann ich meine 0179-Nummer zu Telekom umziehen?
Aber das geht mittlerweile schon. Ja, nee, das geht auf jeden Fall.
Ja gut, das wäre sozusagen dann, also wäre ein Argument. Aber das hängt voll vom Tarif ab. Und wenn sie halt Tethering nicht machen, dann können sie es einfach vergessen. Oder, also ich meine, ich will halt auch mit dem Rechner und so weiter.
Also ich bin, also wenn wir jetzt gerade schon mal so bei Tarifen sind, ich finde diese Symmio-Tarife gar nicht so schlecht. Und noch sind sie Sponsor von O2, diese neuen Tarife, finde ich auch nicht scheiße. Die haben da sowas.
Ah, da gibt es einen neuen Tarif.
So eine versteckte Flat, die dann irgendwann kommt.
Ja, die haben dieses, wie heißt das, O2O. Und das ist, du hast keine Grundgebühren, glaube ich. Du zahlst 15 Cent in alle Netze und für alle SMS. Und wenn du aber mehr als 60 Euro im Monat hast.
Genau, gibt es seit einer Woche.
Genau, dann ist das bei 60 Euro dann quasi gedeckelt. Nee, es ist bei 60 Euro gedeckelt.
Also 60 Euro flat telefonieren.
Nee, also wenn du weniger als 60 Euro verbrauchst, also du telefonierst, wie du magst, für 15 Cent pro Minute. Und wenn du nur drei Minuten telefonierst, dann zahlst du eine 45 Cent. Wenn du aber extrem viel telefonierst, wenn du 1000 Minuten telefonierst und hättest normalerweise eine absurd hohe Telefonrechnung, dann ist die bei 60 Euro gedeckelt.
Die Flatrate beginnt bei 60 Euro.
Ja, also Mindestverbrauch. Nee, nicht Mindestverbrauch.
Maximal Verbrauch.
Aber nicht für alles, sondern da ist SMS drin und irgendwie...
Telefonieren, in alle Netze.
Genau, aber nicht ins Ausland oder so.
Nicht in alle deutschen Netze. Und was ist mit Datentarif?
Mit Datentarif ist da nicht dabei, aber sie haben auch einen neuen Datentarif, 200 Megabyte für einen Zehner.
Den gibt es ja schon ewig.
Ja, wobei vorher wurde es danach teuer und jetzt drosseln sie es runter auf GPS-Geschwindigkeit. Zumindest auch, dass man da nicht auf die Fresse fliegt zumindest am Ende des Monats. Und es gibt irgendwie eine Datenflatrate für einen Tag, für 350. Also für einen Tag kannst du sagen, heute brauch ich eine Datenflatrate und dann boost die für 350 dazu. Also es ist nicht das Beste, was man kriegen kann, glaube ich. Also bei Sumio ist es ein bisschen günstiger, wobei Sumio hat das Problem, die sind ja im E-Plus-Netz, die haben kein HSDPR, die haben immer nur UMTS-Geschränkigkeit. Egal, wo du bist. Und ich weiß nicht, da hast du 10 Gigabyte für 10 Euro oder irgendwie sowas. Auch monatlich.
Aber slow halt.
Aber nur UMTS.
Also ich finde ja das T-Mobile-Netz auch insofern interessant, als dass es einfach deutlich besser ausgebaut ist, so auf Bahnstrecken.
Das Lustige ist aber, dass da, wo ich mich gerade meistens aufhalte, z.B. in meiner Wohnung, ich überhaupt keinen T-Mobile-Empfang habe. Auch keinen Vodafone-Empfang. Aber E-Plus und O2 funktioniert hervorragend.
Na gut, aber in der Stadt kannst du dich dann immer noch beschweren.
Ich hab zu Hause keinen O2-Empfang und ich hab halt O2. Voll bekloppt.
Da hattest du dich schon lange gewechselt.
Ja, dann nimm doch Skype. Auch wenn es bei T-Mobile irgendwie nicht so gut ankommt.
Gerade kurz beim iPhone muss ich noch eine Sache hinterher schieben. Das Apple hat jetzt den Developern gesagt, Jungs hier, alle eure Programme, die ab heute, also es war vorgestern oder vor ein paar Tagen, alle Programme, die jetzt irgendwie da zum, wie sagt man, zum Appstore eingereicht werden, müssen auf unter 3.0 laufen. Wenn die nicht unter 3.0 laufen, werden sie nicht mehr akzeptiert. Und in der Zukunft ist so, alle Programme, die auch schon im Store sind, also alle 30.000, die Programme, die nicht unter 3.0 laufen, werden rausgeschmissen.
Wann geht das los, dass die rausfliegen?
Ist schon so.
Ist schon so?
Also die, die drin sind, noch nicht. Das ist erst dann, wenn 3.0 rauskommt, weil die können ja noch ein paar Sachen dran drehen und so. Aber alles, was jetzt eingereicht wird, muss unter 3.0 auch funktionieren. Es muss 3.0 Features nicht benutzen. Es kann weiterhin für 2.0 entwickelt sein oder sonstiges. Aber es muss auch sauber unter 3.0 laufen.
Ja, aber das ist dann, wenn 3.0 draußen ist, dass es dann auch unter 3.0 laufen muss. Alles, was im Appstore ist.
Nein, auch wenn es nicht weiterentwickelt wird, also auch die bisherigen Versionen, also wenn sich nichts an deinem Programm ändert, so wie es jetzt im Appstore ist, aber es aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht unter 3.0 läuft, fliegt es raus.
Genau, also wenn du zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt irgendwelche hidden Features benutzt oder sonstiges, die dann bei 3.0 nicht mehr da sind oder nicht freigeben sind oder wie auch immer, kann man ja so machen irgendwie. Private Apis benutzt, die nicht da sind, und dann fliegst du raus.
Es könnte natürlich sein, dass Apple einen Fehler in 3.0 einbaut und dass ein Programm auf einmal nicht mehr läuft, obwohl es eigentlich laufen müsste.
Absichtlich meinste?
Nö, unabsichtlich. Also absichtlich, warum sollten sie das tun? Aber so ein Regression-Bug kann ja sehr wohl sein.
Klar. Ja, aber man kann ja nicht den Kunden zumuten, dass die sich dann am Endeffekt auf ihrem neuen, schicken 3.0-iPhone gerade aktualisiert. Genau, du hast halt schon 30 Euro pro Gramm oder sowas und dann geht das einfach nicht.
Auf jeden Fall treiben sie alle ganz schön vor sich her. Sie wollen einfach jetzt den nächsten Schritt und 3.0 ist schon echt ein Riesenschritt, wollen sie einfach gnadenlos durchsetzen.
Na, aber ist doch gut, du kannst ja bei deiner Software angeben, ab welcher Version sie läuft. Also ich kann ja klicken, meine Software läuft ab 2.0 oder ich könnte auch genauso gut klicken, meine Version. Also meine Software läuft erst ab Version 2.2. Das heißt, nur dann würde das wahrscheinlich im Store angezeigt. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es genau machen. Und natürlich wollen die nicht noch irgendwie, dass man sagt, meine Version läuft ab 2.2, aber sie läuft nicht mehr ab 3.0, weil dann blickst du ja auch gar nicht mehr durch. Deswegen wollten sie alles, was drin ist, hat zwar eine Minimum-Anforderung, aber keine Maximum-Anforderung. Und das ist doch gut. Und dass man ein bisschen sauber gehalten wird.
Ich finde das auch gut. Ich meine, das zwingt auch Apple da, ordentliche Arbeit zu leisten.
Ja, und nicht nur Apple, sondern die Developer auch. Das alle sauber irgendwie promieren. Und am Ende hat der User auch was davon.
Also das finde ich tatsächlich mal eine App Store-Einschränkung, die ich sinnvoll finde.
Ja, ich habe auch irgendeinen Artikel gelesen, wo sich irgendjemand da drüber aufgeregt hat. Und die Argumentation war so dermaßen Hanebüchen, dass man sich manchmal schon wirklich an den Kopf fasst, was manche Leute so treibt. Ja, also er meinte so, ja, wenn mein Programm eine Library benutzt von Third Party, über die ich nicht den Source Code habe und die wird nicht aktualisiert, dann könnte es ja sein, dass mein Programm nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ja, aber wenn dein Programm nicht mehr funktioniert, dann kannst du es nicht mehr verkaufen.
Sind aber echt an den Haaren herbeigezogen, oder?
Jaja, also konkret war davon die Rede von so einer Library, die tatsächlich von so einem Werbe-Menschen, also so ein Ad-Network irgendwie, dass du halt Werbung in dein Programm einbauen kannst und so weiter, so wie das halt die ganzen Twitter-Klines oder manche zumindest machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die diese Library benutzen, aber sowas war das. Aber dann meinen sie halt im nächsten Zug auch schon wieder, naja, wir entwickeln das ja auch weiter und so weiter. Also ich meine, wer sowas in sein Programm einbaut, ein Binary-Blob, was nicht weiterentwickelt wird, der hat dann auch im Upstart echt nichts zu suchen. Also ich finde den Zug auch völlig in Ordnung. Ich habe jetzt nichts gehört, was da...
Und das läuft ja auch alles. Also wenn man nicht irgendwie böses Zeug präumt, sollte eigentlich alles ganz normal unter 3.0 laufen.
Ja, also wo wir jetzt schon beim iPhone sind, in dem Zusammenhang, ihr werdet ja auch gehört haben, dass die iPhone-Developer jetzt hurra geschrien haben, dass sie jetzt endlich diese Crash-Reports bekommen.
Ja, habe ich auch gehört.
Sie haben sozusagen die Schleife jetzt auch endlich geschlossen. Du hast das gehört oder du kriegst jetzt auch Crash-Reports? Ich habe noch keine.
Nein, mein Programm crash nicht.
Oder benutzt das vielleicht keiner?
Da kann ich keine Auskunft drüber geben.
Nein, nein. Ja gut, also du hast noch keinen gesehen sozusagen. Ja, also das ist jetzt noch kein Zuall. Weil es taucht ja dann diesem iTunes-Connect irgendwie mit auf, was die Developer verwenden. Also da, wo du halt auch deine Software hochlädst und so. Und dann kannst du halt schön sehen, so hier, dieser Fehler ist auch getaucht. Und jetzt haben sie halt endlich mal die Möglichkeit, das zu machen. Jetzt werden natürlich alle auf der World Wide Developers-Konferenz wonachschreien.
Sag's!
Na die Macintosh-Developer wollen das natürlich auch haben.
Ach so!
Weil seit Jahr und Tag schicken wir Crash-Reports an Apple für irgendwelche Programme. Und nur Apple kriegt sie.
Na außer, die entsprechenden Programme haben eine Bibliothek eingebaut, die die Crash-Reports abfängt und zu ihnen selber weiter zu fahren. Ja, wär natürlich schön, wenn das ginge. Überhaupt finde ich es mal ganz schön, gerade im App Store finde ich immer nach wie vor relativ doof, dass so dieser Kontakt zu den Entwicklern so komplett über Apple geht.
Das finden die glaube ich auch doof.
Also, dass man zum Beispiel, wenn man bei auch ein Programm, wenn es über einen App Store verlinkt ist, dass man das unter Umständen gar nicht bei Google so richtig gut findet und so. Und wenn man Supportanfragen hat, sieht man die, ist das auch immer schwer, sich darum zu, also so, nicht Supportanfragen, sondern wenn ich eine Frage zu einem Programm habe, ist das relativ schwer, den Entwickler dazu zu finden. Fände ich besser, wenn Apple mal dran arbeiten würde.
Ja. Das wär toll. Wär das toll.
Achso, aber was nochmal für eure, ein bisschen für eure 3G-Theorie doch spricht, wenn auch nicht sehr.
Mit diesem Developer, den die da eingestellt haben?
Nein, nicht nur das, sondern dass ich, ich hab gehört, dass in Snow Leopard werden, wohl so USB-Sticks, UMTS-Sticks vielen nativ unterstützt werden.
Nein.
Ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr, wo ich das hatte. Wirklich?
Ja. Das hab ich, ich glaube, bei Arztesika. Also dann ist es doch jetzt...
Dieses W-Warn-Slider, den du da in den Network-Prefs gesehen hast oder irgendwo?
Hm?
Dieses W-Warn.
Dass sie in den USA einige Karten serienmäßig unterstützen, das ist ja nichts Neues. Das gibt's ja schon lange.
Apple Insider hatte das. Snow Leopard to support native 3G wireless Warn-Hardware.
Na ja, aber das ist ja nichts Neues. Das war ja schon... Das ist ja heute schon so. Also es gibt ja einige Karten, die in den USA... So Verizon, diese, na wie heißt das noch gleich, diese e-Video Netzwerke, also so bestimmte populäre Karten, auch 3G, werden in den USA von Apple schon unterstützt. Also die Treiber sind im OS schon mit dabei, aber eben nur für diese paar Karten. Und ich hab schon immer darauf gewartet, dass das sozusagen mal, ja, dass das sozusagen umfangreicher wird. Wenn sie jetzt tatsächlich noch mehr Treiber selber bereitstellen oder zumindest irgendwie mit ausliefern, keine Ahnung, und man eben dann auf so Tools wie Launch-Tournet verzichten könnte, das wär natürlich super. Aber...
Also es gibt wohl im System Profiler, gibt's wohl einen neuen Tab links unter Network, wo dann W-Bahn drinne steht.
Das spricht wiederum für eingebaute Hardware. Und das wär mir auch viel lieber als so ein Dommel, weil da haben wir glaub ich schon mal drüber gesprochen, oder?
Ich glaub, wir haben das schon mal drüber gesprochen.
Ja, du kannst ja noch mal sagen, was für mich wichtig ist, ich will halt, dass dieses Teil ein Device im OS ist, so wie im iPhone, also dass es wirklich ein Systemlevel-Zugriff darauf gibt, dass da nicht eine eigene Firmware sozusagen unabhängig von dem OS agiert, damit eben dieser Reconnect besser funktioniert. Bei so einem iPhone, wenn du halt mit der Bahn fährst, das sieht ja alle Netze auch, in denen es nicht ist. Während, wenn du jetzt mit so einer normalen UMTS-Karte arbeitest, da hast du halt immer diesen PPP-Kram dazwischen und so, und das heißt, du hast immer dieses Anwahlversuch und dann schaut der ja überhaupt erst noch, ob er in dieses eine Netzwerk reinkommt, so. Aber es ist nicht ein permanentes Monitoring, wo er wirklich mal schaut, was haben wir denn, und dann irgendwie selektiv in eigener Zuständigkeit da einfach reinmarschiert und dann eben einfach auch eine viel bessere Connectivity halten kann. Also ich verspreche mir davon, erstens weniger Zeug mit rumschleppen, zweitens weniger Kompatibilitätsprobleme, drittens nicht irgendwelche bekloppten Ho Chi Minh, Taiwan Flower Power Enterprises Treiber, die einen einfach zum Wahnsinn bringen, von den User Interfaces dafür mal ganz abgesehen, sondern halt einfach eine solide Integration in mein Netzwerk-Kontrollpanel und so, wie es einfach schon hätte seit Ewigkeiten schon immer sein müssen. Und jetzt wird es langsam auch wirklich Zeit. Ich habe echt Schnauze voll.
Und Sticks will ich auch nicht haben.
Aber es wird ja eine ganze Menge. Gut. Was ich jetzt auch geflüstert bekommen habe, ist das in der neuesten Beta 5, bisher glaube ich die aktuelle, vom iPhone OS 3.0. Take it with a grain of salt, weil ich habe da jetzt noch keine zweite Confirmation gefunden, aber angeblich gehen jetzt Bluetooth-Tastaturen mit dem iPhone. Nativ? Ich habe keine da. Ja, nativ. Also naja, keine Ahnung. Mir würde schon die Apple-Tastatur reichen, die finde ich schon recht reisefähig. Also die Apple-Bluetooth-Tastatur, die kleine, die kann man schon ganz gut in eine Tasche stecken. Die ist so groß nicht, die passt schon so irgendwo an der Seite rein. Es geht natürlich noch kleiner, gar keine Frage, aber das ist dann halt auch eine richtige Tastatur. Und wenn du die dann wirklich dein iPhone auf den Tisch legen kannst, diese Tastatur auspackst und dann deine Mails und deinen ganzen Kram damit schreiben könntest, das wäre der Brüller. Ich meine, ich merke ja jetzt schon, dass ich eigentlich in neun von zehn Fällen, wo ich noch vor wenigen Jahren mit dem Laptop aus der Tür gegangen wäre, wenn ich auch... Jetzt ein iPhone reicht. Wie das iPhone reicht. Ich weiß, ich hab mein iPhone und irgendwie Mail, Twitter, zwei, drei andere Dienste hab ich.
Die wesentliche Komplikation ist da.
Genau. Und dafür brauch ich einfach keinen Laptop mehr. Und mit der Tastatur, sagen wir mal acht von zehn Fällen. Und dann gibt es aber einen von den zehn Fällen, wo ich irgendwie den Laptop trotzdem noch mitnehme und das würde dann sozusagen mit der Tastatur auch noch wegfallen.
Ich würde es ja...
Zehn von zehn ist, wenn du halt wirklich einen Laptop brauchst.
Ich gehe doch mal davon aus, dass dann Apple auch als Zubehör so eine schicke kleine Bluetooth-Tastatur irgendwie hinpacken würde. Habt ihr wohl so sehr wie Steve Jobs Tastatur?
Nein, sie haben ja eine Bluetooth-Tastatur, die wunderbar ist, was ihre Anforderungen an Tastatur auch entspricht.
Naja, aber so richtig geil ist das halt auch nicht.
Dann kannst du dir immer noch Ho Chi Minh Scheiße kaufen. Da kannst du dir deine Acer XBG3-45LJ kaufen. Oder wie die heißen, du weißt diese sinnlosen Produktnamen, die das Marketing weltweit immer noch glaubt, dass irgendjemand drauf abfahren würde.
Da kann ich ja gleich noch ein paar Storys erzählen.
Sogar bei Sony. Ja, und die würde dann vielleicht unter Umständen auch laufen. Aber die müssen ja auch die richtigen Tastaturen haben und so. Und die Tastnamen, die haben ja keine Option-Taste und so. Wir kommen so ein bisschen davon ab. Aber wäre auf jeden Fall schön, wenn das mal drin wäre. Ja, dann habe ich auch noch ein zweites Gerücht gehört. Nämlich, dass da so ein Find-Your-iPhone-Feature kommen soll. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Aber irgendwas haben sie so... Ich tippe mal auf so einen Klauschutz. Oder so ein, wo habe ich es liegen lassen, Dingsbums. Ist mir vollkommen unklar. Ich habe da keine weiteren Informationen dazu.
Wo habe ich es in meiner Wohnung liegen lassen? Das wäre auch mal was Kleines.
Wenn es WLAN hat, kann man es ja anquatschen eigentlich.
Na ja, du hast auch 3G drin.
Ich glaube, es hat eher sowas mit GPS und so zu tun, dass du dieses Feature auf deinem iPhone einschaltest und dann trackst du sozusagen dein iPhone.
Die ganze Zeit?
Na ja, sodass der letzte Aufenthaltsort, solange es online ist, in irgendeiner Form irgendwo abgelegt ist. Angenommen, sie würden das mit.Mac koppeln.
Klar, weil die wollen ja Geld verdienen.
Mobile Me.
Äh, richtig. Mobile Me. Und das ist ja nur wirklich mal dein Mobile Me, wenn du dein iPhone irgendwo vergeigt hast. Und dann kannst du halt auf die Webseite dich einloggen in dein Mobile Me und dann fragst du, wo ist mein iPhone? Und dann sagt er, da. Und dann hast du da so Google Maps und so. Und dann ist es halt da.
Na im Idealfall ginge das natürlich ohne Mobile Me, weil wenn es hier geklaut worden ist und du hast es einmal auf deinen Namen registriert sozusagen. Also Mobile Me würde ja durch ein Factory Set wärs ja wieder flöten. Diese Information wahrscheinlich. Nein, nicht zwangsläufig.
Ja es geht in gewisser Hinsicht um geklaut und in gewisser Hinsicht geht es vielleicht halt auch um...
Wenn du dann diese E-Mail-Nummer nehmen könnt, also wenn die quasi irgendwo gespeichert werden würde und sobald das Ding wieder eingeschaltet wird, ist es lokalisierbar.
Jaja klar, aber da musst du dann halt schon irgendwie durch die Polizei gehen und so.
Klar, weil ich meine, sagt der Polizei, mein iPhone wurde geklaut und sagt...
Ja aber denk mal so Parental Controls mäßig, so irgendwie, das Kind hat jetzt auch ein iPhone und ein GPS und... Es ist nicht so sehr ein Find-My-iPhone, mehr so ein Find-My-Teenager.
So rauskriegen, wo die sich wirklich rumtreiben.
Ja genau, auf welcher Bilden Party sie gerade irgendwie...
Es gab doch so eine absurd dämliche Software fürs Android. Und zwar, das war auch für Eltern, die ihren Kindern so ein Android-Telefon schenken sollte. Und das hat automatisch die Telefonie abgeschaltet, sobald man sich mit einer Geschwindigkeit von mehr als so und so viel Mind pro Stunde bewegt hat. Oder mit einer höheren Geschwindigkeit. Gedanke dahinter war, dass die Teenager-Kinder nicht während der Autofahrt telefonieren. Und nicht SMSen und so. Was das natürlich alles nicht bedacht hat. Erstens, dass der Akku unglaublich schnell leer ist. Zweitens, dass es ja die potenzielle Möglichkeit gibt, dass man Beifahrer ist oder auch im Zug sitzt oder sonst wie irgendwas. Also es war so ein dämliches Programm. Aber das wäre damit theoretisch natürlich auch möglich irgendwann mal.
Es gibt so tolle Software für Android. Und wo wir noch bei der Hardware-Gerüchte-Küche rund ums iPhone sind, was mir ziemlich sicher zu sein scheint, ist ja, dass dieser digitale Kompass mit reinkommt ins nächste Jahr zu reden.
Stimmt. Das sieht doch ziemlich sicher aus.
Ja, mit diesen ganzen Screenshots und so. Also da hab ich jetzt mittlerweile überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel. Ehrlich gesagt, da wär ich auch schwer überrascht, wenn sie das jetzt nicht nachrüsten. Ich meine, wenn sogar das Telefon mit Google das hat.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, beim Telefon mit Google hat der Kompass nach meiner Erfahrung eher unterirdisch funktioniert.
Ja, so war das auch mit dem GPS in dem Nokia N95.
Das stimmt.
Ja, deswegen muss Apple das halt mal ordentlich machen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und ich fänd das schon eine coole Nummer.
Und eine bessere Kamera.
Eine bessere Kamera, ja.
Und Video wird dann kommen, ne? Ja, das war alles schon.
Das haben wir ja auch schon mal besprochen.
Kaltes Kaffee.
Das Kompass ist irgendwie neu.
Wollen wir noch auf meine anderen neuen Spielzeuge mal so ein bisschen drauf rumreiten? Nee.
Weil ich finde, wir können jetzt mal einfach das Thema iPhone abschließend behandeln.
Okay.
Und dann kommen wir auf den anderen.
Abschließend für heute oder?
Ja, weil wir sind schon so weggesprungen vom Mac-Kram.
Das stimmt, wir sind gerade so ein bisschen. Was hast du da noch zum Thema iPhone?
Ich hab da noch zum Thema iPhone neue Applikationen. Abgelehnte und nicht-abgelehnte. Was du schon erwähnt hast, war ja hier diese Transmission-Fernbedienung.
Das hab ich im Vorgespräch erwähnt.
Ist das denn eigentlich nicht, geht das nicht eigentlich über Web, die Fernbedienung? Ich meine, Transmission hat doch ein Web-Sawyer.
WC-Interface, das heißt, du kannst auch ein Programm schreiben, was direkt sozusagen deren Interface anspricht.
Na ja, okay, dann haben wir eine richtige eigene API. Und das haben sie gesperrt mit dieser Shady-Geschichte, mit kann auch für urheberrechtliche, oder kann auch ein Web-Browser auch für verwenden.
Und die haben im Kommentar auch dabei, da müssten wir Safari jetzt ja auch sperren, weil über Safari kann man dieses Clutch benutzen, was sozusagen das Web-Interface für den Transmission ist. Und, ja.
Das ist cheesy, oder? Man kann über die Telefonfunktion, kann man Urnen...
Also die kann man nie einbauen in iTunes. Na, sie werden bitter und nie einbauen in iTunes. Das ist mir in dem Moment wieder bewusst geworden. Also zumindest nicht so lange alle noch so dermaßen am Rad drehen. Naja, aber es haben ja auch ein paar Applikationen geschafft. Und, ähm, wo sich ja viele Leute gefragt haben, wofür man das gebrauchen kann. Und ich hab auch ehrlich gesagt nur eine eingeschränkte Antwort da drauf. Aber ich finde absolut bemerkenswert, hatte allerdings noch nicht so richtig viel Zeit, das zu testen, Bento. Bento find ich schon auf dem Macintosh-Stamp. Von FileMaker. Das ist ein Tool, das ist unter dem Radar von allen. Und ich glaube, ungerechtfertigterweise.
Ich glaube absolut gerechtfertigterweise. Das ist so eine Mini-Datenbank für den Heimgebrauch, oder?
Das ist eine Desktop-Database. Der Macintosh war, wenn man mal von Microsoft Access absieht, schon immer eigentlich so vorne mit Desktop-Databases, seinerzeit noch mit Hypercard. Und dann kam halt FileMaker, und FileMaker zeigte halt jetzt auch schon seit längerer Zeit Spuren von Alter. Und also wer FileMaker kennt, der wird mir zustimmen. Das war schon einfach lange nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Und vor allem fehlte auch schon seit längerer Zeit der Schritt ins Mac OS X. Und ich hatte mir gedacht, naja, ob sie das nochmal irgendwie neu geschrieben bekommen. Und das haben sie jetzt getan. Und zwar haben sie es anders gemacht, als ich dachte. Ich dachte, sie werden dann irgendwann nochmal ein Filemaker X und jetzt irgendwie auch alles richtig Mac OS X. Tatsächlich sind sie noch radikaler beigegangen und haben halt dieses Bento gemacht. Und Bento ist insofern sehr cool, als dass es sich eben extrem viel besser verzahnt in Mac OS X. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du mit deinem Adressbuch, also mit dem Programm-Adressbuch, noch nie so richtig glücklich warst, weil du einfach komplexe Abfragen damit nicht machen kannst und irgendwie nicht so Sachen einfach aussortieren kannst, weil du einfach nur dieses Kinderkarten-Interface hast. Es gibt ja das Adressbuch-Interface als API im Betriebssystem. Und Bento ist halt ein Client dafür. Aber halt so ein Editing-Client dafür. Das heißt, du kannst generisch auf dem Mac OS X-Adressbuch rumsuchen und so weiter. Das gleiche geht auch mit Kalender. Und ich vermute, dass alle Data Stores, die in Mac OS X in irgendeiner Form zugänglich sind bzw. noch zugänglich gemacht werden, in irgendeiner Form in Bento landen. Zusätzlich dazu hast du auch noch die Möglichkeit, wie in FileMaker, eine generische Desktop-Database zu machen. Das heißt, du definierst dir halt so ein Record-Set und hast dann eben so eine generische Oberfläche, mit der du einerseits dir ein User-Interface machen kannst, aber andererseits eben da drin suchen kannst und so weiter. Also wenn du den Bedarf hast für...
Also so Masken-Erstellung meinst du?
Ja, genau. Aber wenn du einfach Daten sammeln willst, weißt du, wo andere Leute, wo Nerds dann vielleicht sich eine SQL-Datenbank aufmachen. Bloß du weißt, wie das ist mit SQL-Datenbanken. Es riecht und stinkt und man will das einfach gar nicht. Man will eigentlich eine Guje haben und man will sagen, ich hab jetzt hier folgende Datenstruktur und davon will ich halt Ende erfassen und dann hab ich da auch noch gewisse Relationen dazwischen. Und das geht halt mit Bento. Und Bento ist einfach mal Mac OS X from the ground up. Also da haben sie wirklich sozusagen diesen Ansatz Desktop Database für OS X komplett neu gemacht. Richtig cool ist, dass es das jetzt eben auch fürs iPhone gibt. Und erstens hast du ein Syncing. Also du kannst eben deine Databases auf Mac pflegen mit Bento und erstellen damit und du kannst es eben auch Synken aufs iPhone. Das hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Aber du kannst eben mit dem Bento auf dem iPhone auch vollständig unabhängig von der Macintosh Applikation machen. Das heißt, du kannst auch da deine Masken machen und kannst halt einfach Daten sammeln. Stell dir vor, du hast jetzt so, du musst halt so vor Ort irgendwelche Dinge erfassen. Irgendwas, ja, du bist halt in the field und unter anderem gehört es einfach zu deinem Job, solche Daten zu erfassen. Dann kannst du das eben mit diesem Bento einfach machen. Du kannst eben selber sagen, was für Daten du erfasst. Dann kannst du das eben relativ einfach auch wieder auf Mac bringen, wenn du eben Bento auch auf Mac verwendest. Und ich glaube, das ist eine ganz coole Plattform.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dass so Datenbanken, also Desktop-Datenbanken sind irgendwie nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Das ist definitiv was in die Wolke gehört. Also ich warte auf Google Database. Weil ich möchte an einer Datenbank nicht alleine arbeiten. Ich möchte...
Ich hab ein neues Wort gerade. Ein Google Fanboy.
Also Google Database ist jetzt einfach nur, weil das in die Google Docs ganz gut reinpassen würde.
Das passt auch ganz gut zu Google.
Weil Datenbanken da stehen ja voll darauf bestimmt.
Und so ein Tool, mit dem ich einfach auf eine Webseite gehe, also ja, so eine Adressbuchintegration und so was, so eine native Desktop-Integration wäre schon schick. Da gebe ich dir absolut recht. Aber was ich für wichtiger halte, ist das guck mal hier, greif mal auf die Datenbank zu. Hier kannst du mit mir zusammen dran arbeiten. Ich brauch keinen Syncing zu machen, um auf dem iPhone und auf dem Desktop zu arbeiten. Sondern ich hab's einfach da. Ich mach's auf dem Desktop auf. Ach, das gibt doch mittlerweile mit den ganz offline Datenbankern.
Ja, dann brauchst du aber trotzdem User Interface, was das macht. Und du brauchst halt eine User Interface, mit dem du den ganzen Scheiß einrichten kannst. Das ist Bento. Also dem brauchen sie sozusagen die Cloud nur noch hinzuzufügen. Und mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn auch Bento über kurz oder lang bei MobileMe landet.
Das würde mich schon sehr wundern, weil FileMaker eine Firma ist, die komplett unabhängig von Apple ist. Und nach wie vor nicht aufgekauft worden ist, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
FileMaker ist Apple.
filemaker.com gehört zu Apple?
Ja, schon immer.
FileMaker ist schon immer Apple. Nein, die ist Clarisse.
Ja, Clarisse hat irgendwann mal sich umbenannt in filemaker.com.
Ja, Clarisse gehört aber auch schon immer Apple.
Das erste, was die ausgelagert haben in einer eigenen Firma, aber es gehört Apple.
Gehört es nach wie vor 100% zu Apple?
Ja, ob es 100% ist, aber warum sollten die es verkaufen?
Weil Apple damals alles verkauft hat.
Nein.
Was haben die denn alles verkauft?
Die haben überhaupt nichts verkauft.
Wahrscheinlich bereuen sie es bis heute, dass sie ihre Arme verkauft haben.
Sie haben bloß über die Zeit von Clarisse, also die Geschichte von Clarisse und Filemaker, dass sie halt die ganze Zeit immer wieder das in Apple hineingezogen haben und wieder aus Apple herausgenommen haben. Also es gab immer unterschiedliche Phasen, in wie weit das drin war. Und sowas wie Apple Works zum Beispiel war ja vorher Clarisse Works.
Ja, aber Apple, ja klar, aber ich meine, das weiß ich, aber ich dachte sie hätten noch irgendwann mal aus Filemaker Inc., also das ist ja eine Firma, die es nach wie vor gibt. Und ich dachte, die sind einfach unabhängig.
Ja, die arbeiten unabhängig, aber sie gehören Apple.
Ja, das hätte ja auch sein können, dass sie einfach hier eine Börse gebracht haben oder verkloppt haben oder weiß ja was.
Ja, hätte.
Ja, ich dachte es.
Ist aber nicht. Das heißt, Bento ist ein Apple-Produkt in Anführungsstrichen. Ja. Das ist so wie Logic Pro.
Logic Pro ist doch aber direkt bei Apple, oder?
Ja, aber das ist...
Also auf der Apple-Seite steht nirgendswo ein Wort. Also steht doch das Wort Filemaker vermutlich nicht auf.
Ja, gut, okay. War insofern jetzt ein blöder Vergleich, als dass das halt Apple gerendet ist. Gar keine Frage. Genauso wie Final Cut. Nur, du kannst davon ausgehen, dass das Logic-Development nach wie vor in Deutschland stattfindet. Also das ist... Die haben jetzt nicht alle in die USA geflogen, weil Audio-Software...
Achso, ja, klar...
.findet nach wie vor in Deutschland statt, und zwar im Wesentlichen in Berlin und in Hamburg. Und im Falle von Logic halt in Hamburg. Wie auch immer. Was ich meine ist, ist eine eigenständige Identität. Im Falle von Filemaker ist es halt so, dass sie eben auch komplett unappelig auftreten, eine eigene Marke sind und so weiter. Das ist halt ihre Entscheidung. Allerdings zeigt mir halt so ein Produkt wie Bento, dass da schon, ja, die unterhalten sich mit ihren Eigentümern von Zeit zu Zeit auch. Und sie kriegen da wohl auch schon was mit. Bento ist so klar Mac OS X, dass es auch genauso gut Apple Bento heißen könnte.
Also es sah auf den ersten Blick, es ist einfach eine gute native Coco-Applikation. Wobei es kann ich ansatzweise so viel wie FileMaker, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, ja. Und ich vermisse, wie gesagt, ich vermisse dieses Multi-User. Und dieses Multi-User übers Netz, und zwar nicht über irgendein scheiß lokales Netzwerk, wo ich dann wie mit FileMaker hier mal sharen kann oder sowas, sondern Internet. Und im Idealfall, wie gesagt, an jedem Gerät im Webbrowser. Das finde ich besser.
Ja, ich denke, dass Bento ist am Anfang. Also die haben jetzt erstmal das Minimum gemacht, was einfach nötig war, und darauf bauen sie auf.
Und...
Ich bin da einfach zuversichtlich. Vielleicht liege ich da auch falsch.
Worin Apple tatsächlich immer sehr schlecht ist, was bei einer Google-Daten mag wahrscheinlich auch besser wäre, dass sie irgendwelche APIs hätten, mit denen man die Dinger von außen ansprechen kann und dann eben... Also was ich schick finden würde, du ziehst dir irgendeine Datenbank auf, so wie ein Filemaker oder ein Bento oder weißt der Teufel was, legst deine Felder an, hast nichts mit SQL zu tun, baust das erstmal zurecht, hast dann irgendwann mal eine große Datenbasis, stellst fest, jetzt will ich den ganzen Scheißdreck wieder raushaben. Und möchtest es gerne in einer anderen Form verwenden. Und dann eine vernünftige API, mit der man das machen kann, wäre großartig. Weil aus Filemaker kriegt man aus Filemaker Daten wieder raus.
Das ist ein Drama für sich. Du meinst jetzt irgendwie live?
Nicht nur live, sondern auch ein reiner Export. Also man kann theoretisch die Daten als CSV-Datei exportieren.
Du kannst das richtig schön in XML exportieren.
Ja, aber Bildmaterial, was da drin ist, ist ein Mal für ein und für immer in Filemaker gefangen. Ich muss zugeben, das ist das vor ein paar Jahren her, dass ich mich damit mal beschäftigt habe. Oder beschäftigen musste. Bilde, Formatierungen in Texten waren damals auch unwiderruflich.
Also gar keine Frage, Filemaker war irgendwie...
Wir haben den Anschluss ein bisschen verpasst.
Es riecht ein bisschen. Trotzdem gibt es eben auch nichts, was auch nur im Ansatz so universell dich schnell zu einer Datenbank bringt.
Der Gedanke, ich finde, nach wie vor...
Filemaker sehr erfolgreich für viele Sachen benutzt und da gab es einfach keine Alternative.
Bist du nicht der, der von dem Filemaker weg wollte und deswegen gibt es jetzt den Pentabank?
Ja, klar, natürlich. Ja, logisch, aber weil es halt ein Internet sein sollte. Ja, logisch. Und weil es halt auch, naja, klar, weil es nicht in dem Maße... Aber das ist halt eine Desktop-Database. Ja, es ist gemacht für den Desktop und ich wollte es aber nicht mehr auf dem Desktop haben. Von daher, klar, jetzt ist es halt auch so eine stinkende SQL-Datenbank.
Ja, ich hätte den Übergang gerne ein bisschen fließender. Also schön so Felder aufziehen. Ich mache hier meine Datenbankstruktur, ohne überhaupt mitzukriegen, dass ich eine Datenbankstruktur mache, so ähnlich wie ein Filemaker, vielleicht sogar noch einen Zacken eleganter. Ja, aber das ist ja so bei Bento. Ja, genau, aber dann eben mit Internet dahinter. Mit Internet dahinter.
Vielleicht kommt das ja noch. Na ja, wer vielleicht Datenbank machen muss, kann sich ja Bento einfach mal anschauen und seine eigene Meinung bilden. Das ist sowieso immer ganz gut. So, das letzte, was ich hier für iPhone noch auf der Liste habe, ist Twitterific.
Gab es eine neue Version?
Ja, wir haben ja letztes Mal so ausführlich über Twitter-Dings geredet. Und dafür hat Twitterific wegen mangels Updates seit ewigen Zeiten komplett hinten über.
Jetzt gibt es die zwei Növel-Versionen. Genau, da ging es aber um die Desktop-Client, also auf die Mac-Client sozusagen.
Ja, stimmt.
Aber ok, Twitterific hat auch auf dem iPhone mal wieder ein bisschen nachgelegt.
Ja, es ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so scheiße.
Es ist jetzt voll bunt und so, es ist ganz schick. Aber wollte ich gestern mal irgendwie benutzen und irgendwie, ich wollte suchen und es ist alles ganz schön, es hat eine Menge Features, aber es ist irgendwie, also nicht intuitiv irgendwie.
Also es sah am Anfang, also ich hab auf den ersten Blick erstmal, oh, ist ja doch ein bisschen besser, aber so richtig begeistert bin ich nicht von. Also ich nach wie vor eher Tweety.
Ich immer noch Twitterphone, gerade so eben.
Gerade so eben.
Ja, also wenn Tweety auf dem iPhone so wird, wie Tweety auf dem Mac, dann gehe ich auf Tweety.
Ja, das also.
Weil das Tweety auf dem Mac hat mich total überzeugt. Und das ist jetzt aus dem letzten Update nochmal so richtig viel cooler geworden und wenn wir jetzt noch irgendwie ein, zwei Sachen einbauen, dann, ja, aber die rohlen einfach derzeit. Das ist interfacetechnisch. Das ist echt bemerkenswert.
Und auch da hätte ich wieder gerne...
Ich kann Twitter jetzt so richtig gut benutzen auf dem Mac.
Transparente...
Was vorher so richtig gar nicht überhaupt nicht ging, geht jetzt mit Tweety so richtig geil.
Eventbox fand ich auch schon ganz okay. Ich fand Tweety auch besser.
Aber Eventbox, das wird doch irgendwie langsam und...
Ist Twitter eigentlich auch wieder so ein... Wo eigentlich, weiß nicht, 90% Macintosh-User das nutzen und... Kann es sein?
Keine Ahnung. Ich find ja meine Statistik ganz interessant, weil eigentlich weiß ja... Na ja, die müssten es ja wissen. Also Twitter hat es bestimmt, weil sie wissen ja immer genau, welcher Klein das macht. Damit haben sie die Plattform und auch übers Web wissen sie ja eigentlich, was da klickt. Aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass es da eine Statistik gibt.
Es gab mal so eine Seite... Mal gucken, ob ich die jetzt finde.
Aber ich weiß noch nicht, um ehrlich zu sein, hab ich da nicht so...
Das ist natürlich keine.
Sollte ich lieber das Maul halten.
Es gab mal eine schöne Seite, auf der das drauf stand. Da war ich aber... TweetStats? Nee.
Vielleicht kennt ja der Chat was.
tweetstats.com. Und die haben... Mal gucken, ob sie diese Information überhaupt noch anzeigen. Die zeigen es im Augenblick gar nicht an. Weil mit welchem Client das Ganze geschickt worden ist, die Tweets geschickt werden. Das kann man ja immer sehr, sehr leicht rausfinden. Schau mal hier im Tweet drunter. Und da gibt es garantiert jemand, der das auswertet. Aber, Twitter Stats. Ah, hier sind es.
Popular Apps and Tweets, oder stand da?
Und da war eine Zeit lang so, dass ein Drittel, glaube ich, aller Tweets überhaupt mit... Top Twitter...
Mit Clients gemacht werden.
Ne, damals mit Twitterific abgegeben worden sind. Okay, today's top ten Twitter-Apps. Web mit 48%. Twitter Feed 7,6%.
Tweetdeck.
Tweetdeck 7,7. Tweetdeck find ich ehrlich gesagt nicht... Na ja, gut.
Ist das diese Airsoftware?
Das ist diese Airsoftware. Das ist dieses Dunkle, was so den ganzen Bildschirm voll macht.
Das waren die ersten, die so wirklich mal anders waren, ne?
Ja, dann Twitterberry 1,6 Prozent. Offensichtlich, das sind dann die Blackberry Nutzer. Twirl lächerlicher 1,8 Prozent. Da hätte ich gedacht, dass die deutlich mehr haben.
Aber Twitterphone macht schon 2,6 Prozent aus. Das ist ja nicht wenig.
Und Tweety 3,3 Prozent. 3,3 Prozent.
Ja, wobei sie... Was ist das? Ist das Tweety Mobile?
Wahrscheinlich beide.
Wahrscheinlich beide. Ja, das find ich doof, dass sie das nicht trennen.
Und Twitterphone 2,6? Fast so viele wie Twitterfox mit 2,6.
Ja, aber sie machen keine Aussage über Betriebssysteme. Nee. Das find ich eigentlich ein bisschen lahm.
Na, das können sie ja auch schlecht.
Aber du kannst davon ausgehen, dass die Adoptionsrate wieder ganz brauchbar war.
Die von Twitter, die wissen nicht so, ob das Twirl auf dem Mac oder auf...
Ach so, das sind nicht die Twitters Jungs selbst.
Ich weiß nicht mal, ob die Twitter-Jungs das rauskriegen, auf welchen Betriebssystem.
Also zum Beispiel, ob du mit einem Safari von Windows oder von einem Mac kommst, steht da auch 1000 Millionen Messes OS.
Wenn du übers Web reingehst, aber wenn du über die API gehst, dann schickst du einfach nur...
Na dann wissen sie ja, welcher Client es ist. Sie wissen ja von welchem Client auf welchem OS der läuft.
Naja, aber ich meine, Tweetdeck läuft auf mehreren Clients.
Wie identifiziert man sich denn als Client? Ist das einfach nur ein String?
Man übergibt einen String, den meldet man an bei Twitter, sagt, hallo, ich hab hier einen Client geschrieben und dann kriegt man einen String zugeschickt, den man ab da in jedes Update einbauen kann.
Da muss man aber keine Plattform angeben.
Da muss man keine Plattform angeben. Das ist einfach nur so ein kurzer String.
Ach, das ist ja blöd.
Bei Edwin ist es Apple vor iPhone. Und insofern, das Client auch...
Die kauft keiner. Ja, nicht mal Fiat.
Stimmt, da gab es ja die Gerüchte, dass Apple die kaufen will, wurde aber schon dementiert. War das auch nach unserer letzten Sendung?
Jaja, das war letzte Woche. Also, kaum einer Information habe ich weniger Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt als dieser.
War ja auch nur ein ganz kurzes Wetter.
Ich hab sogar eine Kiste Mate gleich auf Twitter gewettet, als irgendwie Lars Hinrichs der Meinung war, er müsste diesem Gerücht jetzt irgendeiner Aufmerksamkeit schenken.
Ja, dann brauchen wir das jetzt auch nicht großartig zu tun.
Nee, aber das halte ich auch. Die Wette.
Fertig?
Fertig.
Kurzes Zwischenthema. Also, dass ich letztes Jahr hier dieses Click-to-Flash nicht installieren konnte. Da gibt es nämlich jetzt wieder eine neue Version, die bei mir jetzt auch automatisch kam.
Was?
Beta 6 oder so. Und zwar haben sie zugegeben, dass sie ein Installerproblem hatten. Also, es lag nicht an mir, Jungs. Ich wiederhole nochmal, es lag nicht an mir. So. Fertig. Musst du dir nochmal klarstellen. Das ging mir echt überhaupt nicht.
Ich tatte dir mal auf die Schuld.
Denn es war nicht up to date.
Ja, man ist doch sehr ruhig, wenn es nicht an einem selbst liegt.
Das stimmt schon.
Trattest du jedes Mal an dir, wenn die Software sich nicht so anzulernen, wie du denkst?
Ja, das ging nicht.
Also bei mir ist immer die Software schuld, wenn ich irgendwas nicht aufhanden kriege.
Nee, manche mach ich auch selber schuld.
Na ja, aber dann war eigentlich doch indirekt nur die Software schuld.
So, Dennis Nerdehre wurde verletzt. Genau so ist es nämlich. Weil bei Max ging's und bei mir nicht. Und das ist ein Ungleichgewicht im Universum, was gelöst werden muss.
Übrigens, Max. Weil ich würde jetzt... Wir wollten ja glaube ich nochmal das Thema Apple TV aufrufen. Aber bevor wir das machen, vielleicht noch mal kurz einen Nachtrag. Auch eine Information, die mir erst gestern auf dem Hörer treffen, dank des Hinweises von Technica klar wurde. Dein MacBook Pro hat einen Adapter und dann steckst du den ran und dann kommt da VGA raus. Gab's ja auch schon vorher. Der Unterschied ist, dass die anderen Adapter damals waren halt Adapter im einlichen Sinne. Das heißt, die haben sozusagen die richtigen Pins aus dem DVI oder Mini-DVI oder Micro-DVI-Port rausgeholt, wo halt das VGA-Signal dran lag. Und dieses VGA-Signal wurde dann sozusagen auf einen VGA-Stecker geroutet. So wie man das auch erwarten würde. Dein Computer, den du da hast, liefert aber überhaupt keine VGA-Signale mehr.
Das wandelt diese kleine Kiste hier um?
Das wandelt deine kleine Kiste da um.
Genau.
Kann ich die mal aufmachen? Nee, nach 25 Euro.
Neulich gab es nämlich ein Software-Update für diesen Adapter.
Ach.
Das kann also sehr gut sein, dass wenn du deinen Adapter da jetzt ransteckst, dass er mir ein neues Software-Update anzeigt. Oh geil.
Das will ich sehen. War das nicht schon mal, dass letztens irgendwie so ein Apple-Kabel-Adapter-Produkt ein Update bekommen hat? Das hatte ich doch hier auch schon in einer Sendung gesehen. Jetzt kriegen schon Kabel schon Updates.
Stimmt, die Tastaturen waren das.
Nein, das war wirklich ein Adapter-Kabel. Deswegen hat es hier, glaube ich, auch in einer Sendung nochmal erwähnt, weil das war ja mal was ganz Neues, dass ein Adapter-Kabel ein Software-Update kriegt. So weit ist es schon gekommen.
Es ist auch so, zum Beispiel hier bei dem DVI-Adapter sieht man jetzt auch hier mal ganz deutlich, dass da ist ja... Genau, das ist rein digital und nicht mehr analog wie bei den alten.
Was nämlich zu echt so Problemen führen kann.
Das Analog-Cross fehlt.
Ja und zwar dann, wie im Club haben wir nämlich ein schickes 10 Meter DVI-Kabel und es hat natürlich die Pins für den Analogen, weil es einfach mal alles überträgt, was irgendwie so kommt, wie so ein Verlängerungskabel halt arbeitet.
Ein sogenanntes DVI-I-Kabel.
Ja, total vernünftig. Das geht aber nicht in diesen Stecker rein, weil der die Löcher nicht hat.
Das ist nämlich ein DVI-D.
Weil es sollte eigentlich von der Logik her genau andersrum sein.
Ja, das finde ich auch ein bisschen bekloppt. Das ist ein echtes Problem. Da muss man nämlich nochmal einen Adapter auf einen Adapter machen, der sozusagen nur den Stecker adaptiert. Aber nicht die...
Ah, da muss man sich da Löcher reinbohren. Der Gedanke dahinter ist natürlich eigentlich relativ okay. Und zwar, wenn man...
Dieses Gerät liefert keine analogen Signale heißt das.
Genau. Und wenn du normalerweise das Kabel direkt von dem Gerät kommst, dann hast du, wenn du ein neues Gerät hast, was tatsächlich mit den digitalen Signalen was anfangen kann, dann braucht das ja auch diese Pins da hinten einfach nicht.
Ja, aber es ist insofern bekloppt, wenn du ein universelles Kabel hast, was eben sowohl für den einen Fall als auch der andere Fall ist. Dafür brauchst du dann noch mal einen Zwischenstecker, der sozusagen nichts anderes macht, als die Pins zu entfernen. Also du brauchst sozusagen DVIi auf DVID-Stecker, ohne dass sich irgendwas ändert. Das ist ein bisschen bekloppt. Hast du deinen VGA-Adapter mal angeschlossen?
Ich hab den angeschlossen. Soll ich jetzt noch mal die Software-Aktualisierung aufmachen?
Ja, du musst ihn reinstecken und die Software-Aktualisierung starten. So und ich fand das nämlich jetzt auch insofern cool, als dass ich, ich hab ja vor kurzem, jetzt kommt wieder meine CRE-Plugs, eine Sendung. Jetzt geht schon die Plastikdeckel nicht mehr ab, oder was?
Ja, dann brauch ich ein Software-Update für. Probier du mal. Rette mal meinen Nerd.
Ist das denn der richtige, sag mal? Nee, so rum, du hast den Fall schon mal draufgesteckt.
Achso, ich hab den Fall schon draufgesteckt. Na, das ist eine gute Erklärung.
Na nun steck ihn doch rein, steck ihn rein, steck ihn rein.
Mobimex, der intime Mic-Podcast.
Es gibt auch so eine Software, glaube ich, die immer so stöhnt, wenn man irgendwie ein USB-Gerät anschließt und so was. War das nicht so oder war das bei einer Floppy-Disc damals? Irgendwie, ich weiß sowas mal.
Du kennst Sachen, da bin ich ganz dringend.
Oder wenn du ein CD reinsteckst oder so. Naja, warum nicht?
So, um für die Hörer das nochmal hier zu visualisieren.
Ich meine, diese Systeme haben so viel zu kämpfen, wenn du da was reinsteckst. Ich muss dir mal den Prozess beschreiben. Ich hab die Software-Aktualisierung geöffnet. Er sucht nach neuer Software.
Das kann dauern.
Das kann immer eine Weile dauern. Er wird auch neue Software anzeigen. Ich hab nämlich noch gar nicht geschafft, mein System komplett auf den Stand zu bringen.
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass sein Adapter schon Up-to-date ist.
Und bei dem VGA...
Mini DisplayPort auf VGA-Update. Das ist immerhin 11 Megabyte groß.
Firmenwehr-Update.
Ist das nicht geil? Du lädst jetzt ein 11 Megabyte-Update runter.
Zum Beispiel die fehlende Bildschirmanzeige.
Was auf einen Kabeladapter eingespielt wird.
Ich nehme an, dass 11,5 Megabyte, mindestens davon, Handbuch und dieses ganze Zeug, wie man das Ding überhaupt benutzt. Und die eigentliche Firmenwehr ist doch hoffentlich mal...
Der Kasten ist auch viel größer bei dem VGA-Stecker. Da ist wirklich was drin.
Da ist was drin und ich kann dir auch sagen, was da drin ist.
Was denn?
Da ist ein FPGA drin. Und das Interessante ist, ich habe ja eine Sendung gemacht zu FPGA. Und mit Hunz.
Bist du da sicher, dass da ein FPGA drin ist?
Ich bin mir da insofern sicher, als dass wir in der Sendung sehr ausführlich darüber gesprochen haben, was man bräuchte, um nämlich genau so etwas zu tun. Nämlich ein DVI-Signal in ein VGA-Signal zu wandeln. Genau.
Also, wenn er so ein Hörer ist und er will irgendwie 20 Euro spenden, dann nehmen wir so ein Ding auseinander und gucken rein.
Ich glaube, gestern, ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, ich glaube, er meinte auch, er hätte sogar reingeschaut und es wäre einer drin. Also, das macht auch Sinn.
Entschuldigt meine Unwesenheit, was ist eine FPGA?
Aha, du hast also den Podcast nicht gehört. FPGA ist halt eine frei programmierbare Hardware-Logik. Das heißt, die Gata-Konfiguration, die so einen Chip ausmacht, also wie quasi Eingangssignale in Ausgangssignale umgesetzt werden in dieser Hardware, also die Logik der Hardware, die ist programmierbar. Das heißt, du kannst in Software definieren, wie so ein Stein funktioniert. Und danach ist es aber wirklich Hardware, also da läuft nicht ein Programm ab oder so. Und diese Technik benutzen, das brauchst du halt bei solchen hohen Bitraten wie einem Bildschirm, da kannst du nicht, da wäre deine CPU in deinem MacBook mit überfordert. Also sie können solche Datenströme überhaupt nicht bearbeiten. Und das geht halt mit so einem kleinen FPGA-Stein wiederum wunderbar.
Also was es zum Beispiel gibt, es gibt ja so FPGA-Boards, da schiebst du die Software drauf und dann ist der FPGA plötzlich ein Amiga, zum Beispiel, weil da sind 68.000 emuliert. Oder du schiebst halt die Software drauf, um einen 650.02 zu emulieren und dann ist dein FPGA plötzlich ein 64er. Und zwar der gleiche Chip.
Das, was gerne für Prozessordesign genutzt wird, um die ganze Schleusel ausprobieren zu können.
Um so Design zu testen, ja. Also es ist sehr universell, muss natürlich, du kannst wahrscheinlich mit einem FPGA heute kein Core 2 Duo emulieren sozusagen, weil so schnell sind die Dinger nicht. Aber so, wenn deine Chips ein paar Jahre alt sind, kannst du dir halt, gibt's einen FPGA-Cores heißen die, glaube ich, sogar, die Module, die gibt's professionell, also angeboten oder kommerziell heißt das, oder es gibt auch freie Cores.
Es sieht tatsächlich so aus, als ob ich dann nach, das mache ich jetzt nicht das eigentliche Update, weil es sieht so ein bisschen so aus, als ob er dabei einen neuen Start machen will.
Aktuelle Firma Version 101, neue Firma Version 103, na wieso? Dein Stecker muss neu starten, dein Rechner nicht, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, sie erzählen irgendwas alles mit alle anderen Programme beenden und so, das sieht schon so aus, als ob die dann ein bisschen mehr zum guten Zauber machen würde.
Oh, ich will auch einen FPGA in so einem KB. Kann ich da auch einen 64er reinschieben?
Das wär's eigentlich.
Das sollten die Hacker mal machen, weil Displayausgang hat's ja schon.
Also, wen das auf jeden Fall interessiert, wie sowas funktioniert und wie auch dieser Adapter funktioniert, kann ich es nochmal sehr empfehlen, Chaosradio Express 117, da wird das relativ ausführlich erläutert.
Vielleicht hör ich mir den sogar mal an. Ja genau, da muss ich jetzt anfangen. Ich war nämlich schon seit Ewigkeiten, weil ich auch mal drauf und dran mir endlich mal so einen schicken, großen Flachbildschirm Fernseher zu kaufen.
Du hast ja aber keinen Sony gekauft.
Hab mir keinen Sony gekauft.
Denn das musst du in der Mitte anfassen und hochziehen.
Bist du mit deinem Sony eigentlich glücklich?
Naja, das Ding ist schon okay. Das ist zumindest kompatibel. So ein Sony und so ein Macintosh mögen sich. Das geht so mit jedem Teil.
Also ich hab mir jetzt einen Samsung gekauft, so 40 Zoll. Klar unterstützt VT Growl. Das müsst ihr nur einschalten, weil es gerade im Chat kommt. Und da hab ich mir so einen schönen 40 Zoller 1080p Samsung Vorfühlmodell gekauft, weil dann war es noch ein hunnibilliger oder sowas. Und komm mit dem Teil nach Hause. Und dadurch, dass es ein Vorfühlmodell war, hatte ich ein paar Probleme damit, dass er nämlich am Anfang die Einstellungen nicht abgespeichert hat, sodass ich mal in den Tiefen des Service Menüs rumwühlen konnte. Und zwar ist das wirklich, wenn man im ausgeschalteten Zustand auf diesem Bildschirm irgendwas, irgendwas, irgendwas drückt auf der Fernbedienung und dann das einschaltet. Ich hab's getwittert, weil's wirklich so absurd war. Dann kommt man in ein spezielles Service Menü, in dem man den Demo-Modus abschalten kann, in dem das Fernseh sich alle 28 Minuten resetet. Seitdem läuft er aber wirklich ziemlich gut. Womit ich tierische Probleme hatte, war mit dem Apple TV. Und zwar war das so, dass wenn ich dieses dämliche HDMI-Kabel da verbunden habe und wenn ich zuerst den Apple TV eingeschaltet habe und danach erst den Fernseher, war alles überhaupt kein Problem. Wenn ich's aber in einer anderen Reihenfolge gemacht hab, haben die nicht synchronisiert gekriegt. Also ich hab immer zwischendurch mal kurz ein Bild gesehen und dann war das Bild wieder weg und dann kam wieder ein Bild und dann kam's wieder weg.
Was erst den Fernseher und dann das Apple TV ging nicht.
Genau, das ging nicht.
Sondern der Apple TV musste schon ein Signal liefern, während der Samsung eingeschaltet wird. Ich hab... Ja, das ist glaub ich...
Nee, erst Apple TV und Fernseher ging nicht, sondern zuerst den Fernseher anschalten und dann den Apple TV.
Also der muss sozusagen dazukommen, während er schon läuft.
Genau. Was jetzt natürlich das total Dämliche daran ist, dass der Apple TV gar keinen Ein-Aus-Schalter hat, sondern ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit über verbunden ist und dann hätte man sozusagen immer das Kabel abziehen sollen. Also es wäre definitiv ein Grund gewesen, das Ding wieder umzutauschen. Und dann habe ich aber irgendwo, also das ist ein HDCP-Problem, das ist diese Copyright Protection, die da drin ist. Dass die sich nämlich nicht mehr einigen können, welche Daten da jetzt gerade gesendet werden dürfen und ob das denn wirklich verschlüsselt ist. Und dann habe ich erstmal gedacht, naja okay, nicht nur für Kabel, Adapterkabel gibt es Firmware-Updates, sondern es gibt ja auch für Fernseher heutzutage ein Firmware-Update. Und habe mich auf die Suche nach einem Firmware-Update gemacht. Und das ist unglaublich. Ich habe mir die Modellnummer von diesem Fernseher aufgeschrieben und den gibt es auf der Samsung-Seite nicht. Es gibt auf der Samsung-Seite diesen Fernseher nicht.
Das kenne ich schon. Auch so ein Grund.
Das ist wirklich unerträglich.
Samsung ist Trash. Das ist wirklich Trash. Ich glaube, der Einzige, der das wirklich halbwegs mit dieser Modellpflege richtig machen, das ist Sony.
Und ich habe mir dann diese Webseite, dieses PDF runtergeladen, wie ich ein Firmware-Update installiere. Und da stehen tatsächlich so Sachen drin, wie die Arbeit mit Wildcards, bei der Beschreibung ihrer, welches Firmware-Update, für welche Fernseher taugt. Also da steht dann, für das Modell LE, Sternchen, Sternchen A786R2FX, lade dir die Software MT8226 slash T minus RB2PEUMD.exe runter. Punkt exe.
Ich wollte schon, bevor du exe gesagt hast, wollte ich sagen, das ist ja für Windows-User.
Das ist für Windows-User, die wirklich gerne...
Also ich meine nicht für Leute, die Windows haben und benutzen, sondern die Windows denken.
Nee, ich glaube, so denkt man nicht mal Windows. Also das ist ja so eine Tabelle mit, ich weiß nicht...
So denkt nicht Windows. Hast du mal Updates für Windows runtergeladen? Na okay, das hat sich mittlerweile auch...
Ja, das geht mittlerweile. Aber so war das. Also das magst du mal so gewesen sein, aber das ist wirklich, das grauen schlechthin. Und dann hab ich dann irgendwann, und dann steht hier auch irgendwo eine URL, die man aufrufen soll. Da steht dann irgendwie so blablabla und dann klickst du da. Das stimmt schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Ja.
Das geht selbstverständlich nicht auf der Webseite. Es steht kein Hinweis drin, wie man dann rauskriegt. Brauche ich denn dieses Scheiß-Firmware-Update überhaupt? Also gibt es denn überhaupt was Neues?
Gibt's auch nicht. Ist ja wie bei QuickTime.
Und dann lädst du das Ganze runter und dann hast du, steht hier aber irgendwann ein PDF drin, ja, dann packt sich diese ZIP-Datei aus, sodass ich dann einfach mal gedacht habe, dann schmeiße ich doch mal diese X-Datei auf Anarkalber. Und tada, tatsächlich. Das ist einfach nur eine ZIP-Datei, die sie aus irgendwelchen fancy Gründen als X verpackt haben, weil ansonsten könnte man ja auch auf...
Auf ein Auto-Unpacker anführen.
Das ist nix weiter als ein ZIP-Auto-Unpacker. Offensichtlich sogar ein relativ bekannte. Und dann kannst du das ganze Ding auf einem Memory-Stick kopieren. Und dann steckst du diesen Memory-Stick rein und dann musst du deinen Fernseher in einen speziellen Modus bringen. Und dann passiert erstmal, dann schaltet er sich ein und dann steht da, ja, ja, jetzt musst du warten.
Eigentlich haben sie diese... In dieser Anleitung die entscheidenden Schritte eigentlich weggelassen. Weil erstens, also was ich den Leuten, die so ein Samsung Fernseher und damit auch dir als erstes empfehlen würde, ist, erstmal ein Knebel in den Mund zu nehmen.
Und dann drauf beißen.
Ja, so ein Ball. Irgendwie The Gimp. So ein Ball, da... Weil dann kannst du dich einfach schon mal bei den ganzen Schmerzen, die du jetzt erleidest, einfach nicht mehr die Zunge abbeißen.
Die schmerzen noch ein bisschen hinter mir. So, und dann hat er... Lass mich erstmal kurz fertig erzählen. Und dann führt er dieses Firmenupdate durch. Und es dauert ungefähr 4 Minuten, bis ein Progress Bar kommt. Und dann steht hier ungefähr 48...
Auf dem Fernseher.
Auf dem Fernseher. Du schaltest ihn noch ein, und dann führt er ein Firmware-Update durch. Und hier steht ungefähr 80.000 Mal, dass du es unbedingt genau so machen musst wie beschrieben. Das heißt, du wartest da 4 Minuten und denkst dir so, äh, hab ich jetzt vielleicht doch meine Fotosammlung noch auf dem USB-Stick vergessen? Und der probiert die gerade als Firmware zu installieren. Und dann kommt aber irgendwann dieser Progress Bar. Und dann geht der Fernseher wieder aus und blinkert erstmal für 20, für 5 Minuten oder so was, in denen du dann wieder so ein bisschen schweißtreibend da sitzen kannst mit deiner neuen Investition von 600 Euro. Und dann hört er auf zu blinkern und du kannst ihn wieder einschalten. Und du hast, ich hab bis heute keine Ahnung, welche Firmware ich vorher hatte. Ich weiß bis heute nicht, ob die Firmwareinstallation geklappt hat. Auf jeden Fall war das Problem danach immer noch da. Es steht natürlich auch nirgendwo drin, was sich mit den Firmware-Updates verbessert. Aber ich hab in den Apple Foren, weil ich hab dann so nach Apple TV und Samsung und Sync und weiß der Teufel was gesucht. Und in den Apple Foren gibt's einen langen, langen Thread dazu. Und auch die Lösung für das Problem. Und zwar in diesem Service-Menü, von dem ich schon vorher erzählt hab, muss man irgendeinen Plug-and-Play-Modus deaktivieren. Und danach geht alles super. Und dann hör ich mich noch mal ein bisschen in diesen Trieb...
Ein Plug-und-Play-Modus.
Ich weiß nicht, ich suche mal, ob ich das finde. Irgendeinen Modus musste man da abschalten, irgendeinen kryptischen Befehl musste man abschalten. Und seitdem funktioniert mein Fernseher so, wie er funktionieren sollte. Und seitdem bin ich ganz glücklich. Und man konnte auch noch ein paar andere Features. Also ich konnte die Modellnummer, konnte ich tatsächlich über dieses Service-Menü ändern. Ich konnte ihm sagen, dass du plötzlich ein 42 Zoll Fernseher bist. Mit anderen Worten, nicht mal mehr mein Fernseher kennt seine eigene Modellnummer, außer auch der kennt ihn nicht.
Es hält eine Standard-Software drin, an diese verschiedene Panels vorne ran.
Genau, also z.B. meiner hat so ein Feature drin, dass er unten eine LED hat.
Steht denn die Modellnummer sonst irgendwo auf dem Gerät?
Die steht so auf dem Aufkleber an der Seite.
Ah, das heißt, wenn du sozusagen das in der Firmware änderst und wenn du das auch noch auf den Aufkleber irgendwie änderst, und du das Ding zurückgibst und sagst, er ist kaputt, ich will einen neuen, dann kriegst du irgendwie einen...
Mein 50 Zoll Fernseher ist kaputt. Er ist nur 40 Zoll. Genau.
Ist mir am Anfang gar nicht aufgefallen. Aber dann hab ich den muss eingelaufen sein. Sie könnten ja nachschlagen.
Aber da kann man noch so ein paar Features... Ich weiß dann auch so, sind so... Dann sind dann so im Menüpunkt drinnen so vorne Nordic Countries und sowas. Also ich nehme mal an, dass die dann einzelne Sachen hinzuschalten oder einzelne Menübefehle abschalten. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was genau. Aber auf jeden Fall war das ganz schön...
Dennis hat schon wieder sein GSM-Telefon eingeschaltet.
War das ganz schön funky, das so zum Laufen zu kriegen. Aber jetzt läuft es. Das hab ich in Apple TV an einem Samsung-Fernseher. Bin soweit ziemlich glücklich. Und wie komme ich dann überhaupt zu so einem scheiß Apple TV? Weil ich wollte ja...
Du bist morgens aufgestanden, dein Fernseher ging nicht an. Und da hast du gedacht, du brauchst ihn diese Woche. Nee, nee, das war ich.
Da muss ich schon nachhelfen, damit der Fernseher nicht mehr geht, der Alte. Nee, ich wollte mir eigentlich so eine Linux-Kiste kaufen.
Also du hast hier schon jetzt regulär gekauft.
Ich bin in den Laden gegangen, hab ins Legal gegriffen, hab mir so eine Kiste mit zum Apple TV rausgenommen und bin schnell gegangen.
Wobei, bei Gravis?
Ähm, nee, das hab ich beim Media-Markt.
Tatsächlich, echt? Bei den Technik-Prolls?
Gibt's da nur eine Version oder mehrere?
Da gibt's zwei Versionen von, es gibt eine mit 40 und eine mit 160 GB, macht einen Unterschied von 100 Euro.
Man will die kleine nehmen und sich die große Platte selber einbauen?
Na ja, für 100 Euro würde ich mir eine 500er einbauen. Na eben.
Und du hast die 40er immer noch übrig.
Und ich hätte die 40er, wobei was man nutzt, ist die Frage, wozu man die große Platte überhaupt braucht. Genau. Das ist, also der Gedanke dahinter war, ich wollte einen kleinen Rechner da stehen haben, irgendwie so ein Intel Atom NetTop dachte ich, der eine hohe Auflösung schafft, auch für Videos. Und da gibt es jetzt so mit so einem Ion, wie heißt das denn hier, mit so einem Chipset, das ist von Nvidia, quasi die gleiche Grafikkarte, die auch in den aktuellen MacBooks drin ist.
Bloß ein 1400m.
Genau. Aber mit einem Atom Prozessor. Das ist ja eigentlich, klingt das ja nach dem, was man genau braucht, um hochauflösendes Video abspielen zu können. Da will man ja keine 3D-Shooter drauf laufen lassen, da braucht man ja kein großes Decoding. Da, je mehr die Grafikkarte kann, wenn die das schafft mit dem Decodieren, dann kann man damit sehr schön aufgreifen.
Das macht die aber auch unabhängig von dem Prozessor.
Das macht die unabhängig von dem Prozessor. Und darum hab ich so einen Testbericht gelesen, die sagen, ja, solange du den mitgelieferten Player dafür nimmst, den Nvidia-Player, ist das alles kein Problem, aber QuickTime kann's nicht und Windows Media kann's nur in Däumchen umschleppen. Und ich hab gedacht, naja, wenn ich dann einen Linux da drauf spiele, bis das vernünftig läuft.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, du wolltest ja dann doch keine Frickellösung, sondern du wolltest was, was funktioniert und dann hast du ja einfach einen Apple TV.
Na ja, natürlich hab ich dann doch die Frecklösung draus gebastelt aus dem Apple TV.
Ja gut, aber du hast auf jeden Fall etwas, was du zumindest resetten kannst, wenn du mit dem Gefrickel nicht mehr weiterkommst.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ob es möglich ist, so einen Apple TV einfach so zu resetten, weil, also es gibt nicht so wie beim iPhone so eine Restore-Funktion. Die hab ich noch nicht gesehen. Und es wird auch überall, was ich vermieden habe, empfohlen vorher doch ein Disc-Image anzulegen von dem ganzen Zeug, was man da drauf hat, weil, wenn man sich kaputt macht, dann sieht man wohl relativ alt aus. Echt?
Man kann so einen Apple TV nicht irgendwie remote... Interessanter Punkt, da bin ich noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Stimmt, wenn sich da das Datalsystem zerlegt und das OS irgendwie braun ist, hat man gar keine Chance, das Teil irgendwie wieder auf Farm anzubringen, oder?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das geht.
Trägt man das zum Händler und der macht das heile, oder was?
Es gibt so einen Diagnosemodus, aber ich hab keine Ahnung, um ehrlich zu sein.
Darf es doch nicht was, dass der über Netz booten kann und dann kann er sich auch wieder frisch machen?
Also vielleicht hat er so einen Recovery-Modus.
Bestimmt.
Achso, ja, was er hatte, weil ich am Anfang hier nur mal den Stecker rausgezogen hatte, weil ich ja genau dieses HDMI-Problem hatte, dass er irgendwann mal gebootet hat und gesagt hat, ja, du, ich bin hier gerade ziemlich dämlich abgestürzt, willst du einen Restore durchführen? Und vielleicht kann er sich in dem Modus dann nochmal mit dem Netz verbinden und von Apple nochmal ein frisches Image runterladen und das dann installieren. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein eigener Rechner mit eigenem Prozessor und das ist ein...
Über das Internet macht ja eigentlich Sinn.
Genau. So. So diese Erfahrung bisher, das ist so ein bisschen eigentlich so ein iPod für ein Fernseher. Wenn ich's jetzt mal so sagen darf. Also du klappst das Ding auf und dann verbindest du es mit deiner iTunes-Bibliothek und dann erscheint das, wie eben auch der iPod und iTunes in der Device-Liste. Dann kann man da eingeben, was man da gerne drauf haben möchte auf dem Gerät. Automatisch, so einen richtigen, komplett manuellen Modus habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Und dann kann man sagen, spiele da alle Fotos drüber und alle Filme und alle meine Podcasts und das ist ein Traum. Also das ist, wenn man diese abgeschlossenen iTunes-Apple-Welt bleiben will und wenn man damit glücklich ist, ist das, glaube ich, eine sehr schöne Lösung. Weil du lässt das halt, du musst es am Anfang ein bisschen länger laufen lassen, damit er die Daten über das WLAN rüber spielen kann. Das dauert natürlich einen Moment, aber danach ist das alles drauf und schon während das läuft kannst du schon anfangen, deine Filme abzuspielen.
Sofern du halt noch einen zweiten Rechner hast. Also sofern du halt noch einen Computer hast, auf dem eben Daten sind.
Genau, sobald ich diesen Nectar irgendwo stehen habe. Und das Ding ist auch mit dem Netz verbunden. Also du kannst auch Filme direkt auf... Hab ich bisher leider noch nicht probiert, das kann ich dann beim nächsten Mal berichten. Du kannst auch Filme direkt auf dem Apple TV ausleihen und kannst dir Trailer angucken und kannst dir YouTube-Videos angucken.
Ja, vor allem diese Filmlei-Experience würde mich interessieren.
Genau, das werde ich auch.
Wenn man Kinder hat, weiß ja, da geht man nicht mehr ins Kino und da ist halt irgendwie so Filmeleihen auf dem Rechner genau das, was man will.
Also ich hab gerade von dir gehört, hat mir...
Na du willst, deine Kinder werden 100.000 Mal den Lion King gucken und das willst du nicht andauernd leihen, du willst ja die DVD kaufen und dann ist Ruhe. Weil Kinder gucken nämlich Filme, schon gerne andauernd und immer wieder hintereinander.
Ja gut, ich mein, dann kannst du es kaufen.
Ja, kannst du auch gleich kaufen.
Ja, aber kaufen mit DRM würde ich auch nicht machen, von daher halt auch eher DVD ist schon klar. Aber sagen wir mal so für diesen Urge, aktueller Film kommt raus, willst du sehen, einfach Entertainment einfach so, ja. Das ist klar, naja, für Kinder Film ist was anderes. Aber für Kinder würde ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht für einen Fernseher sitzen wollen.
Das ist jetzt bei dir selber schon viel zu lange vor.
Ja, das macht nur blöd. Na egal, das kommt nicht drauf an, was sie gucken. Ich wollte es mal gesagt haben.
Ja, das hast du gesagt.
Ich vertrete diese Meinung.
Ja, also dafür ist es eine schöne Lösung. Man kann sich fantastisch Fotos angucken. Und das ist echt... Das funktioniert? S-Advertised.
Und wie viel hat es gekostet?
300 Euro.
Und ich finde es schade, dass sie die Dinger nicht billiger gemacht haben.
Für den Kleinen.
Finde ich echt schade. Was kostet ein USA-230 Dollar?
Ich habe nicht geguckt, weil ich wollte mich nicht ärgern. Ja. Ja, ich habe jetzt die 300 Euro ausgegeben.
Aber man kann ihn ja vielleicht in Britannien, da ist doch gerade Krise. Da kannst du irgendwie auf Amazon CO UK echt Geld sparen.
Okay.
Also wenn du so eine Wii neu kaufst mit irgendwie komplett Bim Bim, zahlst du da irgendwie 500 statt 600 Euro oder so.
Da ist doch gerade Krise.
Ja, also ich meine die haben, weiß schon. Klar. Also Krise haben wir alle, aber die haben halt richtig Krise und das Problem, dass sie noch Euro sind. Die haben jetzt noch Währungen im Arsch.
Oder wir haben das Glück, dass sie kein Euro sind.
Da kann man sich unter Umständen noch ein bisschen Geld sparen.
Ein Euro, nee ein Pfund, ein britisches Pfund sind noch ein Euro und elf. Also fast gleich.
Ist glaube ich schon wieder, ja war schon mal, sie hatten auch schon mal Parität. Das hat sich glaube ich etwas erholt.
Aber was ich ja eigentlich, ich hab ja noch irgendwie, hatte ich ja noch so ein paar Avi-Filme rumliegen, die ich mir aus meinen DVDs konvertiert habe. Und die wollte ich dann natürlich auch gerne drauf abspielen. Also ich hab noch mal, ich hab jetzt einen Fritzbox mir gekauft, auch eine neue. Also richtig shoppen, ne?
Ja, ich staune irgendwie, also.
Das war mal fällig, ich hab das erstmal seit einem Vierteljahr wieder Geld auf dem Kopf.
Voll der Konsum-Rausch.
Also das mit dem MacBook, wie gesagt, das war richtig, richtig geplant.
Das gehört sich aber auch für so einen Macintosh-Podcast. Ich meine, wir müssen die Klischees der Konsumgeilen, irgendwie DUM-User, die alles nur mit so einer drei-Button-Fernbedienung benutzen wollen, müssen wir auch erfüllen, oder? Insofern danke für diesen Beitrag.
Achso, an der Fernbedienung. Schickes Detail.
Lernt andere Fernbedienungen.
Also die Apple TV lernt andere Fernbedienungen.
Genau, also man kann dem Apple TV sagen, hier hast du eine neue Fernbedienung und dann drückt man mal so ein paar Tasten, spielt da so ein bisschen im Menü rum. Und dann hat man sogar mehr Funktionen, also man kann mehr Tasten belegen, als die Apple original mitgelieferte Fernbedienung überhaupt hat.
Die haben da die kleine Apple Remote auch nur dabei?
Genau, da ist nur eine kleine Apple Remote dabei. Das reicht auch im Wesentlichen für alles, für das meiste. Aber die haben noch mal separate Vorspult- und Rückspult-Tasten. Und die kann man dann auf einer normalen Fernbedienung verlinken. Was ich an dieser kleinen Apple Remote wesentlich nerviger finde, als die wenigen Tasten, ist, dass diese unglaublich klein ist. Du liegst so auf der Couch rum und die ist so schnell weggerutscht. Also so eine Fernbedienung, hab ich jetzt festgestellt, braucht auch eine gewisse Größe, damit sie nicht von der Katze runtergespielt wird, vom Sofa oder sowas. Und um das zu vermeiden und weil es ja sowieso immer ganz gut ist, nur eine Fernbedienung zu haben, hab ich einfach, das sieht ja so bei den meisten Fernseher, die haben eh so ein Fadenkreuz irgendwo drauf, was so ähnlich aussieht wie diese Apple Remote. Das fällt ja gar nicht schwer, die da neu zu belegen.
Aber du musst ja schon die Möglichkeit haben, auf der Fernbedienung zwischen unterschiedlichen Devices hin und her zu schalten, dass du nicht gleichzeitig deinen Fernseher mit steuerst.
Nein, Senderwechsel oder sowas funktioniert darüber nicht, sondern diese Tasten werden glaube ich im Wesentlichen in den Menüs benutzt und solange ich die Menüs nicht aufrufe, geht das wie eine Eins. Dann steuer ich zwar, wenn ich in den Menüs bin, immer noch die Apple TV mit. Quasi. Aber ich meine, so oft ist man ja auch nicht in den Scheiß Menüs.
Aber es gibt ja so Ferien, die so Umschalter haben, mit Geräten 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Ja, aber das passt jetzt wirklich gut, muss ich sagen. Aber wie gesagt, ich hab ja noch ein paar andere Filme und ich wollt gerne auch auf meine bestehende Dateisammlung zugreifen. Und darum hab ich mir gedacht, es gibt ja auch dieses Xbox Media Center, dieses XBMC. Das gibt's auch fürs Apple TV. Und da hab ich mir mal die Anleitung durchgelesen. Und da gibt's, die empfehlen den Apple TV USB Creator oder sowas heißt das. Und das ist eine Software, mit der man einen beliebigen Memory Stick darauf vorbereiten kann, den sozusagen im Recovery Modus an die Apple TV anzuschließen. Und dann bootet man das Gerät.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Apple TV USB Creator. Ich guck mal, ich such das mal kurz raus.
Und dann, Entschuldigung, ich hab das irgendwie nicht richtig verstanden. Dann kann man was damit machen?
Du nimmst diese Software, schließt einen Memory Stick an deinen Rechner an.
Normalen Mac.
Genau, an deinen Mac. Oder Linux oder Windows. Und dann bereitet der sozusagen das Datalsystem auf dem Memory Stick so vor, dass es für ein Apple Recovery irgendwas ist. Also, dass das den in so einen hackbaren Modus versetzt.
Das Apple TV.
Das Apple TV. Und dann ziehst du diesen Stick ab, wenn das fertig ist. Steckst ihn an deinen Apple TV, bootest den Apple TV neu. Dann hast du mal kurz den Linux-Penguin auf deinem Fernseher drauf.
Also er bootet von dem Teil?
Nee, er bootet nicht. Oder ich weiß nicht, ob er nur Software nachlädt.
Wenn ein Linux-Penguin kommt, dann bootet der von der USB.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er wirklich davon bootet oder... Stimmt, ja, du hast recht, es wird ein Linux gebootet. Und dieses Linux baut dann in dem Apple TV ein paar zusätzliche Menüpunkte ein.
Also so persistent, also er modifiziert sozusagen.
Danach kannst du den Memory-Stick abziehen und hast das für alle mal. Und damit hat man dann SSH-Zugang zum einen. Und was hat man noch so? Ja und eben ein paar zusätzliche Menüpunkte. Und mit den Menüpunkten kann man dann XBMC nachinstallieren. Das ist diese Media Center Lösung. Man kann Boxy nachinstallieren, was so XBMC mit ein bisschen Social-Charakter ist. Man hat, wie gesagt, SSH-Zugang. Man kann ohne Ende so NES- und Sonne-Emulatoren nachinstallieren. Und auch so ein paar Player, die direkt auf die native Oberfläche zugreifen. Also zum Beispiel gibt es einen Player, der heißt Sapphire, Sapphire, irgendwie sowas. Mit Z. Ne, mit S vorne. Und damit kann man dann genauso, wie man über die Filmauswahl von Apple drauf zugreifen kann, die aber bloß auf ihre eigene Bibliothek zugreift, kann man beliebig auf das Dastel-System zugreifen. Und man kann sich auch Befehle wie Mount SMB nachinstallieren, mit denen man dann das SMB-Dateisystem z.B. mounten kann, übers Netzwerk. Und damit kann ich dann auf meine entfernten Platten zugreifen.
Und dieses Boxi, das bringt doch, Boxi macht da erst mal so andere Formatunterstützung und dann auch so ein Holo-Interface oder so.
Was ist das wieder? Das Holo-Interface ist leider rausgefallen. Und es gibt einen Menüpunkt, der installiert die Perian nach.
Ah, okay, der macht dann sozusagen andere Colegs.
Und damit kann man dann alles abspielen. Zum einen erst mal über dieses Apple-Interface. Oder wenn man mag, startet man einfach XBMC oder Boxi und hat dann eben noch ein paar zusätzliche Features.
Okay, also ein bisschen nerdy, aber es geht dann wenigstens alles.
Na, es ist ein schickes Interface, wobei ich mittlerweile das Apple-TV, das native eher schicker finde und ich hab bisher auch noch keine Datei untergekommen, die ich damit nicht aufgekriegt hätte. Und dieses Sapphire in Zusammenhang mit diesem Perion ist echt eine hübsche Lösung.
Dennis, du hast dich doch mal mit diesem DAAP-Protokoll ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt. Ist das eigentlich...
Videotauglich?
Ist denn so das aktuelle iTunes, die Version davon, gibt's da auch wieder Open-Source-Varianten und kann man irgendwie so ein Network-Share über DAAP so sharen, dass es auch mit Apple TV dann zusammenläuft? Das geht doch mit Apple TV, ne? Man kann doch auch sozusagen bei einem iTunes... Man kann auch einfach die geschaerten... Genau.
Das geht auch.
Das iTunes kann ja auch so ein MT-DAPD zugreifen und müsste das Apple TV das ja auch können. Und da kann man sogar Filme drüber schicken.
Ach so, das wäre nämlich genau die Frage gewesen.
Das wäre auch meine Frage gewesen. Das wäre sozusagen eleganter, als jetzt irgendwelche SMB-Mountpoints und so weiter zu nehmen.
Na ja, das mit dem SMB-Mountpoint ist das Schicke, dass die Fritzbox kein SMB hat.
Bei so einem Nass-Share ist es halt...
Und dann hast du da irgendwie eine kleine billige Box, die ständig Strom verbraucht oder die sowieso den ganzen Tag durchläuft, dann kannst du das halt eben noch mitmachen. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz sexy. Und jetzt irgendwie hier so...
Wenig Strom verbraucht, wird das Ding scheiße heiß, diese Apple TV?
Das wird ziemlich warm, ja. Aber das Apple TV, das kann man in einen Standby-Modus versetzen, wenn man 5 Sekunden lang die Taste gedrückt hält.
Macht es nicht von alleine?
Macht es nicht von alleine nach einer Weile?
Aha, warum?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Die Platte fällt auch nicht runter?
Also ich geh mal an, dass das...
Die Platte fällt bestimmt runter.
Dass das die üblichen Energiesparfunktionen von Apple da drin hat.
Aber was macht denn das Teil, wenn es nicht in einem Schlafmodus ist?
Ich glaube es schickt zum Beispiel die ganze Zeit über ein Videosignal raus.
Okay, es ist ja Fernsehen. Du schaltest dann einen Fernseher um und du wirst es einfach da ist. Aber er könnte ja... kann er das detekten? Nee, er kann wahrscheinlich nicht detekten, also ich gehe mal das......lesen wird, ne? Nein. Aber analog sowieso nicht.
Über den analogen Anschluss kriegt das nicht hin.
Ist halt die Fernsehwelt.
Aber der HDMI-Anschluss, da kriegt er auf jeden Fall mit.
Könnte das auch 1080p abspielen? Nee, schafft er nicht.
Doch, das hat er. Hab ich explizit auch eingestellt.
Geile Scheiße, wa, Dennis? Ich seh schon, du rollst mir in den Augen. Da kannst du mal deinen ganzen Content ordentlich rausrollen.
Na, ich hab ja so einen Movie, der ist ja aus dem Netz gefallen. Der will bei mir nicht, der ist zu fett. Der ist 1080p mit irgendwie 5.1 Audio.
Ach, der passt nicht auf deinen Bildschirm drauf. Das macht Apple TV, er steckt das halt mit Hardware.
Also das ist mir auch aufgefallen, dieses Apple TV ist auch nicht unbedingt, nicht richtig, also es ist relativ schwachbrüstig. Und das kommt zwar mit dem HD-Material, was in den Trailern drin ist, hervorragend klar.
Das ist ja auch nicht so wirklich.
Und so was, also mit dem Material, was Apple zur Verfügung stellt, kommt das, wie gesagt, sehr gut klar. Aber ich hab mal so ein MPEG-4, was ich irgendwo gefunden habe, und das hat auch geruckelt. Also da hab ich auch noch keine perfekte Lösung für.
Das war eine Erfahrung mit Apple TV.
Das war meine Erfahrung mit Apple TV.
Nicht die schlechtesten Erfahrungen.
Für jemanden, der eigentlich gar keinen haben wollte, sondern es nur eine Notlösung war, bin ich sehr glücklich. Und den hab ich seit einer Woche. Ich hab jetzt noch nicht so viel Zeit gehabt, mich damit zu beschäftigen. Also im Augenblick hab ich da eben noch eine Bastellösung. Wenn man keinen Bock hat zu basteln, wenn man sagt, ich möchte gern über iTunes meine Daten abspielen, ich möchte gern meinen Podcast, der Podcast-Support ist relativ gut. Ich muss mal gucken, ob er auch selber von alleine Podcasts runterlädt, das Apple TV. Aber so diese iTunes-Integration ist gewohnt gut, außer dass man mal kein Kabel anstecken muss, wenn das tatsächlich Overseer läuft. Und wenn man darüber hinaus noch ein bisschen mehr will, ist dieser Hack, also dieses eigene Software darauf installieren und einen SSH-Server, einen Boxi drauf zu machen und ein fast vollwertiges Mac OS draus zu basteln. Also ich hab Firefox zum Laufen gekriegt zum Beispiel, inklusive Tastatursupport und Maus-Support so halbwegs. Also es ist jetzt keine... Ich würde es auf keinen Fall kaufen, um darauf Mac OS-Software laufen zu lassen. Aber um Videos abzuspielen, um Boxi drauf laufen zu lassen, um XBMC drauf laufen zu lassen, ist es definitiv eine ziemlich schöne Lösung. Und vermutlich auch eine der günstigeren, die man sich so vorstellen kann.
Hier gibt es übrigens verschiedene Aussagen dazu. Also mit dem FPGA nochmal, mit dem Adapter.
Ja, hat eine ordentlich Infos gepostet.
Nein, im Update ist wohl nicht wirklich ein Update für den FPGA. Sondern das ist tatsächlich Mac-seitig. Also es geht ins EFI. Aber ich werde hier sozusagen dann mit irgendwie... Also hier wird der Schluss gezogen, dass es dann kein FPGA ist, aber das ist es trotzdem. Also da gibt es einen... Ja, also ist einer drin.
Okay, also es wird...
Aber das Update betrifft...
Sie tun so, als ob das Displaykabel, das Adapterkabel bearbeitet werden würden, aber in Wirklichkeit wird ein Stück Software in einem Rechnungsbearbeitet...
Es ist sozusagen mechseitig ein Update, was für ein Zusammenspiel...
Aber den Stein, der da gepostet hat, das ist ja so ein... Der hat doch da einen von SD Microelectronics, oder wie die Jungs heißen.
Wer der wo was wie gepostet hat.
Warte, hier weiter oben.
Ah, auch mit überhaupt so kein FPGA?
Ist halt so ein Fertestein. DisplayPorto VGA Adapter STDP 3100. 10 x 10 mm ist genau dafür da und kann irgendwie genau das. Dann braucht man kein FPGA mehr, weil es dann auch billiger. Also warum soll man so ein...
Nee, stimmt schon.
Für so eine Massenanwendung.
Klar.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch logisch, dass es dafür so was gibt.
Wussten wir doch die ganze Zeit, wenn wir ehrlich sind, oder?
Nee, das ist unser, für uns berühmtes Halbwissen. Aber wir haben halt auch den Vorschlag.
Ich hatte jetzt den Hinweis, ich hatte den Hinweis bekommen, dass es sich um einen handelt und dass dem so sei. Und das war eine ungeprüfte Information. Ich entschuldige mich. Ist halt nicht so. Umso besser.
Wir können uns ja auch live updaten.
Interessanter Stein hier. Ja, naja, aber mit FPGA kann man sich sowas selber basteln. Will man da wahrscheinlich bloß nicht. Aber der rechnet halt wirklich die DisplaySync-Signale um. Also der rendert das sozusagen da intern raus, das Bild und macht dann halt da aus.
Das ist wie eine Minigrafikarte, eine alte.
Mit 10 Bit irgendwie gehts raus.
Gibt es eigentlich noch von DVI nach S-Video-Adapter?
Also wenn du wirklich nur von DVI, also von dem DVI-Digital-Signal, S-Video haben wolltest, dann bräuchte du so einen ähnlichen Stein wie hier. Den es vielleicht gibt oder nicht, weiß ich nicht. Kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass da irgendwas gibt.
Weil früher war ja mal noch so ein S-Video-Port an den Rechnern mit dran, der ist ja jetzt nun nicht mehr da.
Ach so, für deinen Rechner ist das einfach ein Adapter-Kabel?
Ja, 20 Euro.
Wahrscheinlich sowas in dem Dreh. Für den hier, hat er mir explizit heute nochmal gesagt, gibt es da keine Lösung.
Gibt es nicht mehr. Nur noch digital. VGA auch, aber kein Fernsehzeug mehr.
Das wäre aber, naja, was willst du? Ich kenne so einen Nick. Hier, ich gebe dir ein Essen. Es gibt eine kreativen Gruppe, die kotzt voll auf die neuen MacBooks. Die kaufen die auch nicht.
Hier gibt es einen Apple DVI nach DVI Adapter. Quatsch, Apple DVI nach Video Adapter. Und da ist ein S-Video und ein F-Bus.
Ja, aber der wird hier nicht...
Ja, aber das war halt noch auf dem... Für DVI-Zeiten, genau. Nicht DVI, sondern der DVI-Stecker sah halt Pins dafür vor, wenn die von der Videokarte bedient werden, dann kannst du die rausführen. Aber es ist halt nicht so ein Umrechner. Im Prinzip bräuchtest du für diese S-Video-Geschichte genau so einen Stein hier.
Deiner hat die Pins noch und deines kein Problem, an meines das Problem.
Beim Display-Port haben sie es einfach weggelassen, da gibt es diesen ganzen analogen Krempel nicht mehr. Das ist ja auch sehr konsequent. Kurz oder lang wird hier alles digital werden.
Wenn der Chip da drinnen einen Euro kostet, oder weiß nicht wie viel, also wenn das Kabel kostet, 20 Euro, ich glaube so was nehmt Dreh, ja. Also wenn das Kabel 20 Euro kostet, dann kann der Chip da nicht viel kosten. Und wenn Apple sagt, gib uns mal 100.000 oder so, dann ist das eh billig.
Eigentlich ist das iPhone-Thema ja schon durch, aber ich hab gerade ein ganz, ganz nerviges Problem. Und zwar werden bei mir ständig lang gelesene SMS als ungelesen markiert. Ich fürchte mal, da hat es die SQL-Leitdatenbank zerschrottet. Das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass das passiert. Da hat immer geholfen, Nachrichten zu löschen. Aber die möchte ich jetzt ungern löschen.
Hab ich dir schon erzählt, dass man mit iPhone 3.0 kann man einzelne SMS löschen? Das ist voll geil.
Hammer.
Das ist wirklich geil, weil sonst hat es immer diese ganzen...
Musste man die kompletten Treppen schmeißen.
Jemand hat versucht, sie anzurufen und es hat so einen riesen Blog in deinem Chat sozusagen drin. Und das hat ja voll genervt. Und jetzt kann man die richtig schön einzeln aufräumen. Hab ich gehört. Und gesehen.
Ja. Aber ich muss dann nachher mal wahrscheinlich an die Datenbank ran. Gibt es da irgendeinen Reparaturmodus?
Einfach hatten wir schon. Es gab jetzt hier noch ein paar News und ein paar Nachfragen. Vielleicht erstmal ein bisschen News, bevor wir da wieder ausführlicher werden. Aber es führt schon mal in die Richtung. Und zwar geht die mehr, dass es ein Bootcamp-Update, nee, ein, was war das? Beta? War das bei der aktuellen Snow Leopard?
Bei Snow Leopard war das dabei.
Snow Leopard, die Bootcamp jetzt auch über einen HFS Plus Treiber für Windows verfügt.
Genau. Also Bootcamp ist eigentlich hauptsächlich dafür da, die Partitionen fürs Windows anzulegen und dann halt die Treiber.
Das Treiberset mit zu liefern, damit die ganze Art auch ordentlich genutzt wird.
Und jetzt ist wohl auch ein HFS Plus Filesystem Treiber dabei. Was ja mal eigentlich ganz cool wäre.
Was total überfällig ist.
Obwohl, ich hab sowas gar nicht.
Was? HFS Plus?
Nee, Windows.
Jaja, gut. Aber du weißt, wie das ist. Es gibt Leute, die haben sowas oder brauchen sowas sogar vielleicht. Und ist natürlich total sinnvoll, dass wenn du eh deinen Mac mit so einem Windows ausstattest, mit Dualboot, dass du dann eben auch auf deine Mac-Dateien zugreifen kannst von Windows aus.
Ist ja voll gefährlich, dass ganze Virenschleuder auch noch auf meinem Mac zugreifen kann. Das ist too danger.
Das stimmt, aber ich meine, hast halt Windows-Viren auf deiner Platte.
Naja, aber wenn du so einen Obtolianer hast, der dir deine Dateien verschlüsselt und nur gegen Kreditkartenzahlung wieder rausrückt, die es ja schon gibt.
Ich finde es sinnvoll. Ja, das ist sinnvoll.
Was noch sinnvoller wäre, wäre natürlich, wenn sie diesen Traber gleich Open Source gemacht hätten und man daraus erstens auch für sonstige Windows-User mal einen vernünftigen HFS-Plus-Traber machen könnte. Und nicht nur für die Macbook-Anwender. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich mal externe USB-Festplatte anschließen möchte oder sowas, die für ein Mac formatiert war.
Ja.
Und für Linux das Ganze nochmal. Das würde ich ja voll Duchte finden.
Ja, warte mal.
Hier meint jemand Read-Only.
Read-Only? Ah, dann passiert das ja sozusagen.
Die Weiple sind schon cool. Erst machen sie von einer Maustaste zu gar keine Maustaste mehr und demnächst liefern die alle ihre Filesystems nur noch Read-Only aus. Haben sie mit ZFS auch schon so gemacht.
Irgendwie... Naja, wenn wir in der Wolke leben, brauchst du eh nichts mehr zu speichern. Bist ja übrigens das...
Ja, aber warte mal, ist den HFS Plus nicht Open Source? Naja, Darwin. Das Betriebssystem Darwin ist ein Open Source Betriebssystem.
Stimmt, das könnte natürlich sein.
Da ist es doch dabei oder ist das irgendwie nicht dabei?
Weiß ich nicht.
Also soweit ich weiß, ist das Einzige, was nicht dabei ist, sind halt die Grafikkartentreiber, wie immer. Weil das halt nicht geht. Aber HFS Plus ist doch irgendwie dabei. Warte mal, ich guck hier grad mal.
Wenn er ein bisschen leiser ist.
Nein, ich will nicht leiser sein. Aber ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, wie das Modul heißt. Sag einfach mal was, ich guck mal.
Was ich nämlich ein lustiges Detail finde, wo du gerade sagtest, so gar kein Button mehr. Ich hab jetzt auch dieses Glass Trackpad, was übrigens relativ schick ist. Und da kann man jetzt plötzlich in den Systemeinstellungen einstellen. Kann man einen echten rechten Mausbutton anlegen.
Ja, du kannst den halt auf eine Seite von dem Display, also von dem Trackpad legen.
Ich kann sagen, wenn ich rechts klicke, in der rechten Hälfte...
Das ist schon krass, oder? Mit Erklärungsvideos im Preferences-Feld. Das ist auch wieder so typisch Apple.
Na, langsam wird's Zeit, oder? Das ist hier schon alles neu funky. Und dann kann ich jetzt, hab ich jetzt hier, und wenn ich auf die rechte Seite vom Mauspad klicke, hab ich... ah, hab ich einen Rechtsklick.
Eigentlich, finde ich, könnten sie gleich noch ein Display unter das Trackpad packen, so wie im iPhone.
Na ja, ich glaub, das wird kommen. Das gibt doch jetzt von Acer, glaube ich, oder von... ich weiß nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist da schon eins drunter, das Ding, ist es auch klar. Du kannst dennächst so eine Folie abziehen und dann kommt das Display da drunter, zur C-Soft. Genau. Und dann kannst du auch deinen rechten Mauspad, kannst dir gleich die Linie ziehen, wie breit er sein soll, und dann wird es gleich so angezeigt.
Und das war das, die haben das relativ hübsch gemacht, die haben, also ich weiß leider nicht mehr, welcher Hersteller das war, natürlich nur für Windows, dann, die liefern so eine kleine Software mit, über das du dieses Display da drinnen programmieren kannst. Und auch so für verschiedene Anwendungen. Also sie haben dann so eine Piano-Anwendung, wo du dann so ein bisschen Klavier darauf rumspielen kannst, da siehst du so Klavier-Tasten, so kleine Malprogramme natürlich und so. Also es ist schon alles ganz niedlich gemacht. Da wird bestimmt noch was von Apple kommen.
Also auf den ersten Blick muss ich feststellen, ist HFS bei Darwin offensichtlich?
Nicht dabei.
Wie machen sie es dann? Es gibt hier in der Tat ein HFS-Modul, aber wenn man da reinguckt, ist da eigentlich nur dieses HFS-Util drin. Das ist ja irgendwie beunruhigend. Aber MS-DOS FS haben sie dabei. Und da sieht das auch deutlich mehr nach Treibern aus. MS-DOS FS, K-EXT, HFS, das ist ja toll. Na toll, Apple. Aber vielleicht schaue ich einfach an einer falschen Stelle. Ja, es gab ja, wo wir gerade bei Fallsystemen sind, gab es ja eine Anfrage, ob wir denn nicht mal diese Konfusion ein bisschen lüften können rund um links.
Und Alias.
Und Alias und so. Kann man eigentlich mal machen, oder? Also es gibt ja deren mehrere und...
Auch bekannteren Namen, Verknüpfung. Für die ganzen...
Bei ganz Märkuligen Betriebssystemen.
Für die ganzen was?
Switcher.
Switcher. Ach so, du meinst, weil das unter Dose so heißt. Verknüpfung, Link.
Aber im englischen Windows heißt das auch links, ne?
Bei Apple heißt das eigentlich nur bei Apple Alias, oder?
Aber in Alias ist ja auch...
Was anderes.
Was anderes. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie sieht das bei den Alias unter Windows aus.
Fangen wir erstmal mit dem GUI an, dann in die Tiefen steigen wir dann später ab.
Man könnte auch von unten nach oben gehen.
Man kann auch ein bisschen technisch sein.
Man sollte mal da anfangen, wo der Hörer mithalten kann.
Nee, wir gehen von unten nach oben, weil man kann eigentlich das wunderbar erklären, was es ist, wenn man von unten nach oben geht.
Aber man könnte auch in der Zeit von hinten nach vorne gehen. Also ich finde, ich bin für die Geschichtsvariante. Weil das hat dann immer so was knisteriges, Kaminfeuermäßiges.
Willst du anfangen?
Muss er ja jetzt.
Es war einmal vor langer Zeit.
Eine Datei.
Die Datei.
Ihr hattet nur einen Namen.
Ein Dateisystem und dieses Dateisystem hieß HFS Hierarchical File System und...
Ach, die Historie.
Ja, die Historie.
Ich dachte jetzt eher so die generelle Historie der Verknüpfung in Betriebssystemen.
Na ja gut, das gehört ja sozusagen mit dazu, weil das ist sozusagen der eine Strang. Und HFS hat halt das Feature eines Alias. Also HFS ist das halt das Ur-McIntosh File System.
Früher gab es das einfach nur das FS, das File System. Das war bei den 400 Kilobyte des Ketten. Und das HFS kam erst mit dem McIntosh Plus.
Ja, ich rede auch von Mc...
Was?
Original Apple McIntosh gab es kein HFS?
Da gab es kein HFS. Der konnte keine Ordner. Ach, wirklich? Das war so ein reingefrickeltes... Also er hatte schon Ordner?
Ist ja wie beim 64er.
Aber du konntest keine Ordner verschachteln, das war nur so notdürftig reingebastelt. Und erst mit dem McIntosh Plus kam dann das Hierarchical File System. Das HFS.
Tatsächlich, McIntosh File System MFS gab es vorher noch.
Das ist jetzt hier der Mobile... Der Mobile Max Mehrwert.
Ich lehne mich jetzt hier gerade so ganz kraftfahrermäßig auf den Tisch drauf, weil ich jetzt gerade mal so Vorteile hatte.
Das wusste ich nicht, das war mir überhaupt nicht bewusst. Ich dachte, sie hätten gleich mit HFS angefangen.
Nee, das kam erst mit den 800 Kilobyte-Ketten.
Okay, na gut, aber das ist ja nun nicht so ein kritischer Zeitraum, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall gab es irgendwann HFS. Und ich schätze mal, auch in MFS dürfte dann wahrscheinlich diese Alias auch noch nicht drin gewesen sein.
Na, ziemlich sicher nicht.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Auf jeden Fall gab es Ordner und es gab natürlich auch diese übliche Geschichte mit ResourceFork und DataFork, dass Dateien sozusagen aus zwei Teilen bestehen können, aus einem ungeordneten und einem geordneten. Und der geordnete enthielt dann auch Programmcode und so weiter, aber das spielt ja keine Rolle. So, und dann gab es eben verschiedene Dateitypen. Unter anderem gab es ein Alias. Und ein Alias war eine symbolische Referenz.
Das kam aber erst mit System 7, falls ich dich kurz korrigieren darf. Aliaser. Also eigentlich schon einige Jahre später.
Das stimmt auch.
Der Mac Plus kam 1986.
Das gab es noch nicht auf System 6, ne?
Nee, nee, das gab es dann nicht.
Guter Hinweis, genau. Also mit System 7 und System 7 kam 1991, 92, 93, ja, irgendwie sowas. Wikipedia weiß ich auch, egal. Auf jeden Fall in System 7 gab es dann Alias. Und ein Alias war eine, ich nenne es mal, eine dynamische Referenz auf eine andere Datei. Das heißt im Fallsystem selber eher wie eine eigene Datei, in der dann der Name und die File ID von der Datei, auf die sich das bezog, drin war.
Ich würde es aus Usersicht beschreiben. Ich finde den Begriff Alias nämlich gar nicht so falsch, weil der Datei war noch unter einem anderen Namen bekannt sozusagen. Wir hatten noch einen Alias.
Genau.
Man konnte einen zweiten Namen für eine und dieselbe Datei anlegen.
Ohne dass der Platz doppelt benutzt wurde.
Genau. Und wenn man das original bearbeitet hat, hat sich das Alias mit geändert.
Genau, aber das Pfiffige war, und das also das Pfiffige von HFS war ja, dass es schon immer diese FileID gab. Und die sozusagen die Datei eindeutig kennzeichnet und die schon immer ja diese Kraft entwickelt hat, dass wenn du eine Datei im Dateisystem verschiebst, dass ein Programm, was diese Datei vorher mal schon geöffnet hat, sie trotzdem findet, auch wenn das Programm wieder neu startet, weil es eben in der Regel über diese Referenznummer darauf zugreift und nicht über den Dateinamen.
Jede Datei und jeder Ordner bekommt noch mal zusätzlich eine Nummer. Das ist wirklich einfach so eine fortlaufende Zahl. Und die kriegt man als Endanwender niemals zu sehen. Aber ein gut geschriebenes, natives Mac-Programm arbeitet eigentlich nur über diese FireRef-Namen ab.
Genau. Und nicht über Dateinamen.
Nee, das stimmt gar nicht.
Das ist ein entscheidender Unterschied zwischen dem Mac und anderen.
Sondern die arbeiten eigentlich intern auch mit Aliassen. Also wenn ich jetzt als Programm zum Beispiel mir, zumindest war es damals so, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es mit Coco ist, aber wenn ich mir damals gemerkt hätte, ich hätte ein Benutzes-Dateien-Menü gemacht, dann hätte ich irgendwo in meiner Preferences-Datei, also in den Einstellungen mit abgespeichert...
Die Referenznummer.
Nee, nicht die Referenznummer, sondern mit System 7 so ein Alias. Du konntest so ein Alias-Handle dir anlegen und da steht mehr als die Referenznummer drinnen. Weil da steht nämlich auch nochmal der Dateiname drin und der komplette Part. Falls ich nämlich in der Zeit die Datei ersetzt haben sollte und es gibt meine Original-Datei gar nicht mehr, sondern es gibt nur noch eine Datei, die aber genauso heißt.
Und die am gleichen Ort liegt.
Und die am gleichen Ort liegt, dann wird in Zukunft wohl die gemeint sein.
Die wird dann halt auch automatisch aufgelöst.
Genau. Diese Alias haben viel viel mehr drinne als nur die Arbeit.
Das geht sogar noch weiter. Es ist ja sogar so, dass der Alias auch Netzwerk-übergreifend funktioniert. Das heißt, wenn du eine Datei-Alias, die auf einem anderen Server liegt, also damals halt AFP über Local Talk, oder später halt auch Ether Talk, und dieser Server ist nicht gemountet und du doppelklickst jetzt diesen Alias oder startest ein Programm, was auf diesen Alias zugreift, dann wird halt sogar der Server automatisch gemountet.
Genau, das war damals eigentlich eine sehr, sehr großartige Technologie.
Der Knaller, ja. Das vermisse ich. Also gut, das gibt das zwar heute noch, aber mit uns ist es nicht mehr so in dem Maße.
Das war ja früher immer das Problem, wenn die irgendwelche QuickTime-Movies aus dem Netz irgendwie zusammengemercht haben, dann dachten sie, alles klar, funktioniert ja prima, sind nach Hause gegangen, wollten den QuickTime-Movie gucken und dann wollte der halt übers Netz auf die eigentliche Datei zu greifen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, weiß er nicht hier.
Das hat aber nichts mit den Aliases zu, sondern es ist nochmal ein QuickTime-Feature, dass du eben Quellenverweis machen kannst. Also eine ganze Menge Dynamik und Indirektionen waren drin. Diese Aliase gibt es natürlich auch so heute noch. Und die kann man ja auch im Final nach wie vor anlegen.
Genau. Aufgrund der Historie gibt es aber noch von Unix.
Jetzt kommt erstmal der nächste Schritt. HFS hat sich dann nochmal weiterentwickelt zu HFS+, mit System... .Mac OS hieß es ja dann. Ich glaube 8.5 hat das eingeführt. Oder 8.6.
Ich glaube 8.1.
Oder 8.1 schon.
Was ist HFS+, 8.1.
Was hatte sich bei 8.5? Irgendwas hatte sich später aber auch nochmal geändert. Oder war das bei 9 dann wie sie... Keine Ahnung, ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall HFS+, war dann sozusagen schon entwickelt worden im Hinblick auf die absehbare Entwicklungsrichtung Unix. Man wusste ja auch, es fehlen einfach bestimmte Features, Dateinnahmenlänge, 31 Zeichen waren nun überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell. Da hat HFS+, das halt dann entsprechend behoben mit 256 Zeichen.
Was aber sehr lustig ist, unter 8.5 konntest du das Dateisystem das, aber das Betriebssystem konntest nicht den langen Dateinamen. Du konntest den Feinern einfach nicht eingeben.
Na gut, aber sie haben es sozusagen schon mal vorgesehen.
Es war geplant.
Vor Later Use und das war ja auch ganz sinnvoll so. Oder auch Character Encoding, das halt in Dateinahme eben nicht mit dem Macintosh-Encoding abgespeichert wird, sondern eben mit Unicode. Auch das war bei HFS Plus vorgesehen.
Na und das Wichtigste eigentlich, die Blockgröße. Weil vorher konnte ja so eine Festplatte oder Diskette nur 32.000 Blöcke haben. Und jeder Datei war automatisch schon mal ein Block groß. Und das war dann schon so geworden, dass irgendwann zu absurden Zeiten, dass dann so eine Datei, auch wenn man nur einen Byte angelegt hat, schon mindestens 96 Kilobyte oder irgendwie so was groß war. Also so absurde Größen.
Es war halt einfach nicht gemacht für die großen Platten. Man musste sich einfach was ändern.
Und man konnte eben nicht mehr als entweder 32.000 oder 65.000 Dateien drauf anlegen. Das wäre heute...
Oh ja, stimmt ja. Das war ja auch noch so eine Limitierung.
Das ist heute euer Wahrscheinlicher.
Eine Chatterbyte Platten wäre dann bei so einem Fallsystem heutzutage in einem Block 30 Megabyte groß.
So, wo waren wir? Genau, wir waren bei den Features, die bei HFS Plus dazugekommen sind. Und was halt auch noch mit dazugekommen ist, generell gesprochen bei HFS Plus, ist sozusagen die Unix Nähe. Das heißt, man hat auch all die Sachen, die bei Unix-Dateisystemen üblich waren, auch mit HFS Plus mit reingebracht. Da gehört schon mal die Dateinnahmenlänge mit 256 Zeichen im Prinzip dazu. So, dass man das Ganze irgendwie auch mit Slash adressieren kann. Also Unix-Dateinnahmenkonventionen hat, während bei Macintosh ja der Ordnertrenner noch ein Doppelpunkt war. Und im Prinzip ja auch heute im OS noch ist. Das wird dann immer so hin und her umgesetzt. Was ich auch gar keine schlechte Idee fand, muss ich sagen. Also der Doppelpunkt ist eigentlich geiler als ein Slash. Weil ein Slash verwende ich sehr häufig in Dateinnahmen, während ich einen Doppelpunkt eigentlich nie in Dateinnahmen verwende. Von daher muss ich sagen, da hat Unix eigentlich schon immer gefailed.
Davon, da kann man ja auch mal Windows eingestehen, dass du vielleicht an dem Punkt mal...
Bitte, jetzt kommen wir nicht mit Backslash.
Ich finde den Backslash zumindest aus deiner Perspektive heraus, den Buchstaben, den ich am selbsten benutze. Noch nie in meinem Leben wollte ich einen Backslash eingeben.
In einem Dateinnahmen? Okay, das mag sein, aber schön ist es trotzdem nicht. Ich finde auch den Slash nicht im eiligen Sinn. Also ein Doppelpunkt wäre cooler gewesen, mal ehrlich.
Ich fand den Doppelpunkt auch cool, ich habe aber...
Aber es ist irgendwie so drin.
Ja, aber man trennt ja auch an anderen Stellen, zum Beispiel unter Unix...
Dann könnte man auch ein Doppelpunkt machen. Eigentlich könnte man es per Komma machen.
Na, wie auch immer. Da hat die Zeit jetzt auch schon drüber gerichtet, ist es jetzt halt einfach der Slash.
Und weil man den Doppelpunkt hast, unter dem alten Mac OS, du hast den ja nie gesehen. Also es war ja alles...
Nein, du hast den nie gesehen.
Du hast ja mit Pfaden nichts getan, und das war ja ein Vorteil, warum Windows so scheiße war. Weil du hast einfach mit Pfaden nichts zu tun gehabt. Du hast immer alles schön klicken können, du musstest nie irgendwo mal ein Pfad eingeben.
Und warum Unix so scheiße war?
Ja, aber da ist es ja wenigstens wieder nur so.
Der Pfad-Terror bei Unix ist ja nun wirklich auch...
Ja, aber gelegentlich sind zu einem doch dann begegnet die Doppelpunkte.
Echt, wo denn?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau wo, aber so wenn ein Programm dann eben mal...
Weil es ist ein schlechter Windows-portierter Software wahrscheinlich, wo man wieder Pfade eingeben musste. Ich glaube auch beim Feinde.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man sich bei einem Alias angeguckt hat, wo das im Original hingeht.
Wenn du versuchst, einen Doppelpunkt in deinen Dateinamen einzugeben, dann hast du es in die Ohren bekommen.
Dann hat er einfach einen Semikolon draus gemacht, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Ja, so habe ich nämlich festgestellt, dass der Doppelpunkt der Dateinahme auch ist.
Wie auch immer. Zurück zu der eigentlichen Frage. So, jetzt haben wir also HFS+, und es war halt Unix näher und das bedeutet, dass es eben auch die gängigen Unix-Dateitypen unterstützen musste und dazu gehören halt auch die sogenannten Symbolic Links, die auch nicht von Anfang an bei Unix immer dabei waren, sondern die in der Unix-Historie auch erst später dazukommen. Jetzt komme ich wieder ein bisschen ins Schwimmen. Ich glaube, mit Symbolic Links haben sie ihren Weg gefunden über SunOS. Symbolic Links sind doch über die BSD-Linie rein. Das gab es nämlich bei System 5 Unix nicht. Das gab es bei Solaris, also SunOS, beziehungsweise generell den BSD-Sachen. Da gab es halt Symbolic Link. Und ein Symbolic Link ist so was ähnliches wie dieser Alias. Nur, dass es eben diese File ID oder File Referenz-Number wie bei HFS so nicht gab. Es gibt da zwar die Ein- und Number, die man theoretisch hätte für so etwas auch nehmen können, die aber dafür nie genommen wurde, weil sie sozusagen nicht als Nummer verwendet wurde im Betriebssystem, um auf Dateien zuzugreifen, sondern die ist nur intern vorhanden, aber sie wurde nie dafür verwendet.
Das heißt, die Grundlage für so einen symbolischen Link war immer nur der Fahrt zum Original. Wenn der Original nicht mehr da war, dann war zwar der symbolische Link noch da, aber er zeigt dabei nichts.
Genau. Das heißt, dir kann es halt da passieren, da wird er auch nicht in irgendeiner Form nachbearbeitet, wenn er auf irgendwas zeigt, was es nicht gibt.
Genau.
Dann fehlt er halt einfach.
Das war 1983, da haben wir das eingeführt, mit BSD, die Symbolik.
Dadurch konntest du aber auch das Original austauschen, löschen und was anderes hinschieben, und der Link war weiterhin gültig. Wenn du das mit einem Alias hier machst, was passiert dann eigentlich? Was passiert, wenn ich einen Alias habe von der Datei und ich lösche das Original? Schau mal einmal aus.
Wenn er nichts findet, dann findet er halt auch nichts.
Dann sagt er, die Datei konnte nicht gefunden werden.
In beiden Fällen gibt es das, nur dass die Vorgehensweise des Betriebssystems komplett anders ist. Beim Symbolik-Link-Datei ist in diesem relativen Namen nicht zu finden, dann fail. Und beim Alias gibt es eben verschiedenste Mechanismen, bis hin zum automatischen Mounten von anderen Fallserver-Volumes, die dann noch aktiviert werden. Und erst wenn das alles nicht klappt, dann ist Schluss.
Also ein Feinde poppt hier so ein Fenster auf, dass das Alias nicht gefunden wurde. Und er bietet mir an, dass ich das Alias löschen kann, das Alias fixen kann oder okay.
Hast du den Dialog vorher noch nie gesehen?
Ja, fixen, das heißt, du kannst dann eben auch gleich andere Datei auswählen, da soll sie halt hin zeigen. Auch ganz sinnvoll. Ja, die Alias unter Mac OS hab ich wirklich geliebt. Das war wirklich so eine Convenience. Heute benutze ich das irgendwie komischerweise fast nicht mehr. Ich weiß gar nicht warum.
Ich glaube, das ist sowieso so ein Phänomen, dass man heutzutage wahrscheinlich aufgrund der Datenmassen, die man hat.
Komisch. Das ist vielleicht daran, dass soviel mit dem Unix-Kram noch arbeitet und solche Alias dann unter Unix wiederum...
Ich glaube, damit hat es gar nichts zu tun. Ich hab damals mein System komplett anders organisiert, als ich es heute tue.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das ist, wenn die Mac OS-Aliase auf Unix... So, jetzt haben wir also Symbolic Links und die Aliase. Und jetzt gibt es ja noch diesen Hard Link. Den hatten wir auch schon mal im Gespräch. Mit Time Machine, wo er sozusagen wieder zu neuen Ehren gekommen ist. Und ein Hard Link ist zunächst einmal nichts anderes als diese Einode. Also die Einode ist die interne Nummer der Datei in einem Unix-Dateisystem. Sprich, verweisen zwei Namen in einem Verzeichnis auf dieselbe Einode, dann handelt es sich um dieselbe Datei. Und sowas kann man eben erstellen durch einen Hardlink. Also serienmäßig gibt es immer Directories, zum Beispiel, haben immer zwei Einträge. Das ist nämlich Punkt Punkt.
Achso, innerhalb von sich selbst.
Also deswegen haben Directories halt immer zwei Hardlinks, weil es halt immer so das Verzeichnis darüber zeigt auf seinen Parent und er zeigt natürlich auf sich selbst. Bei einer normalen Datei, wenn du eine normale Datei anlegst, dann hat sie halt einen Link. Und du kannst aber dann eben mit dem LN-Kommando auch noch einen zweiten Link anstellen. Also LN, mit dem machst du ja auch die Symbolic-Links, mit LN-S machst du halt einen Symbolic-Link, aber ohne Minus-S machst du halt einen normalen Link. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt die Datei Foo habe und dann mache ich irgendwie einen Link auf die Datei Bar, dann habe ich halt zwei Einträge in meinem Verzeichnis, die aber auf dieselbe physikalische Datei verweisen.
Also vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen zu erklären, weil ich glaube, das kam jetzt noch nicht so ganz rüber. Bei so einem Symbolic Link hat man tatsächlich, man hat eine Originaldatei, in Anführungsstrichen.
Und etwas anderes, was wie ein String darauf zeigt.
Was darauf zeigt, sozusagen ein Zeiger, der steht irgendwo rum und da ist ein wegweiß Schild und wenn man das Original löscht, dann zeigt der Zeiger ins Nix.
Also immer noch den gleichen Fahrt, nur da ist halt nichts mehr.
Genau, da zeigt er zwar weiter, da steht dieses Schild, da geht's lang, aber da ist halt nichts mehr.
Und ein Hardlink ist die eigentliche, wie das Dateisystem funktioniert. Also du brauchst einfach überhaupt erstmal einen Verweis auf die eigentliche Datei, die eben durch die I-Note, also eine Nummer repräsentiert wird und dein Eintrag in deinem Verzeichnis ist der Hardlink darauf.
Und das führt dazu, wenn ich zwei Hardlinks irgendwo rumliegen habe, dann gibt es kein Original und keinen Verweis mehr.
Genau, die sind vollständig identisch.
Egal welche Seite ich lösche, die andere Seite funktioniert, aber es ist trotzdem derselbe Datei.
Hatte er denn einen Referenz-Counter?
Die müssen noch nicht mal in derselben, ja. Du siehst immer, wie viele Links es gibt. Das ist in der Einung verwirkt. Das ist ja auch eine Beschränkung. Wenn du LS machst, na wenn es null ist, ist gelöscht.
Ich mein, ich muss ja eine Beschränkung geben, weil die nur 32 Bit für die Anzahl der Links nehmen.
Nur rein so theoretisch. Ja, gibt es, aber praktisch ist das, glaube ich, kein Limit, wo man jetzt wirklich drunter leidet. Ja, so, und diese Hardlinks sind eigentlich ein Problem, weil sie ja auch eine Menge Schindluder machen können. Du kannst halt zwei Namen in vollkommen unterschiedlichen Verzeichnissen haben, die auf dieselbe Datei verweisen. Und da eben diese Hardlinks auch für Verzeichnisse benutzt werden, hat man das aber sozusagen für das Loserland.
Na, für Verzeichnisse hat erst Apple das eingeführt, oder?
Nein, was ich meine ist, technisch, also wie das Dateisystem aufbaut. Du siehst ja, wenn du so ein Directory hast, der hat ja zwei Links, aber du kannst halt keine Links auf Directories, keine Hardlinks auf Directories anlegen. Und das haben sie halt gemacht, um eben so zirkuläre Strukturen im Verzeichnissystem zu verhindern. Deswegen gibt es das nicht.
Ich meine, die Hardlinks führen ja schon mal zu ziemlich absurden Sachen. Also man könnte ja zum Beispiel, man hat eine 8 GB Platte, legt da eine 6 GB Datei drauf. Und legt nochmal eine 6 GB Datei drauf. Dann wird einem der Finder-Tap veranzeigen, dass man 12 GB auf seiner 8 GB Platte belegt wird.
Weiß ich nicht, ob der Finder das wirklich tut. Oder ob er nicht die Annoten auch irgendwie auflöst.
Also zumindest, wenn man Ordnergröße bereitet...
Können wir gleich mal ausprobieren, weiß ich nicht.
Wenn man so verschiedene Ordner liest, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Also ich hab mich durchrechnen lassen bei der Time Machine, die ja Hardlinks verwendet. Und er zeigt dann tatsächlich für jeden Time Machine Ordner die eigene Größe an. Die eigene Größe an.
Stimmt, richtig, du hast recht. Genau. Okay, stimmt. Und das macht nämlich keinen Sinn. Sollten wir jetzt sozusagen nochmal erklären. Also HFS Plus hat halt einerseits Sachen übernommen, wie sie bei Unix schon immer waren. Symbolic Link und überhaupt generell dieses Prinzip des Hardlinks und der Einod, was dann eben genauso funktioniert und nicht so wie früher bei HFS. Auch wenn es da eben Kompatibilitätslehrer noch gab. Und andererseits haben sie aber auch gesagt, wir wollen Hardlinks aber auch für Directories haben. Und wir nehmen dieses Risiko in Kauf. Können das aber dann eben für andere Sachen nutzen. Und das haben sie dann eben das erste Mal wirklich zum Einsatz gebracht mit Time Machine, wo es auch einfach total sinnvoll ist. Weil du eben in zwei, wenn du halt zwei Verzeichnisse hast, die beide eben ein Backup sind von einer anderen Quelle. Und da hat sich halt eine Datei nicht geändert. Dann legst du halt einfach nochmal einen weiteren Hardlink in der anderen Directory Struktur darauf an. Und du kannst das eben auch für komplette Verzeichnisse machen. Das heißt, wenn ein kompletter Baum sich nicht geändert hat, dann kannst du eben einfach auf dieses Verzeichnis linken und musst eben nicht eine Million weitere Hardlinks für alle eine Million Dateien, die da drin sind, anlegen, sondern nur einen einzigen Link für eben diesen Top-Level.
Eine Datei-Operation, die nur einmal Platz auf der Platte weglässt.
Also das ist eigentlich total klug, wenn man das halt Content hat irgendwie und die Benutzer davon abhalten kann, schlimme Sachen zu machen. Kann man zwar machen, aber du weißt ja, wie häufig auf dem Mac Aktivitäten auf der Kommando-Zeile entfaltet werden. In der Regel nicht.
Softlink macht man in der Kommando-Zeile übrigens mit dem Kommando LN und dann als Option Minus S. Und was man sich immer merken muss, weil ich muss auch jedes Mal mich immer wieder darauf konzentrieren, man gibt zuerst das Original einer, also was schon existiert, und danach den Namen vom Softlink. Und nicht andersrum, nicht so von hier dorthin zeigen, sondern erst das, wo es hin zeigt, und dann den Namen, den der Link haben soll. Oder man kann den Namen weglassen, und dann ist der Link automatisch der Name, wie das Original, dann kann man sich das abkürzen, weil meistens benutzt man ja schon denselben Namen.
Eigentlich voll logisch, ich muss mich aber auch wie jedes Mal darauf konzentrieren.
Ja, das ist so wie bei Copy und bei MV halt.
Stimmt eigentlich. Eigentlich ist es absolut logisch.
Ja, ich werde gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass HFS doch in Source vorhanden ist. Ich hab nur im falschen Direktoriegel geguckt. Es ist natürlich innerhalb des Kernels und außerhalb des Kernels gesucht.
Apple hat was schon lange gemacht, was ich gerade gesagt habe, was sie mal machen sollten.
Ja, ja, nee, das ist halt da. Und ich verstehe auch nicht, warum das keiner nimmt. Aber das ist ja dann in der Regel immer so die Forderung, dass man das dann in Linux einbaut. Und das kannst du natürlich nicht in Linux einbauen, weil es halt WSD lizenziert ist.
Tja, die haben sich so selber ins Knie geschossen.
Aber das brauchen wir ja eigentlich nie ausdiskutieren.
Ich hab mal nachgeguckt.
Ich finde, wir haben das jetzt relativ erschöpfend behandelt, diesen Bereich, oder? Nein, noch nicht.
Im Endeffekt gibt es noch ein bisschen hinterher.
Wirklich?
Und so habe ich nachguckt, der Counter, der die Referenzen zählt, den gibt es halt wirklich. Und bei NTFS ist der 10-Bit groß. Das heißt, die können maximal 1023 Hardlinks auf einen Pfeil haben. Und bei den Unix-Systemen steht hier, dass er meistens die Größe der Architektur hat, also 32 oder 64 Bit. Wobei ich das auch nicht ganz glauben kann, weil das ist ja im Pfeilsystem festgenagelt und ein 64 Bit muss ja trotzdem ein 32 Bit Pfeilsystem lesen können und andersrum, deswegen denke ich, man wird es 32 Bit sein.
Ja, vermutlich. Mindestens auf jeden Fall.
Ja, und 4 Milliarden Links auf die gleiche Datei ist eh schon ganz schön bescheuert.
Das kriegt man ja nie voll.
Aber mehr als 1023 Backups vom gleichen Tag, wo dann das Time-Maschine, das wäre schon möglich und das wäre schon ein Limit.
Ja.
Obwohl der löscht dann auch irgendwann die einzelnen Tage und hebt dann nur noch die Wochen auf.
Na gut, aber du musst ja nicht Tage machen, du kannst ja auch Stunden machen. Beziehungsweise macht er ja auch.
Ja, löscht er dich auch irgendwann später raus und nimmt die feilen Stunden weg.
Na gut, aber erst wenn kein Platz mehr ist, wenn du genug Platz hast.
Nee, die Stunden löst er schon vorher auf.
Nach einer Woche.
Dann hebt er nur noch wöchentlich auf und die Wochen irgendwann auf und schaltet monatlich um und so weiter.
1000 Wochen ist schon viel.
20 Jahre.
Ja, das reicht.
Aber was sich daran jetzt mal ganz lustig macht.
Aber dass es halt nur wie Time Machine ist macht. Du kannst dir natürlich ein Backup-Modell vorstellen, was es eben nicht so macht und dass du eben wirklich jede Stunde einen Backup machst und dann geht das doch spürbar schneller voran als tausend Wochen. Tausend Stunden dauern nie lang. Windows fail, Lattenzaun fail.
Was jetzt aber ganz lustig ist, ist, dass Windows dann mit Windows 95 diese, werden wir schon verweise mal erwähnen, eingeführt hat, dass dann quasi ja auch sowas wie die Links oder die Alias war.
Verknüpfung.
Verknüpfung, genau. Das hast du schon wieder gesagt. Und die waren dann aber wieder so wie unter Unix und nicht so wie bei Mac. Sie haben dann probiert, irgendwie so diese Intelligenz drauf zu flanschen, dass er dann angefangen hat, nämlich wenn er die Original-Datei nicht mehr gefunden hat unter dem Pfad, hat er nämlich intern angefangen so eine Suche und dann hast du da so 4 Stunden gewartet, bis er deine Festplatte durchsucht hatte. Kennt bestimmt noch jeder diesen Dialog, wo dann so diese dämliche Lupe am rumrotieren war. Weil die es offensichtlich nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt haben, das einfach mal so geschickt zu machen wie Apple, obwohl sie 4 Jahre vorher schon das Vorbild hatten.
Und gehen jetzt die Stream-Hörer aus? Geht's schon abwärts? Gehen alle schlafen jetzt?
Ich auch.
Wollen wir langsam?
Wo ist der Band hier? Darf ich da drauf drücken?
Wenn wir schon mal beim Thema sind, absolute und relative Simlinks. Danach hat er nämlich auch gefragt.
Absolut und relative?
Ach, ihr wisst das jetzt gar nicht.
Ach so, naja, das ist halt vom Pfad. Kannst du halt einen absoluten Pfad in deinem Softlink nehmen oder einen relativen?
Das wäre jetzt auch meine Vermutung.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst hier...
Jaja, klar. Das ist einfach nur ein Pfad.
Also absolut ist halt, wenn Slash vorne dran ist. Ganz einfach. Dann geht er halt vom Route aus und wenn nicht, dann kannst du ja auch deinen Link mit Punktpunkt beginnen lassen. Dann ist der Link immer in dem Ordner da drüber.
Also das hätte, also wenn man zum Beispiel...
Das ist so etwas, was halt mit Aliasen nie ging.
Relative, sozusagen relative, also...
So ein relativer Alias, sowas gab es halt nicht.
Geht ja auch nicht, weil er verfolgt das ja.
Nee, nee, Moment mal, ich glaube, das ging. Also es ist, wenn du sozusagen...
Also zumindest mal sowas nicht im Feinde anlegen, aber du kannst vielleicht dramatisch machen?
Du kannst nicht aber, naja, so weit reichte die Intelligenz da noch. Also wenn du irgendwie, du hast eine Datei genommen und hast eine Alias genommen und hast das dann auf eine damals noch das Kette geschmissen und hast es dann an einen anderen Rechner reingeschoben, dann funktioniert dir dieses Alias immer noch. Bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Wenn du es guckierst, dann, ja, das ist ja auch was anderes. Relativ zum Fallsystem, aber so relativ zum Ordner.
Und wenn man es relativ...
I don't know.
Ich glaube, der hat erstaunlich viel hingekriegt. Ich hab mal, kann mal jemand ausbuddeln. Es gibt einen sehr, sehr langen CT-Artikel nur zum Thema Alias unter System 7.
Wir sind jetzt hier auch schon langsam so ein Vintage-Podcast. So, was haben wir denn jetzt noch? Was habt ihr denn noch so auf der Uhr?
Transmission 1.6 kam raus. Aber da ja alle Auto-Updates haben, interessiert das ja auch kein Schwein mehr.
Ja, aber was war denn da drin?
An Updates.
An Features.
Hab ich auch noch nicht so richtig entdeckt. Nichts wirklich Tolles. Nee.
Transmission ist wahrscheinlich das Programm, was du am häufigsten benutzt, oder?
Nicht am häufigsten, dauernd.
Am ausdauernsten.
Ja, da lädt sich doch immer die Lieblingsdistribution runter.
Wisst ihr übrigens, was ich an dem ganz neuen MacBook Pro jetzt extrem schick finde, ist, dass dieser Helligkeitssensor, der mich ja immer so aufgeregt hat, der bei dir ist ja hier noch in Lautsprecher drin.
Der ist jetzt bei dir da oben.
Der ist bei mir da oben. Das heißt, ich kann endlich einschalten, dass die automatische Helligkeit, dass die Display-Helligkeit sich automatisch ändert. Und normalerweise beim Tippen, wenn ich nicht tippe, dann lege ich immer die Hände auf die Lautsprecher drauf und dann wird das Display jedes Mal dunkel. Das war so nervig. Da gehört es hin. Und ich glaube, da oben ist auch das Mikro, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Das heißt, man kann endlich tippen ohne...
Du hast ja Glossi jetzt, ne?
Glossi hatte ich ja schon vorher. Ich auch. Ich hatte schon vorher Glossi, aber ich glaube, das ist nochmal Glossier als Glossier.
Inzwischen gab es schon mal irgendwann einen Tag, da hat es mich voll abgestresst, da hatte ich wirklich so eine böse Reflektion drin. Aber so im Großen und Ganzen finde ich es trotzdem cooler. Aber ich glaube, das will jetzt auch gar keiner mehr wissen.
Nee.
Glossi vs. Non-Glossi.
Das hätten wir vorhin schon bringen müssen. Jetzt sind wir eigentlich schon so voll in Unix und Fallsysteme. Dazu könnten wir nochmal kurz ein Update liefern. Dennis, du hast da was rausgefunden. ZFS und Snow Leopard.
Wie sieht es aus?
Hat sich das gemutmaßt?
Da hat ja dein Gloss eine neue Gerüchtequelle. Da hat deine neue Gerüchtequelle dir gesagt, dass ja in dem Bild 10A314 wohl kein ZFS mehr dabei ist. Das wurde mir zugetragen, dass das so stimmt. Also kann ich es sozusagen bestätigen. Zwei unabhängige Quellen. Und dann habe ich das getwittert und dann hat mir jemand zurückgetwittert, dass in der nächsten Version, in der 10A335, dass da auch kein ZFS bei ist. Das heißt, da sind jetzt schon zwei Bilds da draußen, wo kein ZFS mit dabei ist. Also weder die Kernel Extension noch die Tools dafür. Also ZFS und Zpool und so weiter. Und jetzt gibt es ja inzwischen schon wieder einen noch neueren Bild. 10A300, schlag mich tot, 54 oder so was, in den 50ern irgendwo. Und da müssten wir jetzt mal wieder die Infos abwarten. Ich hab schon so ein bisschen befürchtet, dass ZFS aus Leopard verschwinden wird. Weil so kurz vorher, weil es ja jetzt schon, langsam werden sie ja mal fertig. Das so rauszunehmen ist ja schon ein bisschen verdächtig.
Ich hab auch gehört, dass es einen AP-Freeze gegeben haben soll.
Ja, mit dem letzten Bild jetzt wohl. Und deswegen bin ich auf die Apple-Werbe-Seite sozusagen gegangen von Snow Leopard Server. Weil da stand ja unten immer ZFS dabei. Und da steht es aber immer noch. Und ich hab vorhin auch noch mal geguckt, da steht es auch immer noch. Das heißt, wenn sie, denke ich, mal diese Entscheidung getroffen hätten, dass sie ZFS komplett rausschmeißen, hätten sie ihre Webseite geändert. Weil das muss ja dann wirklich überall verschwinden. Und das ist aber noch nicht geschehen. Ich hab sozusagen noch Hoffnung. Und wenn auch nur ein Server kommt, ist es mir auch egal. Weil ich denke, man kann die...
Also sie müssen es ja zumindest Read-Only wieder reinbringen.
Warum?
Na, weil sie das jetzt auch schon drin haben.
Na, ich trau Apple zu, da auch einen kompletten Rückzieher zu machen.
Das glaub ich nicht. Doch.
Ich trau denen das zu. Glauben ist erst mal noch was ganz anderes, aber ich trau...
Nein, das glaub ich nicht, dass sie sich das selber zutrauen wollen. Also, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Also, mein Tipp ist, Mac OS 10 Server Snow Leopard kommt mit Read Free ZFS und All Features On. Und der Kleine kommt mit Read Only und kann dasselbe Format lesen.
Und kann natürlich sein, dass ich es dann mit 10, 6, 1, 2, 3...
Genau, schalten sie es ein. Machen sie es einschaltbar.
War ja mit dem Journaling auch so, ne?
Ja, das passt irgendwie auch. Und du kannst wahrscheinlich es auch irgendwie separat runterladen. Ich bin da nicht wirklich in Panik. Ich denke mir, dass sie schon auch selber wissen, was das bedeutet, das ZFS. Das muss man ihnen nicht erklären.
So, kleines Tipp mit am Rande. Jetzt weiß ich jetzt den Namen. Triklops hat ein schönes Tweetpick geschickt, wie er gerade sein Samsung Fernseher aktualisiert.
Aufgrund unserer Beschreibung. Hier gibt es noch eine schöne Nachricht. Da haben wir jetzt Snow Leopard und iPhone mal wieder in einem Tisch. Oh Gott, jetzt muss ich gleich nochmal nachdenken. Ich hatte hier, da gab es einen schönen Artikel bei Roughly Drafted, der sozusagen beschreibt, wie Snow Leopard Server dann eben auch als iPhone Server sozusagen verwendet werden kann.
Das wäre immer für kleine Firmen ganz cool.
Das wäre für kleine Firmen ganz cool. Das wäre eigentlich auch so selber cool. Ich meine, das ist eigentlich immer noch so ein bisschen zu teuer, sich selber irgendwie einen Mac Server hinzustellen.
Ja, eben deswegen für kleine Firmen.
Das finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen schade. Also, dass man wirklich so gut, ich meine, was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst ja natürlich einen Mac OS X Server kaufen und auf den Mac Mini schmeißen und den hosten.
Das ist ja teuer.
Was? Mac OS X Server?
Das ist ganz schön teuer für eine One-Man-Show. Aber man kann sich natürlich mehrere Leute zusammenlegen und das machen. Ich kauf mir keine 500 Euro, damit ich irgendwie ein bisschen VPN für mein iPhone hab oder so.
Naja, das geht auch mit einem Linux.
Aber du hast halt 500 Euro, um irgendwie einen Server zu haben, mit dem du den Kalender-Server, einen Web-Server, einen SMTP-Server, einen IMAP-Server, vielleicht eben auch einen VPN-Server mit aufbauen kannst im Netz, der halt so mit GUI daherkommt und einfach aufzusetzen ist. Also da steckt ja schon eine ganze Menge drin. Alles brauche ich. Nee, das ist klar, wenn du es nicht brauchst. Aber es gibt ja auch mal die Advanced-User. Und was kotzen wir immer über Mobile-Me? Weil, naja, das eine oder andere will man ja schon haben, aber dann eben nicht bei Apple gesurft und schon gar nicht zu diesen Stabilitätsbedingungen und schon gar nicht zu dem Preis.
Und schon gar nicht ohne Krypto.
Und wenn halt, sagen wir mal, das Fünffache, was kostet Mobile-Me jetzt nochmal im Jahr?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
99 Dollar oder so, 79 Euro. Fürs Fünffache hast du dann sozusagen einfach deinen eigenen Server mal.
Ja, aber man sollte sich von dem Mac OS und dem Mac OS Server nicht zu sehr blenden lassen. Das ist nicht leicht, das Ding einzurichten. Also es war bestimmt leichter.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal Mac OS Server wirklich mal versucht, so richtig von 5 auf 5 hochzuziehen? Mit 10.5? Und war es immer noch schlimm?
Es war immer noch... also ich hab's so richtig intensiv genutzt. Habe ich es mit 10.4, glaube ich. Ja, mit 10.4 war das. Das war... also für die Features, die ich haben wollte, war es okay. Also wenn man nur das genutzt hat, wofür es Gui gab, dann war das so verhältnismäßig einfach.
Das ist nicht für Advanced Setups. Aber...
Also was ich z.B. total nervig fand, das war mit dem 10.5er, da musste man irgendwo ein Domain Name eingeben für das Ding. Und dann musst du es einmal bei der Installation machen und da habe ich irgendeinen Namen erst mal eingegeben. So erst mal, kann ich danach erinnern?
Dann kannst du den nicht erinnern?
Du kannst den nie wieder erinnern.
Auch bei 10.4 noch?
Bei 10.5.
Bei 10.5 noch?
Das hat mich schon bei 10.3 so genervt.
Und dann das Betriebssystem komplett neu aufsetzen, weil ich einen Domädennamen ändern will, das kann es irgendwie eigentlich nicht sein.
Ne, das stimmt. Echt, das haben sie immer noch nicht in den Griff gekriegt?
Ein bisschen dir sicher?
Du hast den Weg nicht gefunden.
Ich hab zumindest keine Lösung gefunden.
Das ist ja auch schon mal eine Aussage.
Also so richtig toll fand ich das nicht.
Ne, sowas ist nicht gut.
Das ist nicht gut.
Das ist aber auch so ein generelles Problem. In den wenigsten Unix-Systemen ist es gelungen, gute Admin-Interfaces bereitzustellen. Und der Mac hat es ja zumindest für so einen Desktop-User hinbekommen. Also für Desktop-Konfiguration, denke ich mal, haben sie es gerorgt und jetzt versuchen sie es halt seit längerer Zeit auch schon mit dem Server. Aber wir wissen alle, wie groß die Interdependenzen so sein können mit all dem, was man so aufsetzt. Und wenn sich was ändert, und ich hatte auch schon ähnlichen Troubles mit sich ändernden IP-Adressen und so weiter. Das ist auch schon irgendwie so ein Elend gewesen. Keine Ahnung, ob sie da Fortschritte gemacht haben. Letztlich musst du halt alles änderbar machen, aber du hast halt da einfach, hängt immer ein riesen Wust dran. Interfaces, bla bla bla, Routing-Konfiguration, VPN, IP-Adressen stehen, müssen überall irgendwie doppelt und dreifach drinstehen. Insoweit, als dass du eben Open-Source-Software verwendest, die eben alle ihre unterschiedlichen Konfigurationsdateien haben und so weiter. Und das dann alles zu propagieren, das ist ja das Problem. Andererseits gehen sie ja auch Schritte, um in zunehmendem Maße einheitliche Directory-Services zu verwenden, die dann in zunehmendem Maße auch als Konfigurationsquelle bedienen für diese ganzen Sachen. Aber das ist halt alles noch nicht so weit, dass man sagen kann, jetzt geht das mal ganz easy.
Naja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich drin ist. Wer schon mal unter Linux einen Mail-Server konfiguriert hat, das ist ja schon, was da alles konfigurierbar ist. Das ist ja nicht, dass sie nicht wollen, dass man das nicht bedienen kann, sondern es gibt halt viele verschiedene Anwendungsfülle für Mail-Server.
Und jetzt Mail-Server im Sinne von Mail-Versenden-Server?
Reiner SMTP-Server. Postfix, nehmen wir mal Postfix als Beispiel. Ob man den als Relay laufen lassen will, ob der vielleicht seine Mails direkt weiterleiten soll an eine andere IP. Ob man irgendeine Route hat, dass man zum Beispiel interne Mails woanders leitet als externe Mails. Das ist schon so ein relativ simpler Fall. Klingt erst mal simpel, muss nur Mails verschicken, nicht mal empfangen, sondern wirklich nur verschicken.
Das ist komplex. Und dann noch der ganze Spam-Kack dazu.
Das ist einfach ein komplexes Problem. Und da wird man wahrscheinlich, egal ob mit der Maus oder mit auf der Kommandozeile im Text, komplexe Lösungen für brauchen. Ich weiß nicht, ob da richtig ein Weg dran vorbeiführt.
Ich finde, das muss alles beherrschbar sein. Das kann ja nicht ewig so weitergehen, dass Serverbetrieb im Internet komplex und schwierig ist. Weil ich will das halt auch selber. Von daher wäre es mir sozusagen auch die Investition in einen Mac OS X Server wert. Ich weiß, dass nicht jeder selber das so machen würde. Aber wenn ich ehrlich gesagt so am Ende des Tages, wenn es so für 500 Euro eine Lösung gibt, wo ich dann eben keinen eigenen Administrator brauche, sondern dieser Administrator selber sein kann, ohne selber sendmail.cf schreiben zu können. Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen überspitzt dargestellt, aber you know what I mean.
Also die Sendmail-Konfektation muss man auch unterliegen.
Ja, aber it's a jungle out there. Du musst wirklich extrem viele Dinge kennen und du musst vor allem bei extrem vielen Dingen irgendwie auch up-to-date bleiben, weil sich permanent die Rahmenbedingungen ändern. Gerade beim Mail mit diesem ganzen Spam und Blocken und Blacklist und diesem ganzen Scheiß.
Irgendwelche Lücken, die das ganze System hat.
Ja, furchtbar. Software aktualisieren und so. Das willst du alles nicht sein. Du willst einfach so eine Büchse haben, auf dem der Scheiß läuft. Da bin ich auch bereit, auf eine gewisse Setup-Komplexität zu verzichten, wenn ich dafür einfach erst mal Mail habe. Und zwar meine eigene Mail. Auf meinem eigenen Server, mit meinen eigenen Security-Bedingungen und vor allem, ich bin mein eigener Provider und hab nicht irgendeinen anderen Provider, der dann meine Daten an irgendwelche dreibuchstabigen Organisationen gibt, wenn die mal zufällig einen Fax schicken.
Also meine Erfahrung damals mit diesem Mac OS 10 Server war eben die, ja, man kann eine Menge mit einer relativ shiny GUI-Oberfläche machen, aber die ist auch nicht wirklich gut durchdacht. Also die ist nicht so gut durchdacht wie irgendwie ein gut durchdachtes Apple-Programm, sagen wir mal irgendwie so Numbers oder so durchdachtes, sondern ein gut durchdachtes Apple-Programm.
Sowas gibt's?
Ja, mir fällt jetzt aber, so ein einfach zu bedienendes Teil ist, sondern das ist schon alles, hat eine hohe Komplexität und sobald man ein bisschen mehr machen will als das von Apple vorgegebene, ist man ganz, ganz schnell wieder da, wo man bei einem Linux auch ist. Ohne, dass es die entsprechenden Binaries gibt, ohne dass es eine Paketverwaltung gibt. Also eigentlich ist man relativ flott, fand ich zumindest, mit einem Linux oder wahrscheinlich auch mit einem BSD besser bedient als mit einem Mac OS X Server.
Kann schon sein, aber ich hätte es einfach ganz gerne mal... Ich meine, ich habe ganz gute Erfahrungen mit Mac OS X Server in der Uni und so, auch so mit so großen Account-Databases für Studenten und so. Die haben dann so ihre Home-Direktorie und so dieses ganze Setup, das ist halt schnell gemacht. Aber Mail, naja.
Gibt es zum Beispiel Time Machine für Mac OS X Server mittlerweile mal? Ich glaube immer noch nicht, oder?
Ähm, haben sie es da nicht drin?
Ich, also so einfach, dass du, dass, dass, dass, das, ähm, dass...
Also, dass das Mac OS X Server als Server oder als, was meinst du?
Na, das ist erstmal, also erstmal, das ist, ähm, ne, das ist...
Dass es sich selbst back ab...
Dass es sich selbst darüber back ab, also...
Ist es da nicht drin?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich glaube nicht.
Nee, letztes Mal mit 10.2 benutzt.
Wir sind schon wieder auf dünnem Eis. Wir reden über Sachen, die wir nicht wissen. Aber wir freuen uns über das Feedback und dann können wir nächstes Mal, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen wieder weiter reden. So.
Genau.
Diese Sendung ist übrigens jetzt schon fast drei Stunden lang. Ich hab jetzt hier noch so ein paar Sachen auf meiner Liste, aber ich muss sagen, darf ich jetzt nicht mehr drüber reden.
Die letzte Snow Leopard-Bild 10A3-54 hat auch keinen ZFS-Hörche. Wurde mir zugeschoben.
Wurde dir zugeschoben. Mir wurde ja auch gerade was zugeschoben, nämlich dass es dann ein Paket geben soll, mit dem man das dann nachinstallieren kann. Wurde mir zugeschoben. Haben wir gehört, meinen wir glauben zu können, weil andere Leute glauben.
Wollen wir Schluss machen? Ich möchte mal ein MacBook streicheln.
Das sind wirklich belastbare Fakten hier bei Mobile Max, dem Quasselfunk.
Die wir niemals Gerüchte verbreiten.
Nein.
Aber merkst du, wir kriegen jetzt langsam schon so Infos zugetragen. Es wird langsam.
Wir werden jetzt so Insider-Typen. Oder wir können noch fauler sein mit der Vorbereitung des...
Nee, aber sowas nützt dem, der Information hat, wenn er so nicht verbreiten kann.
Ja, das stimmt.
So und über uns kann er sozusagen voll zur Geltung kommen, dann kann er seinen Kumpel sagen, guck mal hier, die verbreiten gerade, die haben die Infos nämlich von mir bekommen. Also mal her mit den Infos, wir geben die weiter und ihr seid dann die coolen Jungs.
Wir sind sozusagen das Wikileaks der McIntosh-Szene.
Und ich meine, ich selber hab keinen Apple NDA auf dieses OS, könnte theoretisch berichten, nur hab ich halt auch die Builds nicht. Andere Leute haben die Builds, dürfen nicht berichten, aber können ja uns anonym so ein paar Sachen ja mal rüberschieben. Machen ja alle anderen auch so. Und Apple hat ja auch was davon am Ende.
Rufst du jetzt zu Straftaten auf oder was?
Zu Vertragsbruch. Nur zu nicht beweisbaren Straftaten.
Dennis, du schwere Nöter. Na, wie auch immer. Ja, haben wir's, oder?
Ja, das können wir doch mal.
Gut, magst du mal jetzt dein MacBook streicheln? Dafür hab ich Verständnis. Dennis streichelt das schon die ganze Zeit.
Du bist zu alt, da wird nix mehr gestreichelt.
Und meins werde ich nachher noch ein bisschen prügeln.
Das Schwarze steht da drauf, ne?
Das Schwarze will das. Er braucht das auch. Damit er richtig läuft. Okay, das war's. Bis bald.
Unterschreib die Petition, falls du es noch nicht hast.
Ja genau.
Genau.